dire le fait que rohff et de
l'opposition à franco de la france de la
suisse ou des états unis la même chose
c'est l'opposition où se lit donc ça je
pense que la réponse elle pâtit de la
question la question de l'antisémitisme
est complexe et simple à la fois
aujourd'hui tous les chercheurs même
ceux qui sont sur des positions très
différentes en ce qui concerne le
coefficient
d'antisémitisme successifs du régime
reconnaissent qu'au début le fascisme
italia et non seulement mu souligna
parce qu'il ya fashizblack et au delà de
mesures mais elle eu probablement le
seul mouvement d'extrême droite nous
l'avons qualifié d'extrême droite dans
notre conversation précédente qui n'a
pas de composante antisémite même les
anglais de la blake unyon des fascistes
de mosler automne éléments antisémite
qui n'est pas aussi prononcée que
d'autres ne parlons pas de ce qui se
passe en europe centrale et balkanique
alors ce qui fait que de coeur ou deux
raisons il y a une participation il y à
une acceptation d'une partie au moins de
la composante juive de la société
italienne qui est comme dans tous les
pays d'europe surévalué de son bled de
son plein droit par ses mérites
intellectuels professionnels et autres
mousseux lily lui même à trois ou quatre
ministres qui sont des technocrates
d'origine juive surtout dans les
finances et le trésor dans les années 30
40 et les assurent entre 20 et à ce
moment là ce qui se passe en 38 est un
crime particulièrement abject parce que
au fond rien ne l'annoncé qu'est ce que
vous entendez par 38 parce que quelqu'un
s'est notamment par nous y aller mais le
moment où enfin 38 avec une progression
qui ce vaisseau de deux ou trois mois
d'entre eux août septembre octobre vient
introduites des lois antisémites
qui sont d'ailleurs des lois également
porteuses de restriction 10 à vis des
autres confessions les protestants sont
également touchés la petite mais très
forte intellectuellement très développée
communauté protestante italienne est
également touché et ce sont des lois de
marginalisation sociale et progressive
qui ne sont pas si vous voulez des
doigts de leur mère mais qui
certainement à partir de 38 m les juifs
italia dans la situation de citoyens de
deuxième ordre et de ce point de vue là
c'est également l'autorisation par la
corruption pour une passation de domaine
de richesse de biens matériels et autres
lots
c'est vraiment la page incontestablement
la plus abominable du régime sur le plan
militaire on voit
mussolini comme un très mauvais chefs de
guerre pas d'ailleurs pas très moderne
là non plus les italiens comme un peuple
qui n'a pas du tout envie de se battre à
ce moment là et au fond les campagnes
militaires italiennes comme une
succession de catastrophes c'est pas du
tout c'est pas du tout vrai en 40 41
contrairement à une image qui a été
également comporter par une certaine
résistance du fasciste on peut le
comprendre les motivations et par nous
allons le beh oui mais non mais le pays
s'est battu enfin et après tout écouter
deux porte-avions anglaises ont été
coulés par les italiens je lançais pas
de que d'autres pays aient fait de même
donc finalement le pays jusqu'en 41 à la
fin de 41 c'est pas long mais c'est un
an et demi en afrique sur d'autres
fronts évidemment il y à la déconfiture
ans d'abord en france
terrible et puis et puis sur le front de
graisse et d'albanie mais les positions
se reprennent en yougoslavie donc la
situation tient encore ce qui évidemment
change complètement la donne c'est la
guerre d'abord contre la russie et puis
contre les états unis c'est quand même
une armée mais l'équipe et c'est une âme
est mal équipée mais qui a des positions
de force et qui tient encore
raisonnablement même après tenez le
débarquement sicile le débat comme en
sicile qui d'ailleurs provoquera la fin
du régime donc nous sommes au début de
juillet 43
et bien le débarquement sicile est
certainement un moment où l'armée
italienne et italo allemande s'est
effondré ans ici les allemands moins que
les italiens c'est un fait mais regardez
ce qu'est ce débarquement ce
débarquement est la répétition de ce qui
sera plus tard le débarquement en
normandie
c'est un effort de guerre
gigantesque qui est mise en place pour
une question essentielle c'est de faire
tomber le premier pays de lacq ce après
quoi le front italien dreux deviendra un
front secondaire dans la tente du vrai
débarquement que les anglo saxons les
anglo-américains honte
décidé avec staline c'est à dire celui
en normandie alors justement à la suite
de ce débarquement sicile en 43
le duce
d'abord renversé par le haut conseil
fasciste puis renvoyé par le roi le roi
renvoie son premier ministre parce qu'au
fond il n'a jamais été depuis longtemps
que le deuxième personne a à jouer du de
l'état un mussolini il y avait un roi au
dessus de lui et au
fond il reste totalement c'est là où on
se dit où ça n'est pas un vrai
totalitarisme ou en tout cas il est très
très loin d'un personnage comme hitler
c'est qu'au fond ils se laissent
destitué oui alors justement c'est une
interrogation qui bien que
disposions aujourd'hui d'une du
d'une de tonnes et tonnes de témoignages
qui sont souvent d'ailleurs des termes
des témoignages qui ont été écrits après
truqués changer modifier enfin vous le
fait est que nous ne savons pas vraiment
mais que nous nous posons le doute
certainement je le pose autre mystère
bruce lee comment sais tu qui quand même
est un conspirateur nez depuis qu'il a
l'âge de raison
s'il a jamais eu la rose qui a toujours
comme tout bon dictateur
exercer un contrôle total sur
l'instrument de la police il n'a jamais
quitté le ministère de l'intérieur
arrivent sans presque le savoir dans une
conspiration au milieu d'une
conspiration qui se passe pendant
quelques semaines dans l'ère du poney
tine romain où tout le monde parle
de tout et lui ne sait rien et il arrive
comme ça le soir au plus tôt la nuit en
par fanon ça commence après midi pour
passer dans la nuit en pensant qui va
renverser les cartes rien que par sa
personnalité ou n'est ce pas plutôt une
façon qui correspondrait à peu à
certains côtés du personnage pour sortir
de cette situation sans pour cela que
les allemands puissent dire qu'elle a
voulu faire une une peine compromis avec
les alliés ce serait ça il se
sortiraient d'affaires pour vous une
certaine manière ça va pas se passer
comme il l'espérait puisque dans sa
chambre il est il est arrêté il est
emprisonné oui ça ils avaient peut-être
primé revanche il est libéré par hitler
à ça ils n'avaient pas prévu voilà ça la
vraie est ensuite hyper le nomme à la
tête puis à la république sociale la
république de salo wii qui va durer un
an et demi après quand même oui ce sont
les parachutistes qui ont libéré veut
tout à fait souligne alors justement
libérer ou embastillé définitivement
mieux se lit dans quelque chose dont il
ne voulait pas on le voit là
vous verrez les photos dans sa rencontre
avec hitler il ad'ailleurs bemba petit
fils il est loin d'être heureux non je
pense que certainement ce qui à ce
moment là à jouer ce n'est pas du tout
sa volonté de créer une république
sociale et par définition en ce cas une
guerre civile dans le centre nord du
pays s'est encore l'espoir de s'en
sortir d'ailleurs ce qui est très
curieux c'est que personne ne veut de
lui
les militaires allemands qui ont
pratiquement le contrôle de l'italie du
centre nord particulier kesselring le
commandant en chef qui est un excellent
militaire souhaiterais qu'il y a un pet
à italien souhaiterait complet plus près
d'un vieux général ou maréchal
peut-être pas tout à fait lucide qui est
quand même la possibilité d'avoir un
rôle tels que l'italie de vie nulle base
de ressources pour le dernier effort la
dernière équipe et du reich et ne pose
pas de problème surtout deux guerres
partisanes et de résistance c'est le
contraire qui va se passer
les allemands du parti comme goebel ce
des tests bout celui et considère que
l'homme est finie et même certaines
fasciste irréductibles ne veulent plus
de boussole idiot considérant que pour
la même raison il est belle et c'est
hitler et seulement hitler qui le remet
en selle et même à ce moment là et même
à ce moment là et mousseux guide il
reviendra à l'italie avec l'idée de
devenir simplement lui à chef d'état
symbolique en prenant au premier
ministre pour faire le
mauvais ou sale boulot et tout cela en
fait une solution pétain laval si vous
voulez les pensées un an et demi il est
quasi non plus de pouvoir me suis mis la
main sur son frein
et puis s'enfuit quand tout s'écroule
il s'enfuit avec sa maîtresse clara
petacci alors parlons femmes justement
on imagine mussolini beaucoup plus
sensuelle keatley recouvert de femmes
vous dit pas du tout mais on est très
prude va pas porter sur la shoah sexy
très portée sur la chose je pense même
en fin d'année mais pas dans le sens
sensuelle du terme à l'assaut comme
c'est adeline affectif c'est en même
temps un nom sensuelle je ne sais pas
quel homme politique on attribue les
cinq minutes douche comprise et alex
irak a et donc mais c'est un peu ce
qu'on pourrait dire de lui jusqu'à leur
rencontre avec la péta clara petacci qui
est là alors que d'autres on a voulu
faire de l'image d'une espèce de bimbo
de les blogs qui se serait jeté dans les
bras de mussolini une fille de la grande
bourgeoisie elle a 20 ans quand ils se
rencontrent il en a 48 et ça va durer
donc présents aussi longtemps que eva
braun et et hitler mais là il découvre
vraiment la passion amoureuse d'applied
là elle découvre la passion amoureuse
c'est incontestable les lettres en
témoigne ce sont les seuls êtres d'un
contenu privé d'ailleurs il a été
je passe d'excellentes idées de les
publier parce que on voit un côté chez
lui qui n'existe dans aucune autre
correspondance n'y avait qu'une femme
n'est certainement avec adam c'est à
dire quand même le côté où il descend un
peu de son personnage pas toujours mais
un peu et surtout vers la fin mais c'est
une des tarifs 48 ans quand même hein
mais oui mais c'est le hasard des
circonstances enfin il en est c'est
parfaitement sa première mettrait non
mais c'est certainement celle qui qui
jouent un rôle considérable surtout vers
la fin et alors à la fin ils partent
ensemble ils ils veulent passer en
suisse il a une mallette pleine de
devises elle est là ses bijoux de
famille qu'elle vient d'une famille très
riche elle a pas eu du tout été
entretenu par le führer comme moi par le
duce comme on l'a dit et ils sont
arrêtés par les partisans italiens
communiste et ils sont fusillés par les
communistes ils sont arrêtés par les
partisans d'ailleurs qui ne le sont pas
mais à partir de ce moment là par toute
une opération qui est une plainte
raconte en détail
à vous écouter un détail elle est disons
il ya donc sept cette arrestation il ya
ce côté qui est certainement peu
comment dirais-je
[Musique]
bricks and qui anoblit très peu la fin
du personnage de ce2
ce2 passé a par-dessus allemand mais
enfin après tout napoléon avait bien
passé le faire dessus
dada général aux tricheurs moment on est
on sûr c'est chateaubriand y voilà
chateaubriand n'ayant jamais beaucoup
plus mais napoléon y en a d'autres qui
l'ont dit également mais là n'est pas la
question la question véritable c'est
qu'il y a beaucoup de spéculations
autour de sa mort bien sûr ça entretient
peu comme les spéculations qu'il ya eu
sur le véritable cadavre ou non les
cendres de hitler dans le bouquet les
spéculations sur la mort de staline
beria et tout cela c'est inévitable cela
fait mousser l'intérêt du public
finalement nous savons les choses
essentielles nous savons qu'il est
porteur non seulement de devises ce qui
est évident dans une fuite mais
également porteur de documents ces
documents peuvent être plus ou moins
intéressants nous ne les avons pas
récupérer mais nous savons par des
témoignages croisés de quoi
essentiellement issus notamment des
lettres de churchill alors justement la
question intéressante est essentiel
c'est les lettres de chukchi je suis pas
remis et celles et ceux qui considèrent
que sauf preuve contraire que nous
n'avons pas cette correspondance qui a
certainement exister dans les années 20
né dans les années 30 où l'entente entre
les deux hommes même sur le plan
personnel était forte vous souvenez de
churchill arriva homme disant si j'étais
italien jeu si j'avais 20 ans ici j'ai
invité italien j'aurais été fasciste
formule 1 ce qui lui a été reprochée
mais le vrai problème c'est existe-t-il
une correspondance intérêts l'entrée en
guerre de l'italie et ça vraiment ça
tourne abonnés vis oh oh oh roman et au
mauvais roman parce que il y a deux
éléments d'ailleurs qui sont en
contradiction d'une part on veut que
churchill insiste sur mussolini pour
qu'il entre en guerre afin d'empêcher
une victoire absolue de heatley alors
que vous voyez que la piteuse opérations
de la guerre des alpes ne rencontre la
france
fait en sorte que la guerre de claire
simon veut la victoire nucléaire soit
encore plus par comparaison encore plus
fort et d'autre part la contradiction
c'est de dire au contraire il ne faut
pas entrer en guerre ce qui aurait plus
de sens donc une neutralité italienne
possible qui permettrait en particulier
à la royal navy de ne pas patrouiller
cette partie de la méditerranée et se
déplacer vers l'atlantique et vers l'est
l'allée soumaré allemand soumaré
allemands qui ont été permis par les
anglais au terme de l'accord navale
anglo allemand de 35 fou tu l'as voulu
george dandin et finalement ça aurait
beaucoup de ça mais on n'a rien trouvé
on ne fait pas on n'a rien trouvé et
puis il y a également une me semble t'il
une considération que qu'on oublie c'est
que
churchill est un homme de poigne
certainement il n'est pas encore nous
sommes en jeu un jeu car en juin juillet
40 il n'est pas encore le chef de guerre
absolue que les anglais connaîtront plus
tard il est quand même entouré de
collaborateurs de services secrets de
policiers surveillaient ce qu'il fait et
sur les airs et il est en même temps
surveillé qu'est ce qui fait cher bénite
qui l'enferment la lettre il met dessus
de la table ils envoient par les postes
jusqu'au palais de venise enfin ouais
donc a priori la correspondance rêvé par
certains de churchill et mussolini une
fois la guerre d'éclairer un peu de
chance ce puits résisté ce qui à mon
avis très intéressant c'est l'opération
commente le parti communiste le parti
communiste de la résistance pour
provoquer la fin de mousseline y non pas
par une cruauté autres mais
essentiellement parce que c'est le
projet politique qui permettra aux
communistes qui ont été en grande partie
minoritaire est tardif dans la
résistance pensons à la guerre avec
l'union soviétique de sortir comme en
france comme le parti de la résistance
et la mort de clara petacci qu'aucun
jeune femme on se souvient qu'ils sont
fusillés tous les deux vous raconter en
détail
par surprise elle se jette devant pour
dire ça c'est se connaissent il a dit
nous les moines y étions allés
mais il ya des témoignages mais
contradictoires les ménages qui sont
assez contradictoires la règle
alors moi je ne crois pas du tout à la à
la mort par comment dirais-je peint par
le cf le fait le mort accidentelle parce
qu'elle s'est jeté non glas pour trois
raisons d'abord
nous savons comment était composé le
groupe de feu nous le savons tous de
comment était composé l'équipe qui est
allé les chercher là où il est et voilà
et on sait qui maintenant elle a pas
toujours su non mais quand même nous
donc je dois dire tous ces détails sont
assez précis vous n'allez pas me dire
que des grands personnages de comme saad
ehret résistants ne peuvent pas
contrôler une femme en empêchant
qu'elles se jette en face de quelqu'un
qu'on est en train de fusil
2° l'hypothèse comme quoi on ne devait
pas la fusiller ce serait elle qui
aurait échappé à cinar mais justement ce
qui a été fait dans le film de mon ami
câble l'unita ligne est inspiré de
l'histoire mais qui ne tient pas debout
pour cette cause la deuxième raison pour
laquelle ne tient pas debout c'est que l
été la démonstration du côté néfaste du
dictateur qu'on voulait même plonger si
vous voulez on revient à côté petit
bourgeois chez les italiens c'est à dire
l'homme qui abandonne même la famille
qu'on aurait coloris tripes et à ce
moment là sur manipule open pour fuir
avec sa maîtresse donc il ya ce côté et
le troisième qui est à mon avis
l'élément fondamental si elle est mort
par accident si on voulait pas d'un et
alors pourquoi lui imposer l'ignominie
également de piazzale loric s'éteignent
à la porte à côté de lui c'est la clé
piété baroque sera épié par les pieds et
vous savez et vous savez que
heureusement je crois à prêtre est
intervenu pour lui serrer la
jupe
ses gants voilà et
quel bilan
et celui de mussolini on a longtemps dit
que
sa révolution au fond s'était réduite à
faire arriver les trains à l'heure etc
ce qui était la première fois en italie
mais l'était certainement une caricature
est bien sûr qu'est ce qu'il a qu'est-ce
qu'il avait 20 ans quand même au pouvoir
qu'est ce que les aime les italiens lui
doivent les ennuis on sait mais est-ce
qu'il ya eu quelque chose quand même de
positive alors un point qui
je souhaiterais évoqué si vous me le
permettez en terminant c'est que le
fascisme est un phénomène historique
morts et des femmes heureusement non
parce qu'on me pose parfois la question
en me faisant le voir ça ça sent abrutis
lever les bras evrard des gens là le
phénomène et m'a aidé et faé c'est
d'ailleurs la raison pour lequel nous
pouvons l'analyser avec les termes de
l'histoire alors qu'avec les termes de
la sociologie de la psychologie de basse
nous pouvons étudier des phénomènes néo
de nos sociétés mais c'est une autre
chose
personnellement je crois que même des
gens qui ont fait leur carrière
politique disons néofasciste vous
rappeler monsieur almirall réglé dès
longtemps n'y croyait plus c'était pour
eux une question d'avancer leur petit
lot politique mais le phénomène fascisme
mussolinien et termine
ce qu'il a légué c'est certainement une
frilosité
tenez le débat en séjour en italie nous
sommes aujourd'hui même ce sera le
premier jour de l'élection d'un nouveau
président de la république et vous voyez
des voix qui disent il faut que le
président de la république ne vit que ce
n'est pas du tout la charge honorifique
que certains considèrent en france c'est
une charge politique qui peut devenir
importantes en moment de crise nous ne
voulons pas de personnel était trop
forte sinon nous allons vers une dérive
présidentialiste
nitrogène d'ailleurs il faut avoir 50 on
y voit là ça c'est un faux souvenirs
éléments mis ce qu'il est arrivé au
pouvoir à l'âge où emmanuel macron il
est arrivé à voir monsieur macro et je
crois monsieur chirac premier
jusqu'à destin n'aurait n'aurait pas été
quand je les dis à monsieur jusqu'à des
salles amuse-bouche n'aurait pas été all
you need is bref on est à dire et
publier ça c'est à cause de mussolini si
on veut plus un jeune président donc il
ya cet élément donc vous voyez qu'il ya
cette crispation et à mon avis c'est à
l'héritage très négatif parce qu'il ya
une sorte d'image l'image d'épinal si
vous voulez mais c'est comme si il y
avait à
une sorte toujours justement de
frilosité de peur de difficultés par
rapport à ce qui est a passé dont
certains éléments ne passez pas
à côté de cela il faut avouer quand même
qu'il y a objectivement des réalisations
faites dans l'urbanisme dans toute une
poussée et ça a été une partie
d'ailleurs
si vous voulez de sa crédibilité
la poussée des jeunes talents des élèves
à et encore des années 30 donc de ce
point de vue l'an sur le plan 10
anthropologique et culturels le bilan
peut être mitigé alors que politique
boyle était indéfendable mais à simone
thiot serra le mystère mussolini c'est
paru aux éditions perrin et vous avez
reçu le prix de la meilleure biographie
politique
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]
le travail de julian et de wikileaks
nous a montré toute une série de
meurtres la corruption la profonde
criminalité des états unis et de leurs
alliés de l'otan
ce sa page de réputation qui a commencé
quasiment immédiatement après la
publication des irakiens warlocks
l'isolent de la société
le new york times le washington post
ils ont tous publié exactement la même
chose
mais la violence du royaume uni et de
ses agents
cela donne la nausée
aviez vous été surpris que ces organes
de presse qui ont publié ces
informations se soit ensuite retournés
contre julian
et bien non pas vraiment je dirais déçu
oui mais pas surpris
chaque épargnant j'ai mal à la tête
et aux oreilles aussi
beaucoup sont morts
ils n'ont pas su s'en sortir
c'était notre maison
et qui peuvent à peine marcher après
avoir plongé pour chercher de l'or
j'ai du mal à marcher maintenant
il est interdit d extraire de l'or sans
autorisation mais aucun d'entre nous n'a
de licence ou de permis
voilà la pépite qu'elle a trouvé ça n'a
pas rapporté gros mais c'est déjà ça
[Musique]
c'est le sentiment que que vous avez eue
vous aussi ce besoin d'autonomie oui
complètement besoin d'autonomie besoin
de retourner à des choses plus
essentielles en fait est vraiment de
sentir qu'on n'est pas forcément un
poids pour la planète il ya une idée
derrière il ya une philosophie aussi
qu'on a vu la serre les plantes qui
poussent le fait de vivre avec les
plantes comme ça
vraiment comme une machine un organisme
pour fait partie de sa vie de cet
organisme on a eu vraiment l'impression
de se construire en même temps quand
vous construisez cette maison en faisant
toutes ces rencontres je pense que ces
genres de projets qui se fait pas tout
seul dans son coin on est dans un truc
vraiment de coopération de partage de
partage
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
notre protocole n'avait qu'une seule
option la greffe j'ai commencé à lui
expliqué petit à petit qu'on allait
sûrement trouver un donneur sanaa
[Musique]
au début je n'avais aucune idée de ce
que c'était j'ai réfléchi pendant une
dizaine de minutes j'ai d'abord eu peur
j'ai même pensé à refuser
si on calcule le nombre de patients
morts faute de donneur compatible
faute de greffe on est à peu près à 3 à
4000 personnes par an en russie
c'est la réalité
[Musique]
bienvenue dans la fri connecte le
continent compte environ 500 millions
d'internautes soit 38 % de la population
un potentiel énorme de croissance mais
aussi un boulevard pour la
cybercriminalité
selon l'expert en sécurité kapersky
l'afrique a été la cible de 28 millions
de cyber attaques entre janvier et août
2020 à la cybercriminalité semble être
devenu la principale menace sur le
continent pour en parler on va se
connecter à tunis avec rima abassi
chercheuse en cybersécurité sélectionné
à parmi les 50 meilleures femmes
africaines en cybersécurité elle a reçu
le prix du meilleur jeune chercheur en
informatique de l'académie des arts et
des sciences de tunis bonjour à vous un
rima abassi merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation dans afrique connect bonjour
et merci de m'avoir invité de me donner
cette occasion de partager avec vous
quelques unes de mes d'informer sans
merci alors je disais la
cybercriminalité c'est la nouvelle
menace sur le continent l'afrique est
elle devenue la nouvelle terre de
prédilection des cybercriminels
la cybersécurité c'est un concept qu'on
va dire qu'il va toucher le monde entier
actuellement de par le volume énorme de
données que nos échanges en deux par le
nombre d'objets connectés et l'afrique
un continent plein croissance ne va pas
déroger à la règle et en fait c'est un
peu comme vous dites la nouvelle terre
de prédilection pour la cybercriminalité
pour des raisons assez simple
tout d'abord parce que nous manquons
cruellement de compétences qualifiées en
termes de cybersécurité d'après les
dernières estimations
on estime cela à son mine si cyber
experts
dont on aurait besoin à court terme est
ce le problème c'est que même les
compétences que nous avançons vont être
très très vite des marchés par d'autres
d'autres pays d'autres continents vu que
c'est une denrée rare dans le monde
entier c'est une pénurie mondiale et en
fait ça fait que on estime que 96% des
incidences de cyber sécurité ne seraient
pas signalés on resterait non résolus ça
c'est la première la première qods la
deuxième clause bas tout simplement
parce que les budgets alloués à la cyber
sécurité en afrique reste très très très
insuffisant on estime que 66% des
entreprises d'investissement de 200
mille euros par an quand rapidement
tendance mondiale en plus même la
répartition de ce budget elle ne se fait
pas de manière équitable entre les
différentes domaines donc par exemple
les investissements en cybersécurité
dans les équipements et de l'ordre de
35% en afrique alors que dans le reste
du monde c'est de l'ordre de 14% donc en
fait on investit beaucoup plus dans les
infrastructures et haytillon crois que
ces infrastructures l'avant nous devons
nous protéger auquel sa haine mais ça ne
protège pas complètement et
paradoxalement bas 5 % seulement des
investissements seront dédiés à la
sécurité des données à la détection des
incidents au suivi des menaces ou encore
la gestion des identités contre 16% pour
le reste du monde donc vous voyez que
réellement cela
aide à créer ce problème de
cybercriminalité bien sûr le problème le
troisième problème un navire est le fait
qu'il ya très très peu de mesures qui
sont prises en faveur de la formulation
et l'adoption de politiques en matière
de cyber défense bas par exemple le 15
pays africains seulement possède une
stratégie nationale de cybersécurité
seulement ont signé la convention de
budapest de sur la cybercriminalité en
2001 vous voyez tout cela va renforcer
en fait cette dernière position de 10
ans ou ceux ce retard de l'afrique en
termes de cybersécurité est donc en
termes de cybercriminalité ou par le
même on parle de menaces en mai voire
même de chaos numérique c'est la réalité
un risque au real
ben c'est un risque réel parce que tout
simplement lorsque vous n'êtes pas
préparé et que vous n'avez pas les
bonnes personnes et les bonnes
stratégies qui sont mises en place bah
vous risquez de subir des attaques qui
vont être désastreuses et ça on le
remarque ces derniers mois et dernières
années on va dire on a noté que la
plupart des attaques ont visé les
infrastructures critiques donc
l'eau l'électricité etc le service
bancaire aussi et ça fait que ça risque
réellement de créer le chaos de dons
dans différents pays et dans tout le
continent bien sûr quels sont les pays
les plus touchés par ce phénomène de la
cyber délinquance cybercriminalité
ben on aura tendance à dire que ce sont
les pays
banques et non qui nous je dirais les
pays qui n'ont pas investi dans cette
stratégie nationale donc de
cybersécurité donc ça va être plus les
pays de de l'afrique de l'ouest audois
l'est de l'ouest 10 ans mais en fait
tous les pays sont touchés par ce
problème de cybersécurité parce qu'on
reste finalement dans le cyberespace
c'est comme une chaîne donc si l'un des
maillons doit être faibles toute la
chaîne doit être faire de tout
simplement est ce que la pandémie de
covile 19 a eu un impact sur les actes
de cybercriminalité
en fait la pandémie elle a fait que nous
nous sommes devenus vulnérables à tous
les égards parce que tout simplement
pendant cette crise nous étions
dépendants plus que jamais des systèmes
informatiques des de nos téléphones dell
de l'internet pour travailler pour
communiquer pour faire des achats pour
partager pourra recevoir des
informations et en fait c'était une
aubaine pour les cybercriminels vu que
on dit que voilà la pandémie a renforcé
la digitalisation dans certains pays
mais paradoxalement elle a intensifié
les menaces et les risques de en termes
de cybersécurité bas tout simplement
parce que
dans l'une de ces raisons c'est que la
plupart des entreprises 10 ans les
petites et moyennes entreprises qui
étaient obligés de passer en télétravail
ont adopté la proche
apportez votre propre appareil on device
ce qui signifie que l'employé en fait il
va utiliser ses propres appareils
personnels téléphones tablettes aux
autres pour accéder aux informations de
l'entreprise et bien sûr ces équipements
là ne sont pas sécurisées de la même
façon que les équipements qui était au
sein même de l'entreprise
donc lorsque on va utiliser un
ordinateur personnel pour accéder aux
données de l'entreprise bat l'entreprise
sera plus que jamais exposé aux cyber
attaques parce que la moindre des choses
c'est qu'un employé ne va pas forcément
avoir un antivirus qui sera à jour il va
pas forcément faire des analyses
régulièrement il va pas forcément avoir
un parfait va pas utiliser du cryptage
pour échanger des données donc cet
environnement de travail à domicile
réellement ne dispose dans la plupart
des cas de presque pas de l'usure
sophistiqué de prévention et de
détection que l'homme aurait eu au sein
de l'entreprise en plus les réseaux wifi
comme va utiliser chez soi sont beaucoup
plus facile à attaquer que les réseaux
de l'entreprise filaire ou sans fil bien
sûr aussi l'erreur humaine qui était
déjà avant la pandémie une source de
sursaut majeur de préoccupations elle
est encore plus aujourd'hui parce que
involontairement ou imprudemment les
employés vont permettre à certaines
personnes d'accéder ou des mauvaises
personnes d'accéder aux informations
parce que lorsqu'on est dans son
entreprise en épuisement concentré on
est dans un environnement bien précis
bien clair on est je dirais sur ses
gardes alors que chez soi on peut être
perturbé par les membres de sa famille
par des individus qui peut rendre visite
par le téléphone personnel qui seul et c
est tout ça fait que le nombre d'erreurs
humaines a augmenté en flèche et ça fait
que
finalement le nombre d'attaqués a
augmenté rendez vous quand le pendant de
la pandémie en à une attaque en lançant
jean ciel toutes les 14 secondes donc
vous imaginez cc c'est énorme agassi
avant de se pencher sur qui se cache
derrière les actes de cybercriminalité
de cyber attaques ce chiffre
les pertes dépassent 4 milliards de
dollars c'est un coût financier énorme
c'est significatif pour les économies
africaines
très significatif j'allais justement
vous vous donnez un autre chiffre ben on
estime que 60 % des pme qui ont connu
une attaque une attaque majeure durand
2020 en cesser leur activité dans les
six mois donc ça vous donne une idée sur
ce qui s'est passé dans long terme de
perte ou de manque à gagner parce que la
perte de vos données il appert que
l'arrêt de vote du travail
antérieur c'est vraiment très très très
très élevé et j'ai d'ailleurs aussi un
chiffre qui concerne les banques
africaines qui a été donnée par une
entreprise marocaine donc en afrique ils
estiment dans les banques africaines en
fait qu'ils en ont signalé des
cyberattaques on estime à peu près 800
mille euros
pour les derniers en termes de pertes
tandis que le coût moyen de chacun ces
infections informatiques et du un
logiciel malveillant coûte 9000 euros
aux entreprises africaines en moyenne
donc vous imaginez la répercussion en
termes de coût et en termes de pertes
comme les 10 en termes de même de
moncany alors la cybercriminalité
s'expriment sont diverses formes de
quelle menace parle-t-on comment
s'exerce hôtels qui sont les cibles
éléments de réponse avec la saga
ap les brouteurs en côte d'ivoire où il
ya ou boys au nigeria les petits
arnaqueurs en ligne des années 2000
poser dans les cyber cafés de quartier
donc plus grand chose à voir avec les
organisations cybercriminelles
d'aujourd'hui autrefois auteur d'
arnaque aux sentiments ou de petits
rançonnage sur la toile les attaques
actuelles sont désormais le fait
d'individus bien rodée et d'entités
organisé pour rappel le terme
cybercriminalité englobe l'ensemble des
crimes commis sur internet ou via des
réseaux ou des outils informatiques avec
la progression du numérique et notamment
celle du passage du cash au paiement
mobile en afrique le secteur des
services financiers a fait un boom
colossal mais dans cette évolution la
cyber sécurité demeure le parent pauvre
manque de compétences et absence de
sensibilisation des entreprises
l'afrique reste très vulnérable aux
cyber attaques
pour y palier en 2018 s'ouvrait au
sénégal une école de cybersécurité à
vocation régionale et
un grand show secours
psc - les brèves et lit les dvd
sidéré par la définition et
l'acquisition de la technologie à les
faire publier
de l'information
la cybercriminalité est l'une des formes
les plus prolifiques de criminalité
internationale un impact annuel sur
l'économie mondiale qui s'élèverait à 10
5 milliards de dollars d'ici 2025 les
sommes colossales qui incite les états à
s'en préoccuper davantage au mois de
décembre le président ivoirien alassane
ouattara a annoncé le dégagement de 18
milliards de francs cfa en 2022 pour
lutter contre les brouteurs ces
champions de larnack en ligne ces
dernières années des groupes organisés
en vue le jour parmi les plus connus
figurent le collectif anonymous
militants sur internet pour la défense
de la justice la politique ou la
religion en 2016 ils ont lancé le
hashtag prob africa pour dénoncer les
gouvernements africains qu'ils jugeaient
corrompu gouvernement et même compagnie
ils prennent en otage les données des
entreprises pour dénoncer leurs failles
selon les experts d'autres catégories de
cybercriminels existe les script kiddies
qui malgré leurs faibles connaissances
en sécurité informatique tente à
longueur de journée d'infiltrer des
systèmes vous suivent ensuite les
individus qualifiés puis les groupes
criminels organisés tout en haut de
l'échelle on trouve les states sponsored
des groupes financés par des états dont
la mission est de collecter des données
sur d'autres états à des fins
financières ou géopolitiques le dernier
scandale d'espionnage en date via le
logiciel pegasus aurait ciblé près de
cinquante mille numéros de téléphone
l'enquète mondiale qui a été menée par
le consortium le journaliste forbidden
stories en lien avec amnesty
international a révélé que des
gouvernements clients de l'entreprise et
nassau une entreprise de cyber
surveillance israélienne
utiliser le logiciel espion pegasus pour
cibler pour espionner des personnes qui
sont des défenseurs des droits humains
des journalistes ou des personnalités
politiques sur la société civile le 17
janvier une rencontre entre eux des
diplomates africains et leurs homologues
mondiaux est à new york objectif
discuter d'un nouveau traité des nations
unies pour lutter contre la
cybercriminalité
[Musique]
un nouveau traité donc des nations unies
pour lutter contre la cybercriminalité
est initié par la russie qui doit voir
le jour auquel les pays africains sont
appelés à participer activement
riba abassi parmi les préoccupations
majeures au niveau international le
cyberterrorisme également sur le
continent cela a pour conséquence aussi
de la cyber censure qu'est ce qu'on peut
dire sur l'action des étals sont à la
fois régulateur mais aussi coupable de
la situation doit dépendre des états sur
table oui sont plus ou moins complice
parce qu on ne vous l'avait dit dans
notre reportage
ben ils ont financé ces groupes là pour
essayer de d'en tirer parti certains
sont coupables en faisant un peu la
politique de l'autruche dans pillards et
un tout va bien en
investira en prendra les choses en main
là le jour où il y aura un grave
incident donc là aussi
ils prennent pas les choses au sérieux
ils sont aussi des fois ils ne peuvent
pas des fois prendre les choses au
sérieux parce qu'ils n'ont pas comme on
l'a dit les moyens ou les compétences
pour les faire pour les faire donc
réellement ce ça va dépendre du c'est au
cas par cas mais bon disons que on est
certains pays essaient de trouver le
juste milieu d'essayer de
2,2 défendre dix ans de leurs cyber
espace du mieux qu'il peut si on va
marquer une courte pause et se retrouver
à l'instant pour poursuivre dans afrique
connaître par rester avec nous
[Musique]
la pauvreté est un problème mondial
comment le résoudre à
la chine ce pays de plus de 1,4 milliard
d'habitants fait de gros efforts pour
lutter contre la pauvreté
[Musique]
la journaliste anna nedeljko entreprend
un voyage à travers la province du
fujian dans le sud-est de la chine
elle y parcourt ces hautes montagnes sa
mère
on s'emmêle dans les cordes et goûtent
aux difficultés du quotidien des
fermiers
je n'aurais jamais cru que les ignames
puisse ressembler ce afin de tenter de
lever le voile sur le secret du miracle
économique chinois je n'ai jamais été
dans une maison comme ça il faut faire
très attention pour ne pas tondre east
et comprendre comment sortir un peuple
de la pauvreté
le projet elle au china apporte quelques
réponses
la violence peut déstabiliser la société
trop de sécurité de mettre en danger nos
libertés
[Musique]
retour dans afrique hohneck consacré la
cybercriminalité en afrique et nous
sommes avec rim à abc depuis tunis
chercheuse en cyber sécurité
on l'a vu dans le sujet rima abassi
l'action d'un collectif célèbre de
hackers anonymous
c'est un collectif de pirates d'experts
capables de mettre hors service des
sites ils ont lancé une initiative
hashtag up africa ce sont des web
terroristes pour certains des robins du
web pour d'autres par quels moyens
techniques qu'ils agissent
en fait ce sont comme vous l'avez dit
c'est un mouvement c'est tout un souci
c'est tout un mouvement de fait ce n'est
pas une une organisation donc en fait
ils agissent par le fait de ne pas être
centralisées pas d'âme n'ont pas de
hiérarchie donc pas d archi c'est un
mouvement complètement décentralisé son
livre archi engrais helmand comme le dit
l'anthropologue gabriella coleman en
fait ils agissent tout simplement à
travers des initiatives individuelles
donc tout le monde peut faire une vidéo
pour faire une action signée anonyme
hausse ils ont un logo ils ont le masque
donc leur emblème se masquer la est en
fait voilà donc ils agissent à travers
ces des actions qui sont complètement
décentralisée et des initiatives
individuelles qui défendent
principalement les libertés sur internet
et il lutte aussi contre la corruption
des états comment est-ce que ce qu'on
peut évaluer finalement leur capacité de
nuisance
en fait ce qu'ils font c'est plus du
activisme 10 ans du machisme à dire que
finalement ils vont ils vont juste dire
voilà on n'est pas d'accord montre que
la plupart des gens ne sont pas d'accord
ça a été fait notamment 2010 2008 avec
l'église de la ce do logis lorsqu'ils
ont carrément ils ont pris l'algorithme
de google en faisant en sorte que
lorsqu'une personne cherche des
informations sur cette église il tombe
sur des sites d'opposants la doctrine
ils ont fait ça aussi en 2012 lorsqu'ils
ont lancé l'opération black out en
réponse à la fermeture de mega blood et
il se sent attaqué aux billes en fait en
fermant des serveurs du fbi ils ont fait
la même chose pendant le printemps arabe
en fermant des serveurs d'autorité
disant
administrative publique dans les pays du
printemps arabe leur dernière action en
date c'est suite à la mort de georges
floyd donc avec le collectif blacklight
battles et ils ont menacé la police de
minneapolis donc leur action c'est
plutôt l hérault bondi katif donc en
fermant des sites en arrêtant des
serveurs en propageant des messages
plutôt que bon voilà donc c'est ce genre
de nuisances et voulait un autre niveau
on trouve les brouteurs on va écouter a
à ce propos notre expert jean jacques
bauguil et docteur en sciences de
l'information et de la communication
auteurs de cet ouvrage la
cybercriminalité une menace pour le
développement
c'est donc
et qui en prend forme
jérémy vie
tout ce qui est faux c'est notre
héritage
dans toutes sortes d adam
inspirèrent d'envolées sentimentale donc
savourer ce qui est des plus les
chroniques la base devrait être lui dit
qu il fasse une cassation yvan
immobilière et c'est très important
donc à terme
les capacités l'est certainement eu la
manipuler des personnes
général à l'étranger
[Musique]
les mavs sait comment échapper aux
griffes de ces broutards
comme l'a dit
notre expert en fait ils vont utiliser
10 ans je dirais pas la naïveté mais
l'éthique ou disons là les sentiments de
certaines personnes qui vont essayer de
dupes et en se prétendant en prétendant
un problème imaginaire où un héritage un
héritage vie dans une fausse loterie et
c'est donc en fait ils vont utiliser ce
ce cette force de persuasion pour
essayer d'obtenir des informations ou de
l'argent donc l'idée c'est d'essayer
d'être sur vos gardes de ne jamais
envoyer d'argent à des personnes quand
tu viens de rencontrer pour entendre
qu'on a rencontrés depuis peu il faut
surtout pas envoyé de photo intime parce
que réellement il ya un grand aussi
problème quand c'est renoncer parce
qu'apres par la suite il va y avoir du
du chantage etc il faut pas dévoiler des
coordonnées personnelles ou des données
personnelles à des inconnus même si ces
inconnus vous paraissent séduisante ce
que vous voulez il faut toujours essayer
de vérifier la véracité de leurs propos
il faut leur poser des petites questions
personnelles pour vérifier pour être sûr
pour qu'il n'ya pas d'incohérence dans
leurs propos lorsque vous avez des
messages par courrier électronique faut
surtout pas y répandre ou cliqué faut
vérifier vérifier l'adresse vérifier ce
qui est pas d'erreur dans les adresses
électroniques que l'on reçoit il faut
être conscient que la police ou où la
gendarmerie ne vont pas vous envoyer des
des demandes par mail donc il faut pas
répondre à ce genre aussi de
communication donc il faut être tout
simplement en alerte il faut toujours
être critique vis-à-vis de ce que vous
recevez des avis des des des gens que
vous rencontrez qui des profils que vous
voyez aussi il faut être un peu
suspicieux parce que réellement douala
leur force c'est leur force de séduction
et de persuasion et qui fait que voilà
il dit certaines personnes pour l'exclu
leur extorquer de l'argent ou des
informations critiques il faut surtout
pas envoyer ses informations
personnelles via je sais n'importe quel
média il faut vraiment être sûr que
c'est votre banque ou c'est votre
vraiment il faut être sûr du
destinataire à fond de partager des
informations critiques pour écouter à
nouveau jean jacques bouilly sont les
stratégies de lutte face aux cyber
menaces
2013 14 un certain nombre de courants
dernière vous
réguliers cela il est avec des
équipements de la sec en prison c'est un
assez mauvais à côté de ça les
commissions qui y travaillent il attend
de lui comme fasciné en place un travail
avec la lente d'occuper aussi
communication alain jacques traumatique
et non aujourd'hui c'est supporte le
susan et cela passe comme prévu
régulièrement il y américains sont
aimantés est en tout cas il va plus loin
le
circuit un jeu les east room ligne est
sur la touche pour qu ils soient arrivés
en cinq sets gagnants ou des pressions
aussi un travail de sensibilisation
qu'il y ait quelques numéros
citoyens
mais parce qu il faut dire que leur
série sans précédent cet égard tirés ses
yeux la femme est comédien au
secteur de roubaix le voir aux serveurs
d'entrée gratifié des monnaies de
musique nous disent de manga est une
année sa fille née mais dans le quartier
parce que le jeune va revenir à
l'origine de nos maux parce que
généralement illégales ce cyber
criminels la seconde après ce deuxième
ces légendes générer des quartiers
qu'ils et elles vont avec les émirats
ça complique forcément les mecs
alors visiblement ce n'est pas facile de
mener des stratégies ont lutté contre la
cyberdélinquance la cyber criminalité
interpol a d'ailleurs lancé une
initiative pour mettre en place un
nouveau bureau des opérations sur la
cybercriminalité
oui en fait interpol a fait tout un
travail en fait pour aider
disant ah les pays membres de
l'organisation
de pour lutter contre la
cybercriminalité
tout d'abord il en a recensé en fait les
cinq plus grandes menaces pour qu' on
puisse ou les pays puissent se
concentrer sur menace sur ces menaces il
s'agit principalement des est ce qu est
ce qu cris en ligne les faux email et
sms l'extension l'extorsion numérique
qui dont on parlait tout à l'heure les
fous ordres de mouvements les rançons
ciel je vous ai parlé de ça tout à
l'heure et les baux tête par la suite en
fait ils ont mis en place toute une
stratégie
tout d'abord en aidant à former les pays
membres à travers un programme complet
de formation qui est adapté aux besoins
des participants parce que comme l'a dit
l'expert scientifique allemand
sensibiliser reste la première chose est
la chose la plus importante à faire
parce que si tout le monde est conscient
de la gravité de ce qui peut se passer
de ce qui peut aider des risques et des
menaces va on a déjà résolu dix ans la
moitié du problème ensuite ils ont mis
en place dans qu'interpol a mis en place
un centre de de cyber fusion donc le cfc
qui a réuni les experts en
cybercriminalité des services chargés de
l'application de la loi et du secteur
privé afin de recueillir et d'analyser
toutes les informations disponibles sur
les activités criminelles dans le
cyberespace et ainsi fournir au pays des
renseignements cohérent exploitables
susceptibles de donner lieu à une action
par la suite opérationnels en vue
d'empêcher les infractions et de
faciliter l'identification des
malfaiteurs aussi
à travers leur laboratoire
d'informatique légal ils ont mis à la
disposition des pays donc les moyens de
renforcer leurs capacités de détection
et d'exploitation des éléments de preuve
numérique juste monde c'est pour pouvoir
retracer ces attaques là dans le cadre
du travail quotidien de la police entier
parce que là il faut il nous faut une
police du numérique merci beaucoup a
avoué rim abassi merci
et merci aux équipes du mag et
techniques pour la préparation de cette
émission retrouver à free connecte sur
nos réseaux sociaux et notre site
internet rt france pointé des merci à
vous de votre attention et à très
bientôt dans la fri connecte sur rt
france
[Musique]
y'a pas une façon plus une pauvre de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre la table sap
est une volonté collective
vous le savez comme moi que dès qu'on
dit il n'ya pas intervenir en sort du
politique il est clair que tout le monde
attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez déçu l'univers
uniforme c'est quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï pelé gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite c'était
des gens qui travaillent c'est des gens
qui avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose à leurs enfants
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soient pas publics
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est on dirait qu il y a quand
même la liberté je vous remercie de
m'avoir invité
[Musique]
oui
j'ai aussi medinski bonjour nous sommes
heureux de vous voir parmi les invités
verte et moi c'est moi merci
commençons par le sujet suivant dès 2021
touche à sa fin il y a trente ans
l'union soviétique s'est effondré nous
aurions bien sûr beaucoup de sujets à
aborder
on a un soutien au collège des
événements de la seconde guerre mondiale
rapporte à la bouche prestiti expand
mais voilà par quoi j'aimerais commencer
ça si je ne m'abuse vous avez travaillé
comme correspondant du journal russia et
avait assisté à de nombreux événements
quel âge aviez-vous à cette époque un
peu plus de 20 ans et sa
1991 j'avais 20 heures non les jeunes
ceux qui ont 21 ans aujourd'hui ne
connaissent probablement pas clairement
ces événements générations plus âgées
s'en souvient beaucoup mieux comment
avez vous perçu ces événements à
l'époque est votre vision at elle changé
depuis la branche j'étais parmi les
partisans de la démocratie la rédaction
du journal russia se trouvait à la
maison blanche nous avons passé deux
nuits inoubliables à la rédaction à la
maison blanche
on a informé on inventait parfois des
nouvelles on a imprimé des tracts on
était au centre de presse du ministère
des affaires étrangères lors de la
célèbre conférence de presse du comité
d'état pour l'état d'urgence puissent
garder un esprit on se préparer à
l'assaut d'un rail avaient des
kalachnikovs au bureau je ne sais pas
s'ils étaient chargés ou non mais il y
en avait je causerait une j'ai bien sûr
changé plusieurs fois d'opinion sur ces
événements comme tout le monde s'en
doute mais à ce moment là il y avait
bien sûr une sorte d'euphorie
démocratique incluant tous dias
et on vous dit plusieurs fois en tête
pour niveau déterminé qu'en
contre l'avant dernière est la dernière
cela intéresse tout le monde aujourd'hui
si trente ans plus tard
une personne qui n'a pas une seule fois
en 30 ans changer de point de vue sur
certains processus et événement mérite
certainement une attention et un respect
particulier
suis pas comme ça choses et
nous vivons nous évoluions il y a donc
différents avis diamétralement opposées
sur les événements de cette époque je
soutiens radicale aux défenseurs de la
maison blanche il ya helsinn ou aux
démocrates jusqu'au sympathie pour le
comité d'état d'urgence
ici dans ce spectre dans cette
perspective nous nous demandons tous les
pays tout entier qu'elle était la
meilleure option qu'aurait-il pu se
passer y est c'est maintenant nous n'en
savons rien l'histoire ne nous a pas
donné le choix il est arrivé ce qui est
arrivé
comme malheureusement cela a conduit à
des conséquences irréversibles
auxquelles nous n'avions pas pensé et
probablement si seulement j'avais pu
imaginer à l'époque en août 91 à quoi
aboutir et ces événements que certains
couples installés selon se terminerait
cet enthousiasme joyeux dans la lutte
contre le monopole du parti communiste
et la censure mais personne ne pensait
que cela aboutirait à l'effondrement
d'un grand pays sont à quoi je sers tu
verras ce procès
oui la dîmière poutine qualifie cela
très ouvertement ces derniers temps de
tragédie et d'effondrement de la russie
story * lacie savoir selon les sondages
aujourd'hui la plupart des russes
principalement ceux qui ont vécu sous
l'union soviétique regrette que cela se
soit produit comme vous le dites doha
les tiens non il ya 30 ans l'attitude
était différente qu'est ce qui a
provoqué selon vous ce changement
d'opinion lab
je ne crois pas que l'attitude était
différente c'est juste que personne
n'avait pensé ou cela mènerait il n'y
avait pas vraiment en masse de volonté
sincère de voir l'urss être dissoute
chef sans prendre en compte une partie
de la société dans les pays baltes mais
il ne s'agit que d'une partie
aussi peut-être le comportement de
l'intelligencia démocratique à moscou et
à saint pétersbourg qui avait également
tendance à se faire des illusions c'est
sur tous les autres plans nous
n'imaginions tout simplement pas congé
très le bébé avec l'eau du bain
si les chiffres globaux
je ne pouvions pas nous figurer qu'en
luttant pour l'en nous perdrions l'autre
c'est ça la question personne ne voulait
l'effondrement du pays je suis personne
ne voulait qu'un visa soit nécessaire
pour se rendre à yuma là et qu'on ne
puisse ne pas y aller du tout comme
aujourd'hui personne ne voulait de
conflit civil ou une vraie guerre en
asie centrale si dieu merci a été
surmontée d'une manière ou d'une autre
nick tonnes y demande en temps je t
embrasse moi j'attaque plus personne ne
voulait une guerre dans le caucase
personne ne pensait qu'une situation
aussi folle avec l'ukraine d'où je viens
soit possible personne ne pensait que
les troupes de l'otan seraient déployées
à quelques kilomètres des frontières de
notre pays comme tout simplement à la
frontière
nixon dont personne ne pensait que ce
pays qui a été construit pendant des
siècles par nos ancêtres seraient en
fait miraculeusement préservée dans ses
frontières d'il ya des siècles
mais quand survivent par miracle au lieu
de partir en morceaux
c'est toute là zone d' influence de
l'urss et l'union soviétique en plus du
fait qu'elle représentait en sixième des
terres émergées et 300 millions
d'habitants avait une énorme zone d'
influence et des alliés pas seulement en
europe de l'est mais aussi en asie en
afrique en amérique par tout ce à quoi
tout cela se fragmente moins bonne
attaque nous étions vous le savez un
empire à l'envers si l' empire
britannique au sommet de sa puissance
s'étendait sur un cinquième des terres
émergées quand sur lesquels le soleil ne
se couchait jamais recensée tu es en
empire qui drainait des ressources
l'urss était en empire inversée qui au
nom de certains objectifs politiques et
idéologiques sel et moi je veux être
éphémère peut être fantaisiste nombre
inutilement humaniste ou naïf chez vous
mais dense et enterré il subventionner
la moitié du monde
je t'offre tout cela cessera d'exister
qui a dit que dans ce pays les gens ont
commencé à vivre mieux après cela je ne
sais plus nous étions donc à senna
identiques
[Musique]
dont je te cite chasse le fait que la
plupart des gens regrette maintenant le
démantèlement de l'urss ne signifie pas
qu'ils veulent restaurer le système
socialiste avec tous ces inconvénients
non ils veulent juste comme je lé déjà
évoqué dans notre conversation
embarqué dans un train le soir pour se
rendre aux pays baltes se rendre
librement chez leurs parents et amis en
ukraine ils ont envie de cet étonnant
climat de fraternité et de compréhension
mutuelle qui cimentait toutes nos
républiques alliés j'ai correspondu avec
un officier vietnamiens quand j'étais
écolier il servait au sein de l'armée
populaire de libération du vietnam et
collectionner des timbres vie où ils
m'ont envoyé des timbres il a même
appris le russe pour m'écrire quelque
chose et moi je lui ai envoyé d'éteindre
soviétique j'ai du mal à imaginer
comment cela se fait aujourd'hui comme
ça qu'il y ait facebook mais on éprouve
plus de telles émotions dans les chais
medinski j'aimerais revenir à votre
évaluation des événements et obtenir des
réponses concrètes si possible et vous
d'accord avec vladimir poutine que c'est
tout de même une tragédie on vous avait
énoncé et beaucoup de points négatifs y
compris que ça a été la désintégration
de la russie historique littéralement
c'est la plus grande catastrophe
géopolitique du 20e siècle et pour notre
pays c'est tout simplement la plus
grande catastrophe géopolitique depuis
de nombreux siècles parce l'avenir
mon gars tu as laitiers
groupe de chahrazad un grand pas en
arrière pour notre puissance
l'évaluation du président l ce n'est pas
parce que je suis son conseiller que je
suis d'accord avec elle mais parce que
99% des citoyens de notre pays j'en suis
certain partage cet avis tranché cette
année télé7 les dispositifs trente ans
plus tard sentez-vous en parlant des
peuples des anciennes républiques
soviétiques je comprends qu'ils sont
tous différents mais tout de même
certaines ont peut-être tendance à se
rapprocher plus particulièrement de nous
peut-être que ce processus a été
enclenché ou qu'au contraire tout a pris
une direction différente
sur certains veulent se rapprocher de
nous et d'autres ont déjà évolué dans de
nouvelles réalités et n'ont aucune idée
de comment c'était avant beaucoup ne
connaissent déjà plus la langue brusquer
quand nous allons dans nos républiques
soeurs comme on les appelle des cas nous
constatons avec surprise et parfois même
avec le sentiment que nous devons parler
anglais avec les jeunes dans un café ce
qui me chagrine nan
parce qu'ils n'ont pas appris le russe
ils ne le connaissent pas mais ceux qui
savent ce qu'ils se souviennent c'est
vrai on envie de se rapprocher de nous
je le répète ce n'est pas une envie de
socialisme ce n'est pas une envie de
censure ou de difficultés liées à
l'autorisation d'aller à l'étranger
tiens acteurs gomis est une aspiration
envers cette idée humaniste qui unit les
gens et qui permettait de fait de
maintenir la paix et de lier des gens de
diverses nationalités
mix'art en tant que tel le problème du
nationalisme n'existait pas du tout à la
fin de l'urss grâce à ce prix il se jeta
on avait tout simplement pas ce problème
personne ne s'intéressait à votre
nationalité
pour ce qui est des blagues on pouvait
rire dans chaque république parce qu'il
y avait différentes histoires drôles
mais tout de même tout cela est apparu
très rapidement à un moment donné
les mauvaises choses apparaissent
rapidement peu d'efforts sont
nécessaires pour provoquer le mal est
bien c'est que c'était là peut-être que
c'est à cacher quelque part oui
certainement le diable existe bel et
bien
parlons du mémorial des nageurs vous
avez directement pris part à sa
construction pourquoi était si important
pour vous pourriez vous nous en dire un
peu plus sur l'idée en elle-même bien ça
n'était pas seulement important pour moi
de manière générale il nous a toujours
semblé que c'était une page
malheureusement peu connue de la seconde
guerre mondiale et qui méritaient une
attention particulière une commémoration
spéciale qui est en hommage aux héros
qui se sont battus jusqu'à la mort pour
défendre notre pays chen un chausse
trappes comme cet enchaînement de
bataille ne s'est pas terminée par une
victoire triomphale on en parle peu mais
ce n'est pas la bataille de stalingrad
ni le saillant de course qui pensent que
ni la bataille de berlin ni l'opération
back gration
c'est une sorte de verdun russe une
saignée pour les deux côtés qui a duré
plusieurs mois
comme toujours ça a été plus ou moins un
hasard d'abord les anciens combattants
se sont adressés à l'association
d'histoire militaire russe avec une
proposition visant à perpétuer cette
mémoire d'un jeune au fil des ans
l'association d'histoire militaire
avec les beaux isco vicky du mouvement
rossia parce qu'on va expédier des
bénévoles qui cherchent les restes de
soldats soviétiques sur les lieux des
combats et avec le ministère de la
défense a organisé une expédition de
recherche annuel d'excellence nous avons
déterré des milliers et des milliers de
personnes dans des fosses communes sans
nom skyways essayant d'identifier les
restes nous les avons inhumé
conformément aux lois humaines et
militaires c'est un travail sans fin
parce qu'il y à des ossements partout la
terre on est parsemé
partons maintenant nous avons trouvé une
petite maison en bois elles subsistent
encore ce qui est extraordinaire c'est
le seul endroit où staline s'est rendu
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale quand
il est allé au front
c'était l'été de l'année 1943 je crois
en tes c'est là où il a tenu une réunion
avec le commandant du front de kalinine
andrei rmn co et cette maison a été
préservé nous l'avons resterait
l'association d'histoire militaire qui
après un petit musée il y a beaucoup
d'objets liés ou commandant suprême
jusqu'aux meubles aux effets personnels
il y a même un lit sur lequel il n'a pas
dormi car la réunion a duré toute la
nuit
nous avons trouvé des gens qui étaient
les gardiens de ce musée à l'époque il y
avait d'abord un petit musée dans les
premières années d'après guerre je suis
après le 20ème congrès du parti il a été
fermé l'enseigne a été arraché et on l'a
également trouvé dans le sous sol où
elle était à moitié pourri pour ce que
nous nous avons reconstruit ce musée
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment un lieu de
pèlerinage pour les touristes qui
partent 11 h
[Musique]
et puis un groupe d'initiative s'est
formé dirigé par grigori rap ôta qui
était alors secrétaire général de
l'union de la russie et de la
biélorussie
dans quelque chose de moi censure je
le montrerai signer quatre anneaux min
son père avait participé aux combats
près de recherche et admire a
curieusement survécu et ce monument a
été érigé presque entièrement grâce aux
dons publics
il y a eu une certaine contribution
budgétaire de l'union de la russie et de
la biélorussie
ce qui est aussi très important en mai
le reste n'a rien à voir avec le budget
fédéral c'est de l'argent des
contribuables ce monument est très
respectée deux millions de personnes
l'ont déjà visité mais un peu plus d'un
an s'est écoulé depuis son inauguration
il y a un petit pavillon donc on peut
facilement compter le nombre de tickets
stoner c'est vraiment beaucoup c'était
étonnant pourquoi les gens s'y rendent
utiles est-ce qui au fait que staline y
soit allé que pouvez vous répondre
d'ailleurs aux personnes qui disent
pourquoi avons nous besoin d'un musée
concernant staline et qui sont de fait
opposés à cette idée mais ce n'est pas
au musée au sujet de staline c'est juste
qu'il est connu au sein du peuple comme
la maison de staline
vous y étiez c'est vraiment un endroit
incroyable je pense que dans n'importe
quel pays jamais un tel endroit ne
serait tombé dans l'oubli si un tel
monument exister
non marché dit cette maison n'est pas à
proximité du mémorial de relief c'est à
10 minutes en voiture
costa
mais oui il ya un juste de staline
encore une fois cela a été réalisé grâce
aux efforts du peuple pas à ceux du
ministère de la culture dont j'étais
ministre à l'époque et ni prime parce
que chez nous tout ce qui concerne le
nom de staline suscite une réaction
malsaine c'est en tort
il faut séparer le bon grain de l'ivraie
lorsque nous parlons de la répression
nous devons dire la vérité au sujet de
la répression les critiques quand on
parle de la seconde guerre mondiale on
doit dire la vérité sur la seconde
guerre mondiale bon ça sans animaux il
ne faut pas tout mettre dans le même
temps sinon apparaissent dans les têtes
des jeunes des bêtises toutes ces idées
comme on a gagné la guerre malgré
staline et schukoff comme s'ils jouent
kof se réveiller le matin en se
demandant quelle nouvelle mauvaise
opération il fallait planifié pour tuer
le plus de soldats soviétiques possible
accession c'est insupportable de voir
cela
comme le new york times pourquoi les
gens seront-ils
parce que c'est la mémoire c'était le
bon endroit semble-t-il et le complexe a
été bien conçu c'est un grand honneur
pour nous que le président russe avec la
participation du président biélorusse
les inaugurer en personne il a prononcé
beaucoup de mots inoubliable
ces derniers temps on entend parler y
compris au niveau des autorités que nous
luttons contre l'arrêt écriture de
l'histoire
mais dans les conditions de la vraie
guerre de l'information qui a lieu comme
beaucoup estiment de l'imposition de la
méfiance à l'égard de la russie et des
initiatives venant de moscou en
particulier dans ce domaine là dans
quelle mesure est-il possible de vaincre
la réécriture de l'histoire non pas à
l'intérieur du pays les à l'extérieur et
vous montez istres année
il faut dire la vérité il est impossible
de vaincre cela l'histoire a été
réécrite à toutes les époques je pense
depuis le temps des pharaons égyptiens
quand même temps un beignet comme dans
la rome antique il existait une
législation sur l'oubli des nouvelles
autorités est éliminé de vastes période
de l'histoire interdisait de mentionner
les noms des précédents dirigeants
fermant à sarrebruck diagne effacer les
inscriptions gravées sur des stèles en
pierre couper les têtes des statuts pour
les remplacer par les têtes d'autres
empereur tribe ans et consuls donc ça a
toujours été comme ça il suffit de dire
la vérité et d'essayer de préserver
cette vérité
l'humanité a parcouru un long chemin et
nous espérons qu'elle apprend au fur et
à mesure à tirer des conclusions de son
histoire
kaki et si cette vérité n'est pas
entendu ou s'ils ne veulent pas
longtemps denture grand qu il faut donc
parler plus fort vous êtes là pour ça il
y a les médias pour faire ça la vérité
se fraiera toujours un passage
on vient d'évoquer la répression pendant
des décennies nous avons tout le temps
commis les mêmes erreurs vous savez
pendant des décennies nous n'avons pas
mentionné le nom de staline dans un
contexte de positif qu'en tant que
commandant suprême
il a pourtant assumé l'entière
responsabilité de l'organisation de la
défense du pays encore et malgré de
nombreuses erreurs que beaucoup auraient
commises à sa place nous avons gagné
mais on a évité de le mentionner midi
n'est ce pas la même chose que lorsque
l'on est face à ses adversaires de
photographies ou lorsqu on arrachait des
pages des manuels concernant des gens
qui avaient été réprimées quand qu'on va
le voir les stars annie c'est la même
chose c'est la même chose mais inversés
en urgence un vrai tant que bénévole
l'histoire doit être représenté dans
toute sa complexité dans tous ses
aspects avec ces pages heureuse et ces
pages sombres ce n'est que comme cela
qu'on peut en tirer des leçons il ya de
nos jours le programme les chefs d'armée
oublié à ce sujet il ya beaucoup
d'éminents chefs militaires et agents du
renseignement dans notre pays qui pour
diverses raisons ont tout simplement été
rayés de la mémoire historique
ils ont bien sûr surtout été réprimé à
la veille de la guerre mais à sa mort si
le destin n'avait pas été aussi cruel
envers eux voyant qu'ils auraient pu
devenir maréchaux de la victoire en juin
1945 mais au lieu de cela les pages
mentionnant leur nom ont été arrachés
des manuels scolaires il ne reste rien
qu'en pas de plaque commémorative sa de
rue pas de bustes ils ont énormément
contribué au renforcement des capacités
défensives de notre pays à la
construction de l'armée rouge juste
avant la guerre idem pour les agents de
renseignement
certains d'entre eux ont été oubliés
parce qu'ils sont morts pendant les
premiers jours de la guerre ils ne sont
donc pas considérés comme héros ils sont
morts à l'été 1941 et c'est tout
certains sont morts dans d'autres
circonstances il en va d'ailleurs de
même pour les événements
révolutionnaires
nous souvenons nous de ces officiers
généraux illustre de l'armée impériale
qui ont été victimes de la révolution de
février et qui ont été mises en pièces
écrasé dans la neige par des marins ivre
à cronstadt dans la foux de joie à
l'idée de liberté de démocratie
victorieuse
serait bien on les a oubliés notamment -
si nous découvrons aujourd'hui c'est non
c'est un programme commun de
l'association d'histoire militaire c'est
notre propre travail avec le soutien du
service des renseignements extérieurs et
du ministère de la défense
nous veillons à ce que la réputation de
ces gens ne soient vraiment pas entachée
par quoi que ce soit et qu'il soit
vraiment considérer pour leur grand
mérite pour la patrie mais pas sur leur
lieu de service pas mais se troue sur
leur lieu de naissance
nous installons des plaques
commémoratives sur les écoles installons
des bustes nommons des rues en leur
honneur ces crimes années
70-80 parfois 100 ans se sont écoulés
depuis mai nous replaçons ces personnes
méritantes dans notre mémoire historique
parce que la vie avait été injuste
envers eux il y a un devoir de mémoire
nous devons honorer la mémoire de ces
gens parce qu'ils ont sacrifié leur vie
pour le pays la vérité ressort toujours
tôt ou tard notre tâche est de faire en
sorte que cela se produise tout est de
ne pas oublier cette vérité
il y a de nos jours un sujet très
concrètes pour les jeunes les forces de
l'ordre depuis déjà un certain temps
s'intéresse à des rappeurs
aujourd'hui tout le monde parle de
morgenstern
mais ce qui est curieux c'est une
nouvelle étape de la procédure a été
entamée après ses propos sur le 9 mai la
fête de la victoire pour résumer il a
dit que de nouvelles victoires étaient
nécessaires vous ne pouviez pas dépenser
autant d'argent pour les célébrations
pourriez vous commenter cela
quel point c'est dangereux de tels
propos étant donné qu'il est
effectivement très populaire
peut-on détruire sa carrière à cause de
tels propos
donc si russell a remis les biens en
raison de son niveau d'intelligence ce
très jeune homme ne s'est peut-être pas
exprimé de manière très sensée
au moment mais il faut noter que cela
reflète le point de vue dans certain
nombre de personnes regardent à lui
signé
notamment
par conséquent si ce n'est pas une
raison pour ruiner la carrière de
quelqu'un ou de le déranger mais il y as
d'autres questions sérieuses la
propagande en faveur de la drogue par
exemple on faisait cela il est
nécessaire d'appliquer des mesures
street car les rappeurs les youtuber et
autres sons populaire parmi les jeunes
dont le cerveau n'est pas entièrement
formés
et les stupéfiants en particulier la
drogue dure sont en mal absolu
dans ce cas il faut avoir recours à tous
les moyens nécessaires
mais en fin de compte ils chantent à ce
sujet depuis des années pourquoi tous
remarqué cela après certains propos sur
le jour de la victoire
ce n'est aucunement lié je crois que le
jour de la victoire n'a absolument rien
à voir avec cela mais il faut lutter
contre la drogue de la manière la plus
dure y compris contre toutes les formes
de propagande concernant les stupéfiants
surtout quand il s'agit des informations
destinées aux jeunes
il ya peu son j'ai assisté à la réunion
du club de discussion valdaï
le président vladimir poutine a
longuement parlé des défis qui se posent
à l'humanité à présenter ses thèses pour
un nouvel ordre mondial il ya eu
beaucoup de commentaires
quelqu'un a déclaré qu'il avait même
formulé une nouvelle idéologie russe
êtes vous d'accord avec cela
lorsque de telles thèses sont exprimés
peut-on dire que nous dans ce cas en la
personne du président regardons vers
l'avenir mais que nous ne nous opposons
pas la civilisation occidentale
le président a parlé de conservatisme
éclairé en tant que moyen pour
l'humanité de préserver le meilleur de
ce que notre culture et notre
civilisation ont créé au cours du
dernier millénaire
le président a expliqué que le
patriotisme au sens classique du terme
était la meilleure idéologie nationale
mais qu'est ce que le patriotisme
le patriotisme provient du mot pater ce
qui signifie perle et le patriotisme
c'est l'amour de la patrie challans qu
en france l amour pour la terre des
pères et au sens large c'est l'amour des
pères de votre famille
est il possible de trouver une meilleure
idéologie que l'amour pour sa famille
pour ses parents pour ses ancêtres pour
la terre sur laquelle on a grandi et
qu'on a cultivé et le désir de préserver
de défendre au sens étroit comme large
du mot cette terre et sa famille sarah
united chez
c'est vraiment la meilleure idéologie
qu'ils puissent être tenus en couche par
couche qui n'a écrit des vers sur
l'amour pour les cercueils paternel vous
vous souvenez le move qui agissent en
bande
sur eux reposent depuis des siècles par
la volonté de dieu lui-même
l'indépendance de l'homme est le gage de
sa grandeur niché au
oui vous ne pouvez pas dire mieux cet
amour pour son foyers natals pour les
cercueils paternel et probablement
l'idéologie officielle la plus correcte
pour l'instant du moins c'est certain
vladimir medinski merci beaucoup pour
cette conversation surtout dans un
endroit aussi intéressant vous êtes le
bienvenu venez nous rendre visite plus
souvent nous avons comme vous le voyez
beaucoup de livres intéressants sur
l'histoire de la russie
[Musique]
de tous les départements français aucun
n'est peut-être aussi intrigant et
méconnue que ce petit bout de france au
coeur de l'océan indien qu'on appelle
mayotte derrière la carte postale ce
101e département et le plus pauvre de
france fois et à la rivière l'aria tout
et c'est un peu dégueulasse
ottawa dit peiné kawase l'onu kawachi
taux
passer une pipe et il me dit rien même
pas de pain
contre l'aja beat dem et une compote qui
est bien sûr fait est-ce que vous avez
une idée de qui sont ces gens qui
attaquent un lycée
bon ça va
faire disparaître
[Musique]
et après
[Applaudissements]
veut contenir tout le monde sur l'île
évidemment quand on est assis sur une
poudrière je leur jette même pas la
pierre c'est bien m'accueillir mais
jusqu'à c1 ne leur donne de l'espoir
puis à la fin on leur dit quoi non mais
t'as pas de papiers mais écoute accroche
toi mais je sais pas de conneries pour
une fois qu'on a la parole aussi mais
est-ce que ce qu'on leur a apporté est
ce que ce système lorsqu'il est bon pour
moi notre gros point d'interrogation
exception française sentiment d'être
oubliés qui sont ces habitants qui
vivent à 8000 kilomètres de l'hexagone
est content il à nous dire entre
grandeur et misère nous sommes allés à
leur rencontre
[Musique]
en 2010 il y avait environ 200
satellites en orbite en 2021 on en
compte quatre mille et en 2030 il y en
aura plus de 100 milles autour de la
terre le secteur spatial est un domaine
stratégique
où les plus grandes puissances se
livrent une guerre économique
territoriale et militaire essentiel de
laventure c'est pas tellement laventure
scientifique et c'est d'abord une
recherche de supériorité stratégique
rien n'est simple car les intérêts sont
divergents et la concurrence totale
pourquoi vraiment hollywood est née au
nigeria et pas par exemple au sénégal au
mali tout le monde est un homme
d'affaires ont déjà vu un homme comme
femme tout le monde et businessman et
c'est assez impressionnant donc
nollywood est là clairement le vent en
poupe et les budgets ce qui est gros
budgets des films à gros budget comme
aux états unis même en france d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui le record de budget au
nigeria ces neuf millions de dollars et
une montée en gamme d'un point de vue
technique au niveau des histoires
racontées et s'est du coup ça implique
effectivement des budgets beaucoup plus
important donc il ya beaucoup de choses
qui se passent beaucoup de pays en
afrique francophone notamment qui
regarde ce qu'est ce qu'on n'est jamais
acquis et apprennent et qui essayent de
de faire pareil
[Musique]
en russie la fabrication de voitures de
cette classe a été suspendu il ya plus
de 20 ans les machines outils avaient en
moyenne 45 ans dont la toiture fuyez et
soudain on nous a confié la tâche de
créer une banque les presque à partir de
zéro l'astuce
il a fallu cinq ans pour rattraper ce
retard sur l'industrie automobile
mondiale de la planche à dessin au
premier modèle achevé ce qu'il y avait
beaucoup de sceptiques au début
eh bien il semble que les russes
fabrique une voiture ce sera amusant de
voir ce qu'ils pourront faire sur
tous leurs amis et est sur des charbons
ardents comme si on attendait un
lancement de fusée
nous devions montrer que notre industrie
automobile et est suffisamment mature
[Musique]
comment redécouvrir auguste rodin l'un
des monstres sacrés de la sculpture
en demandant un réalisateur de faire un
film pour lui rendre hommage par exemple
augusto à nos vélos et réalisateur de
films d'animation
sa passion pour la sculpture l'a amené à
utiliser la technique du volume dans ses
films primés à maintes reprise dans les
plus grands festivals internationaux
pour lettres de femmes il a accepté de
relever le défi qui lui a été proposée
réalisé un court métrage en hommage à
rodin je veux pas moi c'est j'espère que
ça va plaire parce que j'aimais quand
même beaucoup de coeur et j'aime
beaucoup ce projet de la genèse à la
projection de son film hommage c'est
toutes les étapes de la création d'un
film d'animation en volume que nous
allons découvrir à ses côtés durant ce
long et périlleux parcours il sera
accompagné de ses équipes
et de grands spécialistes de rodin
[Musique]
faire un film d'animation en volume
sur rodin c'est quand même très
intimidant parce que c'est un grand
artiste et sculpteur et je me disais est
ce que je suis à l'autre
[Musique]
lettres des femmes c'est l'histoire d'un
infirmier qui pendant la première guerre
mondiale soit il est blessé avec les
lettres d'amour qui reçoit
arrêté comme le personnage sont fait des
papiers des cartons ces lettres chargé
des mots et des sentiments viennent à la
fois réparer l'aspect physique et
spirituel
laisse pas faire
[Musique]
mon âme chérie je n'ai plus de nouvelles
depuis plusieurs semaines et je prie le
bon dieu qui ne te soit rien arrivé pour
l'hommage à rodin je ne compte pas
raconter une histoire de manière
classique je vis les travailler de
manière beaucoup plus libre
[Musique]
pour cet hommage j'ai tout de suite
pensé à la porte de l'enfer nord
d'erding que j'adore
[Musique]
la première fois que j'ai vu cette porte
ça m'a tout de suite intrigué c'est
étrange une porte qui a pas d'ouverture
qui semblent immenses lourde
cette porte mais facile parce que j'ai
l'impression qu'elle nous raconte une
histoire
[Musique]
on sent qu'il s'est vraiment des scènes
il ya des personnages qui est par dessus
un autre qui qui tire un autre d'un
fonds ou qu'il soulève
ou qu'il enfonce au ou qu'ils tombent ou
qui caresse au qui crie et on sent qu'il
ya plusieurs personnages mais le fait d
les imbriquer les autres ça fait en
sorte que ça ça donne commence
pour accompagner augusto à nos vélos
tout au long de la réalisation de son
hommage il rencontre françois
blanchetière qui a conçu l'exposition de
référence sur la porte de l'enfer
l'enfer selon rodin on peut voir
aujourd'hui à paris et dans ses environs
trois exemplaires de la porte de l'enfer
la première chronologiquement c'est
celle qui est exposé au musée rodin à
meudon qui est en plâtre et qui est
incomplète
on peut voir d'autre part un exemplaire
en plâtre complet au musée d'orsay et
puis enfin il y à un exemplaire en
bronze dans les jardins du musée rodin à
paris
c'est l'une des premières fontes en
bronze réalisée après la mort de rodin
mais conformément aux souhaits de rodin
que son oeuvre soit édité en bronze par
le musée
[Musique]
un taux
non
la porte de l'enfer quelques retards là
qu'on soit au début on a des questions
qui divisent chacun des deux vantaux et
puis à l'intérieur des scènes de groupe
c'est très clairement inspiré de la
porte du paradis de ghiberti l'une des
portes du baptistère de florence corps
d'un à vue quand il est allé en italie
au tournant en 1876 donc quelques années
avant seulement et c'est pas pour rien
si c'est la porte de l'enfer en quelque
sorte face à la porte du paradis
pour réaliser sa porte de l'enfer d'un
parent d'un
d'une source d'inspiration littéraire
qui est la divine comédie de dante la
première partie en fait de ce grand
poème le premier livre qui est l'enfer
qui décrit la traversée que dante fait
guider par virgile des neuf cercles de
l'enfer c'est vraiment le point de
départ de l'inspiration de rodin
place qui est passionnant c'est qu'on a
vraiment un état de la réflexion de
rodin sans doute vers 1881 après
quelques mois de travail un an peut-être
sais pas trop
[Musique]
oh on a cette figure à 6 on reconnaît
très bien la composition je pense que
quand on montre ça dans les salles du
musée rodin à des visiteurs qui
connaissent pas bien quand même light il
sait pas ce que c'est quand même une des
compositions les plus célèbres du monde
c'est l'ancêtre du penseur en fait et
qui probablement à ce moment-là de la
réfection de rodin représente plutôt
minos le jugent infernal celui qui
accueille si on peut dire les d'années
et qui va les assigner en fonction de
leurs péchés à l'un des cercles où ils
vont être punis
[Musique]
brodin c'est pas un intellectuel c'est
pas quelqu'un qui va écrire ses pensées
il a dépensé c'est pas la question c'est
quelqu'un d'intelligent de subtiles mais
qui manie pas la langue avec beaucoup de
facilité en revanche le crayon oui du
coup quand il lit mais il fait un petit
croquis quand une idée l'intéressent
on a des croquis très maladroit des
choses qui sont faites très vite
d'autres qui sont très travaillés où il
rajoute de la couleur des choses très
dense très épaisse on a des styles très
variés c'est des recherches ne peut pas
vraiment parler de ce qu'ils sont ce
sens que ça ne prépare pas
nécessairement à travailler sculpté mais
des recherches il y en a beaucoup que je
compare à des notes de lecture
le travail de modelage il est fait en
parallèle on en a des exemples ici c'est
très belle terre cuite qui nous montre
des figures qui sont des figures de
désespoir de lamentations des figures
très fermée sur elle même et sur leur
douleur il communique pas du tout avec
nous elles sont là dans l'enfer et sont
juste certains souffrir
[Musique]
peu à peu ils infuse dans son oeuvre une
nouvelle source d'inspiration qui aime
les fleurs du mal de baudelaire qui
petit à petit se mêlent aux éléments que
rodin est allé prendre dans la divine
comédie et petit à petit on peut on peut
dire que les fleurs du mâle traîne le
dessus
[Musique]
ici on a un très beau groupe composé par
assemblage on a deux figures qui
préexiste et que rodin modifie
[Musique]
oh
on
l'homme qui tombe et la femme accroupie
il modifie chacune des figures et les
assemble il les fait interagir
et puis sur la base il porte une
inscription une annotation qu'il grave
qui est en fait le premier 4 1 du poème
la beauté je suis belle aux mortels
comme un rêve de pierre etc ce sont les
premiers mots qui donne son titre à
l'oeuvre je suis belle
[Applaudissements]
quand j'ai vu et
là les sculptures j'ai su belle avec
l'inscription du poème de baudelaire je
suis belle en dessous ça m'a donné tout
de suite et l'idée d'utiliser un poème
aussi pour l'hommage je me suis replongé
un petit peu dans les fleurs du mal
comme je voulais faire un film
qui fasse entre deux minutes et trente
minutes je voulais un poème un peu plus
longs et donc je ne cherchais pas mal et
1 et donc j'ai trouvé que
l'hymne dans la beauté était intéressant
et à et moi j'ai trouvé que ces points
mae
était vraiment très très beau en parler
de manière générale et de la sensation
masculine et à face à une beauté
féminine
[Musique]
m
où
ou
au
augusto a choisi un poème pour lequel
roeder n'a pas
fait d'illustration dans le temple hare
de l'édition originale des fleurs du
mâle appartenant à pol gallimard sur
lequel rodin dessine mais c'est un très
très beau poème qui me semble
effectivement pertinent ça c'était je
crois que c'est un choix très très
précoce d'augusto dont sont dans sa
réflexion dans son processus créatif
en utilisant les poèmes ça va à donner
quelque chose de beaucoup plus oniriques
des beaucoup plus libre je pense que
c'est ça la puissance de la poésie c'est
qu'on ne comprend pas tout et msa à
laisse une marge quand même aux
spectateurs de pouvoir compléter des
pouvoirs et interpréter à sa façon
[Musique]
on a ces figures ces groupes que rodin
utilise en fait en dehors du contexte de
la porte auquel il donne une forme
d'autonomie ce qu'on appelle le entre
nous les évadés de la porte de l'enfer
c'est la danaïdes beaucoup de visiteurs
ont tendance à vouloir la toucher
la faunesse à genoux et la faunesse de
mots qui sont deux des figures les plus
importantes dans le tympan qui nous
montre ce type féminin qui est
visiblement celui pour le cadre d'un a
le plus de goût avec canon assez
longiligne c'est nerveux avec des
hanches qui sont pas très larges une
poitrine pas très développé dans la
porte le type féminin qui domine c'est
celui là
[Musique]
un observant la porte j'ai remarqué un
petit bas relief qui j'avais pas vu
avant qu'ils se retrouvent ils tout en
bas à droite
c'est comme une signature de rodin et où
il a fait un petit autoportrait avec une
petite bonne femme nue sur l'épaule et
moi je trouve ça très intéressant parce
que ça représente bien et à l'idée que
je m'ai fait de la manière comme rodin
représente la femme dans ses hommes
sont pas traités de manière réaliste et
naturaliste
elle représente plus un concept une idée
en fait est un peu comme des femmes sont
là pour valoriser une figure masculine
elles sont souvent a émis un peu au
dessus ou à côté un petit peu comme si
elle était là soit pour le perturber un
petit peu pour l'inspirer comme si elle
était un peu des génies aux deux ailes
faut de haut des muses
on
nous il
bien tu du ciel profond ou sortu de
l'abyme aux beautés
ton regard
infernale et divin
vers ce confusément le bienfait et le
crime
et l'on peut pour cela te comparer au
vent
le
ça c'est le résultat auquel redin arrive
vers 1890 après une décennie de travail
pour moi c'est le résultat le plus
abouti en tout cas c'est le plus complet
c'est ce lieu où il ya toutes les
figures la commande est toujours en
vigueur merlin n'a plus vraiment
déchéance il ya plus de nécessité de
terminer la porte pour ce musée du coup
ça devient une oeuvre en tant que tel
une sorte de grand bas-reliefs autonome
revient à travailler sur une seule porte
en plâtre à dire que c'est un même objet
physique et sur lequel rodin revient
ajoute retranche mais des plans qui
s'ajoutent les uns aux autres ce qui est
étonnant c'est qu'il ya des partis qui
sont beaucoup moins travaillé que
d'autres disons plus abstrait sur celle
du figuratif oui ça s'intègre avec ces
fonds un peu lave ou
matière en mouvement voilà et matières
en mouvement tout à fait
ce qui est au fond est souvent plus
ancien que ce qui est devant donc on
peut pas dire qu'on aurait dans un des
ventes aux par exemple un état plus
anciens plus dantesques et dans un autre
des vantaux un état plus récent plus
baudelairien tout ça se superposent
c'est plutôt en profondeur qu'il faut
chercher comme des strates en
archéologie finalement j'ai l'impression
la partie plus sensuelle même des
figurines du groupe des figurines sont
plus dans la partie droite de la partie
gauche mais je sais pas parce qu'on a
on en a aussi de ce côté là on a par
exemple les trois sirènes qui sont un
groupe très très sensuelle et même ce
sont des sirènes au sens où dante les
entends qui sont là pour tourmenter les
damnés donc je pense que c'est assez
assez bien répartis
[Applaudissements]
j'ai fait deux beaux arts au brésil il
s'use arrivée en france juste après
rodin j'ai connu à cette époque
j'ai travaillé un peu les arts en
général la peinture les beaucoup le
dessin et les sculptures aussi
dans l'animation c'est intéressant c'est
travailler le volume est en fait les
sculptures samassa m'intéressait
beaucoup pour ça
j'avais beaucoup temps libre donc je
profitais pour dessiner tout simplement
dessinée dans les musées
gérés découvert un petit peu plus rodin
est un des sinon un petit peu ses
oeuvres et petit à petit je commence à
voir que les choses n'étaient pas aussi
conventionnel que ça ça c'était un peu à
cheval entre un classique et il n'ya
moderne
[Musique]
j'ai pas mal dessinée comme ça librement
en dessiner au fur et à mesure qu'il
existe des vérins en décidant d'après
sculptures et après petit à petit ses
croquis sont devenus un petit peu des
scènes j'ai commencé à les assembler
ici pour moi c'est léger
et sage et les montées à ce qu'on
appelle le storyboard cédé 5 c'est
suivre les uns après les autres c'est
une étape très importante
ça ça nous permet de voir un petit peu
là là la globalité on va dire du
scénario mais un dessin
sorti du gouffre des sons issus des
astres le destin germé suite et je
progresse
suite à ça on fait un petit film on met
du rythme à un petit peu entre les
images on y rajoute la musique j'ai
rajouté justement le poème que j'avais
choisie avec ma voix par là par dessus
pour faire une maquette du film et
savoir exactement combien de temps ça va
durer donc tu t'es moque
d'être l'idée c'était pas trop de de
faire des oeuvres de rodin animé mais
j'ai gardé certaines certains sculpture
comme ici un peu ça peut faire penser à
ugolin et quand il prend la femme qui la
hisse au bout de bras et c'est vraiment
j'y suis belle voilà donc cela danaïdes
qui s'anime
dans tout ce que j'ai dessiné sari
sortait cette sensualité qui était
commune à rodin et à baudelaire est en
fait un hommage était et à rodin mais il
sentait que petit à petit il est vrai
n'est sûr en hommage aux femmes
[Musique]
ce qui me dépasse un petit peu c'est le
fait que peut-être comme beaucoup de
monde se soucier beaucoup et camille
claudel à roda
[Musique]
je suis parti sur la mer je voulais
quelque chose amer il décore qui qui
sortent et qui rendent à la mer ici déjà
un aveu qui vient couvrir l'image tu
vois ce que je veux dire donc j'ai un
peu réfléchir tous les états que je
voulais donner à la mer et forcément il
y avait une vague un moment donné et du
coup j'ai travaillé cette vague avec des
personnages qui sortait de la vague et
inconsciemment j'ai commencé à
travailler aussi les sculptures de
camille claudel
comme si et camille claudel auguste
rodin n'en faisais qu'à ma
première réaction en lisant le premier
storyboard qu'augusto avait réalisé je
trouvais que camille claudel avait
beaucoup trop de place beaucoup trop
d'importance commencer par exemple avec
la vague ça me semblait pas pertinent
parce qu'on parlait bien d'une oeuvre de
rodin et non pas d'une oeuvre de camille
claudel
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je voudrais vous poser une question
c'est un coin et la légende à camille
claudel intéresse autant le public et
peut-être s'agace un petit bleu
conservateur du musée oui ce qui est
cassé le conservateur du musée rodin
c'est qu'on
nous cherchent la petite histoire on
cherche l'anecdote on cherche à voir
camille claudel partout parce que son
histoire a fasciné elle mérite d'être
valorisé c'est un grand sculpteur
intéressant mais il n'est pas plus utile
pour sa de partir d'un attentat ce n'est
pas possible de vouloir la voir partout
on sait qu'elle a beaucoup profité au
meilleur sens du terme elle a beaucoup
appris auprès de rodin dont elle était
une élève au sens propre dont elle était
une assistante elle a contribué à la
création de re d'un épuisant elle était
évidemment la menthe la partenaire
la passion que rodin et camille claudel
ont vécu l'épanouissement sensuelle le
la relation sexuelle aussi qui s'établit
entre ça a contribué à une évolution de
l'oeuvre de rodin de son son intérêt
pour le corps féminin il est certain
qu'il ya une plus grande sensualité dans
l'oeuvre de rodin au milieu des années
1980 c'est lié à son intérêt pour
baudelaire pour les fleurs du mal qu'il
inspire beaucoup et puis s'il y est
aussi très probablement à une forme de
d'épanouissement qu'il connaît avec
camille claudel tout ça se mélange et
contribuer à l'évolution de son art
[Musique]
auteur de la très sensuelle exposition
rodin la chair le marbre aline magnien
parle du rapport qu'entretenait rodin
aux femmes et à camille claudel en
particulier
ça a été sans aucun doute une très
grande passion presque plus pour rodin
que pour camille claudel alors si on se
base sur les documents que nous avons
les lettres les plus passionnés les plus
émouvantes d'ailleurs aussi
sont celles que rodin écrit à camille
claudel et pas celle que camille claudel
écrit à odin on n'a pas ça du tout
chez camille claudel qui est quand même
très préoccupé par son travail par le
fait de pouvoir créer de pouvoir réussir
en tant qu'artiste en tant que femme
artiste c'est une autre ambition c'est
autre chose
[Rires]
la fascination de rodin pour les femmes
c'est pour le corps féminin
effectivement pour la sensualité
féminine
il disait il à une expression il dit je
dois tout aux femmes elles marchent
comme des chefs-d'oeuvre alors ça
l'empêchent pas d'être
macheist au sens où nous l'entendons
c'est à dire que la libération des
femmes est quand même très très con à
genté c'est pas c'est pas non plus dans
tous les domaines c'est pas pour tout le
mois j'aimerais rajouter à propos de
rôdeur et les femmes ce qu écrit aurel
en 1919 je trouve que le texte doral qui
était un écrivain féministe évidemment
est très intéressant à cet égard devant
l'oeil de rodin dit elle la femme ne se
sent plus obligé se sent libre 1 elle ne
se sent plus obligés d'avoir ce rôle un
peu ridicule que l'on fait jouer aux
femmes au 19e siècle de fausse timide
de pudibonde etc elle s'anime à lise dit
elle elle emploie le terme elle s'anime
à lise
[Musique]
je pense que l'époque est mûr pour ça
l'époque est prête à recevoir
des représentations du corps féminin
nouvelle autre plus libre plus réaliste
plus expressive plus sensuelle en dehors
des schémas classiques voire
néoclassique académique des pauses
convenu ça permet de comprendre aussi
ses dessins incroyable d'une certaine
manière de femmes se masturbant devant
lui deux scènes saphique très explicites
qui avait lieu manifestement devant lui
et qu'il ne pouvait demander qu'à des
femmes qui avait une grande confiance
dans son regard et qui pouvait être
devant lui parfaitement libre
la charge la force de cette libération
du désir féminin elle elle et elle peut
être tout à fait d'actualité aujourd'hui
je pense que c'est pas c'est pas plus
évident et c'est peut-être même moins
évident encore aujourd'hui que ça ne
l'était en 1900
[Musique]
à voir toutes ces infos de la part
d'aline et françois est sur les rapports
d odin aux femmes ça m'a conforté dans
cette idée que j'avais vraiment envie de
faire un film sur le sur le sur les
femmes
toute cette partie des préparations qui
j'ai fait tout cela est fini maintenant
je vais pouvoir
constituer mon équipe pour pouvoir
travailler avec moi
tous les mondes l'équipe ils viennent un
peu d horizons très différents mais dans
l'animation et ses vagues de leur
proposer de faire du rodin c'est tout de
suite ça intimide est parce que c'est
travailler l'anatomie c'est un peu plus
complexe et peut-être il mettait la
barre un peu haut on a l'impression
quand on travaille à un stop au c'est
qu'on joue un peu à la poupée c'est un
peu ça il ya en fait elles leur proposer
un hommage rodin ça faisait tout de
suite ou lors on nous propose rixe très
sérieux il faut qu'on arrête de déconner
mais là
après avoir dépassé un peu cette peur
tout le monde s'est mis au travail
[Musique]
vous
tout
m
les décors j'avais prévu il ya plusieurs
des cordes d'ateliers desrochers et tout
ça dans des matériaux différents
stable pour les décors des rochers c'est
des blocs de polystyrène et qu'on a
taillé et qu'on a peint couleur glaise
ça l'a pas trop mal
ces derniers
la télé de rodin et une bonne partie
s'est fait avec des dubois de la résine
et le les paravents ils ont été
construits au départ on affaire moule et
après des tirages
on a fait le divan pour qui a un côté
intime dans l'atelier de rodin il ya des
éléments qui sont réellement fait
anglaise parce qu'ils vont bouger et
d'autres qui sont faits dans le dur on a
peint couleur glaise et aussi des
sculpteurs et qui ont fait les
personnages à l'intérieur des
personnages il ya des armatures
l'escalette et donc il y à un autre nom
de l'équipe qui a fait l'escalette qui
vont à l'intérieur
[Musique]
l'actualité économique de la semaine
décryptées par olivier delamarche le rsa
remplit-il ses objectifs non à en croire
un rapport de la cour des comptes
comment voulez-vous avec un peu plus de
500 euros vous en tirez et vous loger et
c'est donc évidemment que c'est pas un
tremplin pour quoi que ce soit je pense
que le dispositif aura et une efficacité
si on est dans une économie réellement
solidaire pour à l'édition 2022 choose
france 21 projets d'investissements ont
été annoncées en france il ya une
contrepartie qu'on va promettre à des
entreprises si elles viennent
s'implanter que d'abord on les embêtera
pas trop sur les licenciements qu'ils
annonceront après et vous aurez une une
déduction fiscale ou des aides pour vous
installer pendant une période donnée les
fier vous qu'on l'appelle pas bientôt
lou france aussi
chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs sont joués mais les
règles ne sont pas toujours respectées
les couleurs changent de camp
les pions prennent la place des rois de
fine stratégie peuvent porter des
résultats inattendus
[Musique]
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire
[Musique]
je suis allée de chômeurs et chaque
semaine dans l'échiquier mondial nous
analyserons les coups les plus complexes
du jeu politique internationale
à bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]
parfois j'ai peur d'être enseveli sous
les rochers
quand je descends
je prie afin de ne pas y rester pour
toujours
les plongeurs savent les risques qu'ils
prennent
vous avez reçu l'ordre de fermer les
mines mais comment vous pouvez être sûr
que les mines et légales seront aussi
fermées quelqu'un vérifier oui oui
c'est illégal mais le gouvernement ferme
les yeux
[Musique]
certains se loi dans la boue
parfois je lui demande de ne pas y aller
mais il y va quand même à sable
il me dit nous n'avons plus de riz maman
ps arrivé
nous disons que c'est plutôt un travail
à mort qu'un travail à vie
[Musique]
je savais qu'il donne mon image je
voudrais être proche de rodin sculpteur
mais aussi du rodin l'homme est que ces
femmes qui étaient autour de lui dans
l'atelier elle était à la fois elle
servait commun comme un modèle et comme
voilà comment inspiration pour faire ses
sculptures ses oeuvres mais aussi pour
satisfaire un peu assez à ses désirs
personnels
augusto avance dans ses recherches il
veut en savoir plus sur l'esthétique que
rodin développe à l'aube du xxème siècle
[Musique]
cette année de ses 60 ans il est un
artiste complètement
arriver un artiste très reconnue établie
il peut se permettre de faire un petit
peu ce qu'il veut il est très libre en
fête quand il a travaillé en particulier
pour le grand monument à balzac ce
monument a pour lui était l'occasion
d'essayer des choses et son esthétique a
évolué a changé il ne cherchait plus à
avoir des oeuvres qu'ils soient d'un
mode les aussi complexe aussi creuse est
aussi contrastée avec des choses qui
sortaient des choses qui rentrent ils
voulaient quelque chose qui soit plus
nuancée d'un mode les différents il
parle à ce moment là il parle de
dhombres blonde qu'il ne veut plus
nombreux noirs arrivé des ombres blonde
des choses beaucoup plus douce plus il
avance et pluie s'affranchit de
l'obligation d'aller loin dans le fini
dans le détail il simplifie ses moyens
d'expression finalement comme beaucoup
d'artistes de grands artistes
c'est peut-être ce qui m'impressionne
c'est que leurs yeux il arrive déjà à
cette période là un certain âge où ils
commencent à se détacher beaucoup plus
de la partie on va dire académique pour
prendre vraiment des risques
c'est vrai que le balzac et moi je
trouve que c'est innovant moments
impressionnante pour sa 2 quand j'ai
appris qu'il a il a trempé une robe de
chambre dans du plâtre pour mettre sur
un bus et je trouve ça assez culotté
en fait un voyant un petit peu vers quoi
tend des rodin sama
pas mal rassuré dans ce que j'étais en
train de faire aussi de partir vers
quelque chose de beaucoup plus abstrait
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est travailler
la forme et le fond qui la forment les
fonds est un peu dans la même direction
car fait le matériel comme utiliser un
sens avec le propos
[Musique]
mon très cher si tu as du courrier
c'est vrai que dans l'être dès forme
j'ai utilisé le papier le carton parce
que ça allait avec le sujet parce qu'on
traitait des lettres et l'écriture
je t'aime je t'aime je t'aime je t'aime
je pourrais te dire
je fais pas chaque humain qu'il matières
différentes ça c'est pas forcément lié à
ça mais là moi ce qui m'intéresse le
plus de lait sculpteur rodin c'est toute
la partie un modelage vous le plus
intéressant
ou beaucoup
de nous
vous pour vous
vous pour vous ou bourg
vous vous pour vous
[Musique]
ou
vous mouvement
quand on m'a proposé de faire un sept
majeur ou d'un j'ai pas hésité une seule
seconde même avant d'avoir un sujet un
peu précis je voudrais à travailler donc
là plastiline donc la pâte à modeler
mais avec rendu glaise
une fois l'aspect graphique défini il
fallait savoir comment l'animé donc
notamment les plans de mer qui c'était
un peu compliqué car c'est vrai que
c'est un plus jeune et rapide un peu
comme des rivières s'est pas vraiment
des vagues qui suivent dans une
direction précise quoi donc on est parti
sur deux principes et une j'ai utilisé
beaucoup plus pour les plans serrés que
c'est d'utiliser la pression des pouces
sur la sur la pâte à modeler image par
image je préfère plutôt que l'aval d'une
science contraire
et donc ça ça apprend quand même
beaucoup de temps
et l'autre c'était pour les plombs large
pour faire des montées et descentes des
vagues donc on a construit une machine
avec des pistons et pourvoir faire
l'oscillation d'éveil et pour trouver
ces solutions c'était un vrai travail
d'équipé un vrai travail de
collaboration avec mon équipe en
sculpture il ya un aspect de
collaboration qui a vraiment important
on imagine toujours l'artiste tout seul
face à son plaque de marbre qui va taper
dessus comme qu'en ligne comme on
imagine michel-ange en fait c'est
largement la fantasque il ya toujours
des mouleurs il ya toujours des gens qui
peuvent même aider pour le modelage des
gens qui vont était à tailler de ne
faire tout le travail de taille du
marbre à partir des indications du
maître il ya les fondeurs qui travaille
pour faire les bronzes dont il ya
toujours d une collaboration ça me fait
penser un petit peu comme une
grand noms de la couture qui a une
maison de haute couture et qui ya les
stylistes et un taux de pétillement il
travaille je trouve la comparaison est
bonne parce qu'on n'attend pas qu'un
grand styliste chez pas que yves saint
laurent avait lui même coupé les tissus
et puis faire les points on sait très
bien qu'il ya des gens qui travaillent
pour lui n'empêche que c'est un vêtement
d'yves saint laurent une sculpture de
rodin c'est bien lui qui la vente c'est
lui qui contrôle sa réalisation mais il
ya un certain nombre de personnes autour
de lui qui travaille à partir de ces
indications vous du tout innocent
coupleux
abou
pour m
je
c'est
pour ça que moi franchement
[Musique]
mieux la voir
si on trouve plusieurs ressemblances
entre le travail d équipe d'erding et de
mon équipe et on trouve surtout une très
grande différence entre les sculptures
et l'animation c'est le mouvement tu
peut plus toucher à sa fin car notre
photo
l'animation c'est une série de photos
fixes qui ont juste à pause les unes
après les autres pour reconstituer les
mouvements
avec la feuille d'exposition on
détermine les nombre d'image qu'on
expose chaque photo afin de reconstituer
la cadence et le rythme du mouvement
j'ai l'impression que rodin et l'aimé
pas trop les cette année et la
photographie à l'époque et même la
chronophotographie et pourtant cette
démultiplication du mouvement qui fait
démarrer au mieux bridge c'est un petit
peu ce qui fait aussi un métaux
plusieurs plusieurs éléments plusieurs
personnages qu'ils ont dans des
positions différentes et qu'ils
assemblent bref je suis pas sûr que
rodin cherche à étudier les phases
successives d'un mouvement à la manière
dont la chronophotographie peut
décomposer de manière très scientifique
avec un écart de temps très précis pour
avoir une pause puis une pause puis une
pause qui vont recomposer le mouvement
quand on va les luxe a posé son idée
c'est que la photographie ment parce
qu'elle capte une réalité trop prosaïque
alors que la sculpture ou l'oeuvre d'art
parce qu'elle est capable de résumer
l'ensemble d'un mouvement en quelque
sorte dans un dans une pose précise elle
dirait plus la vérité
à ses côtés un peu de sculpture c'est à
quel moment on va figer une oeuvre est
un moment choisi ficquelmont choisi j'ai
regardé justement le
l'homme qui marche cette pause comme ça
bien les pieds bien plaqué au sol et à
ce n'est pas du tout une dépose de la
marche ça démarre mollement votre récit
isolés par la photo à vrai dire ça ne
dit pas vraiment le mouvement non plus
je trouve ce qui dit le mouvement dans
cette oeuvre là c'est plutôt le
déséquilibre mais c'est une composition
étrange c'est pas comme ça qu'on imagine
forcément la marche
parfois même le mouvement c'est reflète
un peu à travers plusieurs poses
différentes plusieurs personnages comme
on a par exemple des trois ombres oui
les trois hommes ont effectivement ils
démultiplient il fait tirer trois
épreuves du même moule et en changeant
l'angle on les voit sous un angle un peu
différent et chacune raconte un peu
autre chose et l'ensemble des trois qui
est un mouvement créé un sentiment de
vide d'opposition aussi
[Musique]
quand on parle du moule d'une figure en
général c'est en fait plusieurs moule
qui vont permettre de tirer des morceaux
séparés le torse les jambes les bras à
la tête et rodin aimait bien faire tirer
plusieurs épreuves de ces éléments
séparés pour pouvoir justement les
réassembler recomposée
c'est un petit peu comparables à des
mots des éléments d'un vocabulaire avec
lesquels on peut faire plusieurs phrases
à partir des mêmes éléments on peut
signifier autre chose et après ça
devient vraiment une façon de travailler
en fait de travailler par fragments de
rajouter des pièces à d'autres d'en
enlever ça fait quasiment un travail sur
la création au fait c'est vrai il
revient sur sa propre création il en
utilise des éléments pour créer autre
chose c'est moi un travail d'invention
en repartant de zéro en quelque sorte
qu'un travail de réinvention de
recomposition à partir de ses propres
motifs
par exemple et ce dit il ya un corps
étendu avec les bras en arrière non ses
bras en arrière mais va pas il le met en
avant un bras pliés donc j'arrache c'est
lui là je viens chercher l'autre et
gecko la place ça peut être ça ou alors
je prends ce bras qui était en du jeu le
casse au niveau du coude et je fais un
joint en ram dans le bras comme ça ça va
être très bricolé au niveau du coude
mais c'est pas très grave ça me permet
de donner forme à à mon idée à mon
impression
et puis s'il faut traduire ça en marbre
par exemple eh bien ce sera le travail
du praticien celui qui taille le marbre
sous le contrôle de rodin et à partir du
modèle que renault lui a donné ce sera
le travail du praticien d'harmoniser
tout ça de faire en sorte que
anatomiquement ce soit un peu plus juste
que ce bras cassés bricoler
pour
mais
c'était incroyable de voir la façon
comores d'un travail est un élément
d'aider les membres des partis en
ajoutant d'autres et voir toute cette
série des bras et des jambes est exposée
comme sa côte à côte dans la vitrine
c'était très très proche de ce qu'on ce
qu'on fait nous en animations
j'ai toute une série justement pour un
plan et on utilise tous ses mains pour
faire plutôt des phases de des
animations donc cédé poser différentes
et comme ça j'aurai le mouvement qui va
faire ses mouvements des mains qui va il
vient un peu anar ya un assemblant des
éléments comme ça redin il
cherchait une position parfaite et du
nous à travers toutes ses phases ce
qu'on cherche c'est d'obtenir un
mouvement qui nous intéresse
un animations on n'imite pas le vivant
disons le on veut pas et des mouvements
réalistes par exemple quelqu'un qui
enlève sa veste aucun absent pantalon on
ferra pas tous les gestes de quelqu'un
qu'elle est vraiment sa veste c'est
beaucoup plus 100 synthétique vet on
travaille plus en matière de temps ça
veut dire qu'il faut que l'on enlève la
veste 1 combien de temps comment ses
pieds le fait d'enlever la vaysse ca va
montrer quels traits de caractère du
personnage c'est ça qui est plus
intéressant même si le geste est tout à
fait du même si le geste n'est pas juste
les choses sont pas anodines en fait on
fait des jeux puisque on les fabrique et
on fait les choix
l'élément les principales donc je ne
vais c'est le squelette qui va servir de
la mâture pour le personnage est l'idée
c'est de pouvoir créer des articulations
et de
mettre dans des poses et qu'il puisse
rester et après bouger image par image
on met l'armature dans le moule en fait
on met la voiture toujours dans le moule
et après on coule au tour et comme c'est
des nues on est obligé de faire un
moulage en entier je vais vous montrer
ça bah oui il s'appelle re d'un homme
est alors là du coup il ya des des clés
qui vont dans les comptes reculé sur
l'autre moitié du moule oui c'est ça ben
justement pouvoir les fermer ça ne bouge
pas la technique traditionnelle
[Musique]
de matériel ça fait un peu comme de la
glaise c'est donc là plastiline qui
tient mieux avec la chaleur et monclar
autres liquides et le moulage s'est fait
de manière plus simple il y apparaît
fera dix ans elle devient un peu dur et
on peut la manipuler plus facilement
aussi
l'idée d'animer comme ça c'est qu'on va
l'animateur et vas y sculpter au fur et
à mesure qu'il anime aussi lève les bras
forcément et les muscles vont se
déplacer et des voeux devoir faire les
détails là il va faire chacun à chaque
image
comme c'est quand même de la pâte molle
à force de manipuler les formes vont
disparaître et du coup au bout d'un
moment il faut les remplacer par un
nouveau personnage à l'épreuve d'hier
voilà une nouvelle épreuve tiré du moule
pour pouvoir continuer à l'animation la
difficulté à l'animation c'est ça c'est
de savoir jusqu'où on peut pousser le
personnage les réparer au fur et à
mesure des transformer offert mesures et
non les remplacer quand il commence à
fatiguer on a la même problématique dans
l'atelier parce que
redin repart en fait d'une des preuves
tirées d'un même moule quand il a besoin
de faire une nouvelle version et au fur
et à mesure le modèle en plâtre suse il
est abîmée par le processus de prise
d'empreintes qu'on a les mêmes
problématiques dans l'atelier d'un
sculpteur finalement
moi ça m'amuse de voir que c'est de la
pâte à modeler de la place tilling parce
que c'est un matériau grodin à utiliser
aussi c'est un matériau synthétique est
inventé je crois à la fin du xixème
siècle et qui a fini par remplacer la
cire en tout cas qui était une
alternative à la cire et à la terre est
ronde elle a utilisé pour modeler un peu
et on a même la dent autour de nous on a
des plâtres retoucher la plasticine
parce qu'il a utilisé pas mal pour ce
soit pour modeler soit pour retoucher
des plâtres et c'est devenu pour lui un
mode de création
presque beau et plus souple que la terre
comme vous disiez ça se conserve mieux
ou
au
où
ouh
[Musique]
ou
pour
[Musique]
où
ça c'est un personnage du film que je
fais avant il date de deux ans
maintenant il y travaille et de vous que
c'est une matière pas facile animé parce
qu'il ait fait du carton et du papier
donc c'est quelque chose qui est pas
souple mais en même temps l'om est par
contre très solide très fragile pourtant
comme ça ah mais il a bien vécu lui a
traversé la guerre
je m'adresse à la guerre il ya un
tournage qui la maltraitait pas mal et
il n'a pas été beaucoup des twins
elle est très stable comme ça elle est
très verticale lui les il est
incroyablement mobile
en sculpture c'est un vrai problème
aussi il faut que la brune statique
qu'elle qu'elle puisse tenir debout mais
en même temps il faut qu'elles puissent
dans certains cas suggéré la pesanteur
le déséquilibre parce que c'est ça qui
va induire l'idée de mouvement j'imagine
qu'un animations ce n'est pas forcément
facile de ses problèmes de poids doivent
doivent être importants pour le
l'hommage de à rodin il ya un personne
qui va monter sur un petit rocher et et
qui va sortir une femme de l'eau
attirées qui va la tirer et va tirer
prendre dans ses bras et l'a soulevé un
peu comme je suis belle comme je suis
belle les actes vaut justement pour
cette histoire des positions un peu
difficile à mettre en place par exemple
en l'air on utilise ce qu'on appelle le
rig alors il va le soutenir elles
permettent de donner toutes les poses la
plus fantastique
c'est un peu l'idée en tout cas côté
bien l'air et donc ça général engouement
post prod après on les fasse des l'image
est facile rixe est une des choses qui
se règlent tout à la fin au moment du
conte positive c'est l'étape où on va
nettoyer un petit peu les images un an
les ventes ou ski indésirables et aussi
c'est la partie où on va composer les
planques été tourné en plusieurs parties
différentes
par exemple la scène de la mer qui boom
on a tourné les éléments
séparément et on a tourné d'abord
l'homme après les deux éléments des
femmes sont dans la mer et la mer à part
et au compositing on assemble tout ça
pour ses plans si on a tourné d'abord la
femme avec avec la main qui vient la
chercher
et à une autre passe avec toutes les
petites marques sont des vins
donc cette partie des danses j'ai voulu
quand même faire une animation en 2d
mais qu'ils se soient fait quand même 1
pâte à modeler qui limite aussi la
glaise méline couleur plus claire à la
façon de dessins de rodin
qu'ils fassent un peu comme en papier
découpé
tous
[Musique]
et
dessinais beaucoup comme ça avec une
petite couleur petit la vie une petite
aquarelle comme ça qui vient juste faire
le contour du personnage
de film et va faire à peu près 3 minutes
et on a pris trois mois pour le faire
quand on fait des plans qu'à chaque fois
d'urines secondes deux secondes c'est
vrai qu'en quand on montre les gens
disent ah ouais c'est super mais à et la
suite avancé tout quoi as tu as passé
deux semaines tu as fait ça
bon bah je voulais vous remercier
l'hommage à rodez a fini presque et vous
allez voir il ya des petites choses
accord doerig a viré des basques sont
pas encore finies et
la bande son n'est pas définitive c'est
une maquette mais ça donne une idée déjà
dû voilà du résultat final
vient du ciel profond ou sens-tu de
l'abyme rogotin ton regard infernale et
divin vers second fusée mans le bienfait
el krim et l'on peut pour cela tout
court barré ou 20
ce principe d'un fonds d'une matière qui
constitue le fond de l'oeuvre qui
s'anime d'où émergent des formes ça
c'est très important dans la porte de
l'enfer et c'est comme cela que le film
commence
beaucoup de petits détails que je trouve
très bien vu de petits gestes très
touchant de
le geste de pudeur de modèles féminins
qui est un moment après avoir pris une
pause redevient une femme et cherche à
dissimuler sa nudité ça j'ai trouvé ça
très bien
[Musique]
[Rires]
vient du ciel profond ou sortu delaby
main au pot tu es tu au regard infernale
et divin verse confusément le bienfait
et le crime et l'on peut pour cela de
comparer aux 20
[Musique]
sorti du gouffre noir ou descend du
désastre le destin a charmé suite et
jupons comme un chien tu sèmes au hasard
la joie est les désastres et tu
gouvernes tout
et ne réponds de rien
[Musique]
oh
[Rires]
que tu viennes du ciel ou de l'enfer
qu'importe aux beautés monstre énorme
effrayant ingénue
sithanen temps sourit tempier nouveau la
porte d'un infini que j'aime
et n'ai jamais connu
[Musique]
de satan ou de tu apportes qu'importe
anjou sirène qu'importe si tueur en fait
aux yeux de velours rythme parfum lueur
au mont unique rennes
l'univers - leader
[Musique]
et les instants
moins lourd
oh
nous
[Musique]
oh
pour
boo hoo
on
[Musique]
[Musique]
on
oh
c'est sa tête à riom j'ai mal à la tête
et aux oreilles aussi
beaucoup sont morts
ils n'ont pas su s'en sortir
c'était notre maison
et on a qui peuvent à peine marcher
après avoir plongé pour chercher de l'or
j'ai du mal à marcher maintenant
il est interdit d' extrême de l'or sans
autorisation mais aucun d'entre nous n'a
de licence ou de permis
voilà la pépite qu'elle a trouvé ça n'a
pas rapporté gros mais c'est déjà ça
[Musique]
il ya 30 ans l'union soviétique s'est
effondré comment avez vous perçu ces
événements à l'époque j'étais parmi les
partisans de la démocratie la rédaction
du journal russia se trouvait à la
maison blanche nous avons passé deux
nuits inoubliables à la rédaction à la
maison blanche on était au centre de
presse du ministère des affaires
étrangères lors de la célèbre conférence
de presse du comité d'état pour l'état
d'urgence j'ai bien sûr changé plusieurs
fois d'opinion sur ces événements comme
tout le monde s'en doute mais à ce
moment là il y avait bien sûr une sorte
d'euphorie démocratique ips enthousiasme
il est probablement si seulement j'avais
pu imaginer à l'époque en août 91 à quoi
aboutir et ces événements restent à
chaumont se terminerait cet enthousiasme
joyeux dans la lutte contre le monopole
du parti communiste et la censure en
apprenant qu presse mais personne ne
pensait que cela aboutirait à
l'effondrement d'un grand pays
certains font entendre leur voix pour
les autres le silence qui parle
[Musique]
l'afrique la nouvelle crypte hollande on
a l'impression d'assister un phénomène
de mode qui est amenée à durer
véritablement sur le continent nous
sommes juste entré dans une nouvelle ère
du système financier et la population
africaine c'est un milliard d'habitants
c'est ça à la valeur de nos crypto
monnaie
notre objectif c'est d'avoir de plus en
plus de partenaires qui acceptent notre
crypto comme moyen de paiement qu'en
scratch s'il use parce que l'argent
liquide perd de la valeur beaucoup de
pays en afrique on t'interdit
la crypto est ce que vous répondez à
cela du canal on ne peut pas dire on va
interdire la crypto tout temps qu'il ya
internet il y aura des crypto
[Musique]
des ogm c'est la cerise sur le gâteau de
la culture intensive et chimiques ou le
nombre de techniques pour faire des ogm
a explosé par quinze dernières années
les ogm c'est un outil c'est qu'il a il
ne pourra rien faire contre la faim dans
le monde puisque en fait la femme au
monde est une question politique alors
ça c'est les ogm il ya également le
glyphosate alors le livre 7 à usage
agricole on pourrait s'en passer il ya
des façons de produire qui peut se
passer de tout thermicien
des gens qui ont un intérêt à ce que ces
molécules hla soient pulvérisés sur les
champs parce que ça rapporte énormément
d'argent peut-être que ça arrange
l'industrie qu'on parle que du
glyphosate parce qu'il ya beaucoup
d'autres herbicides et sont en jeu et le
glyphosate est une molécule qui est
tombé dans le domaine public elle n'a
plus de problème dans tout le monde peut
en produire il ya d'autres herbicides
qui sont en train d'arriver il ya
beaucoup de choses qui sont dehors de
l'économie dire qu'on nous impose ces
choses là non pas parce qu'il ya un
intérêt social pascal intérêts
économiques
[Musique]
alexandre je faisais direct vous êtes
vous déjà dopé il n'y a jamais de ma vie
[Musique]
vous pensiez que la sphère du dopage en
russie était terminée pour vous trompiez
les documents sont arrivés et que j'ai
ouvert le dossier et j'ai eu
l'impression d'être recouverts de boue
la participation des athlètes russes aux
compétitions internationales est en jeu
cela concerne notamment des événements
tels que les jeux olympiques de tokyo et
la coupe du monde de football au qatar
c'est ma médaille je sais que je les
gagne honnêtement je ne la vendrai
jamais comme il ya quatre ans le
laboratoire antidopage de moscou est au
centre de ce scandale
alors qui a modifié la base de données
d'échantillons des sportifs et quel
rapport cela a t-il avec grigoriy
rodtchenko off
ils ont pu remplacer des résultats
négatifs par des résultats positifs
comme si l'athlète avait déjà consommé
des substances interdites pour
l'approcher par la suite et le faire
chanter pour de l'argent
[Musique]
julian assange a commis ce qui est le
pire dépêchés pour l' empire il a prouvé
que ce dernier était une entreprise
criminelle il a documenté ses mensonges
sont impitoyables mépris pour la vie
humaine sa corruption effrénée et ses
innombrables crimes de guerre
républicains ou démocrates conservateurs
ou travaillistes
tom ou baden ça n'a pas d'importance
ceux qui supervisent lempire ont tous la
même partition satanique
les empires tue toujours ce qui leur
infligent de sérieuses et profondes
blessures
qu'assange dont la santé physique et
psychologique est précaire et qui a subi
un avc le 27 octobre pendant une
procédure judiciaire soit condamné à
mort ne devrait pas surprendre voilà dix
ans qu'il est détenu s'étend dans
l'ambassade d'équateur à londres et
presque trois ans dans la prison de
haute sécurité de belmarsh où il doit
faire face à l'absence de lumière
naturelle et d'exercice ainsi qu'un
incessantes menaces pressions à
l'anxiété au stress ses yeux étaient
désynchronisée sa paupière droite ne se
fermait pas sa mémoire était brouillée
c'est ce qui a expliqué sa fiancée
stella maurice en parlant de son avc sa
progressive détérioration physique et
psychologique l'a amené à avoir des
hallucinations à la dépression il prend
des antidépresseurs et des médicaments
antipsychotiques
il a été observé marchant dans sa
cellule avant de s'effondrer
se donnant un coup au visage et se
frappant la tête contre le mur il a
passé des semaines dans l'aide médicale
de la prison de belmarsh les autorités
pénitentiaires ont trouvé une moitié de
lames de rasoir sous ses chaussettes il
a à plusieurs reprises appelé une ligne
de prévention du suicide géré par les
samaritains car ils pensent mettre fin à
ses jours des centaines de fois par jour
les bourreaux n'ont pas encore achevé
leur sordide travail
toussaint louverture qui mena le
mouvement d'indépendance d'haïti la
seule révolte d'esclaves qui ait réussi
dans l'histoire de l'humanité a été
physiquement anéanti de la même manière
enfermé par les français dans une
cellule exil et non chauffés et qu'on a
laissé mourir d'épuisement malnutrition
apoplexie pneumonie et sans doute
tuberculose et à moins qu'on se mobilise
pour empêcher cette exécution judiciaire
ce sera aussi le destin de julian
assange me rejoint pour discuter de
l'exécution ralenti de julian assange
son père john shipton
avant de commencer je voudrais
mentionner le très bon livre de nice
melzer concernant le procès de julian
assange et où il décrit avec des détails
abominable toutes les anormalités légal
qui ont été utilisés en plus du sa page
de réputation
tout ce qui a été fait contre votre fils
depuis 2010 et la publication désir
acquis warlogs
à la fin du livre mais l'air écrit
quelque chose que je voudrais que vous
commentiez
aussi longtemps qu assange restera
l'isolément en prison ni les états unis
ni le royaume-uni ne se presseront de
faire aboutir la procédure d'extradition
plus il est possible de faire durer
chaque procédure légale plus la
stabilité la santé d'assange se
détérioreront et plus l'effet dissuasif
sur les journalistes et les lanceurs
d'alert sera fort
comme les autorités le savent
parfaitement il ne reste plus beaucoup
de temps avant que la résistance
d'assange ne cède s'il devait mourir en
prison ou si sa santé mentale devaient
se détériorer au point de le voir être
dépossédé de ses capacité légale est
enfermé dans un institut psychiatrique
pour le reste de sa vie l' affaire
pourrait être close sans peur d'un
précédent judiciaire ou le 4 janvier
2021 serait classé par un panel de juges
consciencieux de haute cour britannique
de la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme ou en fin de compte pas la cour
suprême des etats unis
a tous je voudrais que vous en parliez
je vais dans le même sens que niels
melzer comme vous je suppose je pense
que c'est le vrai but de la longue
détention d'assange et je voulais savoir
si vous pouviez commenter cela
bonjour crise merci de me recevoir
cela rappelle le discours d'un rôle
painter
quand il a reçu son prix nobel
il avait dit c'est arrivé mais ça n'est
pas arrivé
concernant julian il a toujours été
considéré pas par moi mais néanmoins que
le royaume uni est un proxy des
intentions américaines
ce qui en réalité est faux
la torture est le fruit des institutions
le service des poursuites judiciaires de
la couronne
le bureau des affaires étrangères et le
pouvoir judiciaire
ce sont ces gens qui font cela ce sont
ces gens qui vont au travail signe un
document qui est un nouvel instrument de
torture visant julian assange puis
rentre à la maison boire un verre de vin
c'est affligeant
si je peux développer un peu
le travail de julian et de wikileaks
nous a montré toute une série de
meurtres
la corruption
la profonde criminalité des états unis
et de leurs alliés de l'otan
et un miroir de cela
un horrible miroir
c'est le traitement infligé à julian
assange depuis 13 ans
qui reflète exactement
il n'y a pas de différence qualitative
la différence n'est que quantitative
sous ce que wikileaks julian assange et
chelsea manning ont dénoncé
ce traitement qui a été démontrée et
vérifier dans le livre de nils melzer
ce traitement que l'on constate avec le
déclin progressif de julian assange
et l'intensité croissante de la
diffamation diffusées par les bouches
les plus violentes
la haine la plus vicieuse
les plus malhonnêtes calomnies
mensonges qui ont entouré julian comme
une tornade ses 13 dernières années
bien cela fait partie du processus
d'isolement parce qu'on parle vraiment
ici d'isolement le cours des événements
est devenu particulièrement dur dans
l'ambassade équateur à la fin avec
l'élection de lenin moreno qui suivait
la partition de washington qui a révoqué
la citoyenneté équatorienne de julian
son droit à l'asile
x dans les semaines qui ont précédé et
vous étiez peut-être dans l'ambassade à
ce moment-là il y à une campagne pour
essentiellement essayer de le faire
sortir est l'un des détails que je ne
connaissais pas avant de lire le livre
de nils melzer c'est qu'ils lui ont même
retiré son kit de rasage
quand il est sorti de force il est barbu
il semble débraillé et tout cela a été
fait intentionnellement
en plus de toutes ces accusations qui
s'avère être fausse les excréments sur
les murs etc
et ensuite à belmarsh il est totalement
isolé
donc il est isolé personnellement si on
parle des conditions d'incarcération
mais ce sa page de réputation qui a
commencé quasiment immédiatement après
la publication des irakiens warlogs
l'isolent de la société
oui je pense vous savez que tout
simplement et des gens écrivent ces
procédures
ainsi sera landen kahn
qui a organisé ces procédures a écrit
une autobiographie qui inclut un
chapitre dans lequel il se vante de la
manière avec laquelle il a organisé la
torture de julian assange
il se vante de son succès dans sa
manière de corrompre les gens
et les conventions d'asile
il se vante réellement d'avoir violé la
loi
et ensuite il se rend au magasin de
souvenirs de buckingham palace
s'est littéralement incroyable
il va au magasin de souvenirs de
buckingham palace
achète une jolie assiette et s'envole
pour l'équateur afin de la donner au
président moreno comme cadeaux en
remerciement du royaume uni et de soeurs
alan duncan lui même
ces gens
c'est une telle insulte faite au
président équatorien
mais ce dernier n'y voit évidemment même
pas une insulte
une telle arrogance dans l'expression de
leur victoire sur quelqu'un qui n'a pas
les moyens de se défendre et qui n'a
fait que publier ce que tous les autres
ont publié
le new york times le washington post the
der spiegel rigaux
ils ont tous publié exactement la même
chose
mais la violence du royaume uni et de
ses agents
des gens sans importance qui g sur des
cadavres pour prendre de l'importance
cela donne la nausée
aviez vous été surpris que ces organes
de presse qui ont publié ces
informations se soit ensuite retournés
contre julian
au long et bien non pas vraiment je
dirais déçu oui mais pas surpris
eux ces vingt dernières années
le royaume uni a montré des signes
d'anxiété
quant à son unité
et cette anxiété se remarque dans les
restrictions imposées
à ce qu'on peut publier
et les actions contre les mouvements
indépendantistes
comme par exemple la récente
incarcération de craig murray
donc je ne suis pas du tout surpris
qu'il souhaite détruire toutes opinions
dissidentes ou clamant la vérité face
aux récits qu'il cherche à développer te
vais
te aucunement surpris
mais que le gouvernement australien et
la justice britannique
n'arrive pas à trouver le moyen
d'arrêter de se déshonorer cela me
choque
choi
ici je peux poursuivre mon illustration
il ya une centaine de parlementaires
brésiliens qui soutiennent julian
assange
en grèce sur
390 soutiennent julian assange
en france 40 députés soutiennent julian
et c'est la même chose en espagne la
même chose en italie
en norvège neuf parlementaires
soutiennent julian assange
même à stockholm en suède il y en a deux
je peux continuer en australie il y en a
30 en nouvelle-zélande au royaume-uni
donc ce déshonneur qui est le traitement
de julian et compris partout dans le
monde et la seule manière qu'ont ces
gens de sortir de cette situation et d'y
remédier
autrement ils seront déshonoré pour
l'éternité à cause de ce traitement
honteuse d'un simple élégant et
talentueux éditeurs deux avoue
très bien après cette pause nous
poursuivrons notre conversation
concernant l'exécution au ralenti de
julian assange avec son père john
shipton
[Musique]
personne n'avait encore jamais navigué
autour du monde sur un catamaran
gonflables
je n'ai jamais cessé d'y croire allez on
fait le ménage et c'est mieux que ça
[Musique]
pour une telle croisière vous avez
besoin d'un équipage solide des gens sur
qui vous pouvez compter en toutes
circonstances
où sommes nous kelly
l'île au trésor
[Musique]
là la regarde
un bateau pirate nous a approchés au
caire reyes sonné du corps et il est
désormais chez fallu rallonger nikolic a
gardé son sang froid a pointé du doigt
les restrictions
il nous avait presque
[Musique]
nous continuons notre conversation
concernant l'exécution ralenti de julian
assange avec son père john shipton
dans la mesure où vous pouvez en parler
est-ce que vous pouvez décrire comment
la pression a commencé à se faire sentir
sur julian ce que vous avez vu
et je dois dire qu'en tant que père je
me dis qu'il doit être terrible d'avoir
à gérer ce sentiment d'impuissance
de voir son fils être soumis à quelque
chose comme ça et de ne pas être capable
d'intervenir en tant que père
en ce sens si vous voulez la colère est
une énergie
et la malveillance la plus sauvage des
malveillances sens et un déluge me met
en colère et donc me donne de l'énergie
pour continuer
et en tant que parent vous savez vous ne
regardez pas ce que ça coûte
si je peux m'exprimer ainsi
je ne peux vraiment
le détail de l'incessant
et croissants en intensité recours aux
calomnies
mes mensonges malhonnête par les juges
ce que
[Musique]
je vais vous donner un exemple
durant une audience julian et ses
avocats ont demandé si julian pouvait
s'asseoir en dehors du box en verre qui
est au fond du tribunal
et qui est destiné aux terroristes
ils ont demandé si julian
pouvait s'asseoir avec ses avocats et le
juge a répondu non donc les
circonstances font que julian doit être
à genoux dans ce box en verre et hors
murs et à travers une fente
alors que l'avocate de l'autre côté doit
être sur la pointe des pieds coller son
oreille sur la fente pour obtenir des
instructions ou donner des informations
à julian puis cet ajout diane de coller
son oreille
je veux dire ce délire se poursuit
pendant trois semaines
et
personne ne songe à y mettre fin
il pense qu'il est normal de traiter les
gens ainsi
c'est épouvantable
absolument épouvantable
vient s'ajouter à cette montagne de
comportement et ne le fait que la
magistrate barid soeur après les
audiences quelques mois après les
audiences
se voit promu
quel honneur pourquoi cette promotion
elle se retrouve promu pour avoir traité
des gens de la manière la plus
épouvantable
je suis plus que choqué je ne trouve
plus les mots
et bien après la condamnation de bradley
manning devenu chelsea manning ce juge a
aussi immédiatement été promus ils font
le sale boulot de l'état pour ce qui est
de la colère saint-augustin a dit
l'espoir a deux filles de toute beauté
la colère le courage colère face à la
situation courage d'envisager qu'elle ne
restera pas ainsi la colère étant bien
sûr quelque chose de très différent de
l'aisne parlons un peu dans la mesure où
vous le pouvez de ce que c'est torture
au ralenti cette exécution ralenti
appelez ça comme vous voulez a fait à
julian
vous savez il met un peu pénible
et inconfortable de revenir sur les
changements progressifs dans la
physionomie et la psychologie de julian
deuxième
5 mai pour parler en termes généraux il
s'est détérioré physiquement
crazy coupé il est très difficile de se
maintenir en bonne santé en prison
c'est vraiment difficile
quand vous faites face à un déluge
incessant de modifications fourbe de la
procédure par le service des poursuites
judiciaires de la couronne
sans intention de faire en sorte qu'il y
ait une procédure régulière du printemps
10 ans en public que julian
bénéficierait d'une procédure régulière
donc toutes ces choses induisent une
abrasives érosion de la substance
cette citation
la citation que vous avez prononcé à
s'applique aussi à jouer à douze joueurs
est elle la colère vous pousse à avoir
du courage et à vous battre
ce qui donne du courage aussi c'est le
soutien que julian reçoit l'échelle
mondiale de la part de gens ordinaires
et cela c'est le radose
c'est l'himalaya qui nous soutient
que des gens ordinaires voit cela et
agissent pour nous soutenir ils font des
donations ils participent à des
rassemblements
il y en allemagne 29 villes où se
tiennent des veillées tous les quinze
jours
depuis deux ans les gens se rassemblent
à sydney une fois par semaine ils se
sont rassemblés une fois par semaine
pendant deux ans à barcelone ils se sont
rassemblés une fois par semaine à
bruxelles je peux continuer encore et
encore à londres il y à des
manifestations toutes les semaines à
piccadilly
de
ce phénomène ce traitement de julian
la désagrégation de l'image de la
justice
du service des poursuites du 10 hier de
la couronne du gouvernement australien
n'est pas passé inaperçu de par le monde
d'ailleurs de terre l'autre jour j'étais
à paris
et je suis tombé sur l'ancien président
brésilien lula the rule qui m'a félicité
pris dans ses bras et dit de l'appeler
si j'avais besoin de quoi que ce soit
dilma rousseff pareil
5 la liste des gens remarquables de par
le monde vous compris qu'ils viennent
nous épauler
nous avons vous et moi il n'y a pas si
longtemps prononcer un discours à new
york
quand rogers water c'était avec nous
un rogers waters totalement dénué
d'hésitation dans sa conviction qu'il
faut cesser de torture et julian
c'était un moment amusant et fort
c'est comme s'il y avait tout un système
solaire
grandes planètes gravitant autour du
soleil que sont les circonstances
la torture le traitement et ne auquel
julian fait face lui et ce système
solaire l'emportera
je voudrais parler des humiliations
vous avez mentionné le box mais il a
aussi été l'objet de fouilles
corporelles dans et hors du tribunal ce
qui est totalement ridicule puisqu'il
était escorté vers et depuis le box et
dans son environnement carcéral à
belmarsh certains mécanismes destinés à
emily julianne sont utilisés en
permanence
pouvez vous nous dire quelque chose là
dessus
oui
le meilleur exemple de ce comportement
et ne
sait que julian a été placé dans l'est
le medic à
l'aide médicale et une aile d'isolement
c'est une zone où d'après ce que je sais
il y à un petit nombre de cellules et
ils sont complètement isolés
c'est extrêmement déprimant et ça a duré
un certain nombre de mois
les autres gens se trouvant dans cette
zone dans l'est le d'isolement sont
vous savez ils sont tous devenus fous
où ils n'ont pas de jambes ou pas de
bras dans un cas
dans un autre un homme est en train de
mourir du cancer écrit toute la nuit
comme et about com été afin de sortir
julian de l' isolement
les prisonniers ont fait une pétition
une pétition pour qu'il soit déplacé
dans l' aile de la prison
dédié aux détenus de plus de 50 ans
la pétition n'a pas marché alors les
prisonniers ont soumis une nouvelle
pétition
qui a encore échoué alors les
prisonniers ont soumis une troisième
pétition pour l'en sortir et ça a marché
voilà les circonstances
les hommes en prison se montrent plus
responsables et plus humain que ceux qui
sont en vérité chargée de rendre des
services décent aux prisonniers
c'est bouleversant
ces petits géôliers qu'ils arrivent au
travail en réfléchissant à une autre
méthode pour se distancer de la réalité
de leurs responsabilités vis-à-vis
d'êtres humains
puis qu'ils rentrent chez eux et boivent
un verre de vin
c'est quelque chose qui doit être
réformé immédiatement et
des petits heckmann ces prisonniers qui
ont fait une pétition pour julian je
sais que étant donné que quand julian a
quitté l'aide médicale ils l'ont remis à
l' isolement et les prisonniers ont fait
une pétition pour qu'il soit déplacé
dans la population générale
ils comprennent comme vous et moi et des
millions de personnes sur la planète
qu'il a parlé pour nous
qu'il ne parlait pas pour les puissants
il nous a montré la part sombre de
l'élite dirigeante mondiale et nous
n'avons peut-être pas ce genre de
pouvoir mais il ya une solidarité de ce
type
oui ce que vous soulignez la est
important
nous allons brièvement parlé si nous
pouvons
donc c'est il ya treize ans que ces
publications ont eu lieu partout sur la
planète
c'était principalement les documents sur
la guerre en irak et la guerre en
afghanistan
ces publications met un certain temps à
pénétrer la population la culture de la
compréhension
en dix ans elle y sont entrés et les
gens aux états unis en particulier se
sont inventé une expression celle de
guerre sans fin aux
ce n'est pas une expression qui vient du
sommet
c'est venu de la base alors que ces
révélations entré dans la culture et
engendrer la compréhension que les
guerres prennent fin dans l'âme de ce
thème
la guerre en irak a pris fin la guerre
en afghanistan a pris fin
et la prison de guantanamo bay qui
participent à l'appeler suppurantes du
département de la justice aux états unis
ne tardera pas à être fermé
voilà les bénéfices
de guerre ont pris fin et l'un des
épisodes les plus sombres de l'histoire
du département de la justice des états
unis touche à sa fin
voilà ce qu'ont donné julian
c'est celle ci est wikileaks au peuple
des etats-unis d'australie et du royaume
uni
très bien c'était john shipton le père
du fondateur éditeur de wikileaks julian
assange
[Musique]
y'a pas une façon plus une pauvre de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
accepter une volonté collectés vous le
savez comme moi qui ait des candidats
n'y a pas d'alternative au sens du
politique il est clair que tout le monde
attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez des sous
l'uniforme c'est quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite c'était
des gens qui travaillent c'est les gens
qui avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose à leurs enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas la ligue
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est on dirait qu il y a quand
même la liberté je vous remercie de
m'avoir invité
[Musique]
ce travail épuisant
travail forcé
[Musique]
stress
accident du travail
[Musique]
punitions corporelles
propriétaire
[Musique]
voilà des mots que nous connaissons tous
êtes vous certain que le monde dans
lequel vous vivez à aboli l esclavage
depuis des siècles
[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous regardez
l'échiquier mondial duels au sommaire
aujourd'hui deux soeurs jumelles qui
sont nées de la guerre froide me qui ont
évolué différemment la république
démocratique allemande et la république
fédérale d'allemagne séparés à la
naissance elles sont devenus par la
suite des adversaires géopolitique et se
sont livrés une bataille idéologique
pendant presque quarante ans
[Musique]
avant de poursuivre voici une brève
présentation des dirigeants les plus
emblématiques de la rfa et de la rda
c'est le blitz conrad adenauer naît le 5
janvier 1876 à cologne fils d'agréer
fier grâce à une bourse il fait des
études de droit à l'université de
fribourg puis de munich et enfin de
bonnes et entame une carrière juridique
en 1901 membre du parti catholique qui
est un trouble adenauer intègre le
conseil municipal de cologne à 1906
trois ans plus tard il devient adjoint
au maire de la ville puis en 1917 et
prend sa place de 1921 1933 il est
également président du conseil d'état de
plus à l'accession des nazis au pouvoir
il est destitué de ses fonctions et se
retire dans sa maison familiale
walter ulbricht nea lipsic le 30 juin
1893 fils d'un tailleur pauvres après
l'école primaire il devient menuisier à
l'âge de 19 ans une brique tu entres
parti social-démocrate le spd auquel
adhèrent ses parents après la première
guerre mondiale où il est mobilisé il
retourne à l'éthique et participe à la
création de la section locale du parti
communiste allemand le kpd en 1923 il
intègre le comité central est élu au rex
tag en 1928 à partir de 1933 il quitte
l'allemagne nazie pour paris prague puis
moscou en 1938 où il travaille pour le
komintern l'internationale communiste à
la fin de la guerre conrad adenauer et
rétablit en tant que maire de cologne
par les forces américaines il s'engage
alors au sein de l'union chrétienne
démocrate la cdu créé la même année qui
réunit catholiques et protestants
adenauer en devient le président dans la
zone britannique en 1946 en septembre
1949 adenauer est élu chancelier fédéral
de la nouvelle ère et femme par le
groupe parlementaire constitué par la
cdu et l'union chrétienne sociale de
bavière
en 1945 une brique trop vient en
allemagne dans la zone d'occupation
soviétique qui et contribue à la
refondation du parti communiste allemand
en 46 et crée le parti socialiste unifié
d'allemagne le sd résultant de la fusion
forcée en zone soviétique du parti
communiste et du parti social-démocrate
à partir de 1949 le nouveau parti
concentre le pouvoir en rda grâce à un
système de liste unique aux élections
walter ulbricht secrétaire général du
comité central du s&ed à partir de 1950
exerce alors le pouvoir réel
tout juste après la proclamation de la
rda son président willem piek propose
une coopération à un but de rapprocher
le plus possible les deux parties de
l'allemagne la réponse du chancelier
fédéral ne laisse pas de place au
compromis seule la rfa a le droit de
parler au nom du peuple allemand dès
lors leur rivalité ne fera que prendre
de l'ampleur économie idéologie
technologies tous les domaines sont
concernés
côté diplomatique la rda est intégré
dans le bloc soviétique alors que la rfa
coopère étroitement avec les pays de
l'europe occidentale et surtout avec les
états unis dans les années soixante dix
la détente fait fondre la glace dans les
relations bilatérales
cependant la crise interne qui éclate en
urss à la fin des années 80 affaibli les
positions soviétique en rda résultat la
destruction du mur de berlin et la
réunification des deux allemagnes
comment cette rivalité at elle marqué le
paysage géopolitique de l'époque
pourquoi la rda at elle finalement cédé
à la pression de la rfa enfin quels
défis l'allemagne moderne at-elle
héritées du passé pour répondre à toutes
ces questions nous rejoignons henri
mennecier professeur honoraire des
universités à paris iii sorbonne
nouvelle germanistes monsieur menuisier
bonjour bonjour tout d'abord pensez vous
qu'il aurait été possible de conserver
l'unité de l'allemagne après la seconde
guerre mondiale ou la division est elle
inévitable
oui je crois qu'il aurait été tout à
fait possible de conserver cette unité
après 1945 si les quatre puissances
victorieuses avait vraiment voulu le
stand et coopérer c'est un perspective
semblait d'ailleurs réaliste lors de la
conférence de yalta en février 1945
entre staline ou sauvette et churchill
c'est d'ailleurs au cours de cette même
conférence que ses dirigeants politiques
ont décidé de créer une organisation
internationale très importante l'onu
organisation des nations unies à new
york
la conférence de yalta en fait conduit
un partage du monde en zone d influence
qui ont été déterminées par les avancées
des différentes armées contre contre
l'allemagne mais les intérêts et les
objectifs divergents des vainqueurs ont
provoqué l'information de deux camps le
camp soviétique dominé par l'urss
s'étendait jusqu'à l'allemagne de l'est
là
le camp occidental avec la france et la
grande bretagne étaient dominés par les
états unis d'amérique elle s'y est
installée une coupure est ouest qui a
divisé l'europe l'allemagne et bernay on
a parlé du rideau de fer et de la guerre
froide est-ce que selon vous les
dirigeants des deux allemagne ont joué
un rôle important dans leurs
confrontations ou n'est-il que des pions
dans la lutte générale entre les camps
des capitalistes et socialiste pendant
les années d'occupation total entre 1945
et 1949 les dirigeants politiques des
deux allemagnes
n'entretenait pas de contact il
n'existait pas d'état allemand à cette
époque la vie locale et régionale se
développer simplement au niveau au
niveau locaux au niveau local ou bien
régional est sous la tutelle des alliés
dans chacune des quatre zones
d'occupation
chaque allemagne à l'est et à l'ouest a
pris une orientation idéologique et
politique différente qui ne favorise
naturellement pas le dialogue
l'allemagne de l'est étaient soumises à
la prépondérance du parti communiste
allemand devenu le est rude et
d'allemagne de l'ouest a très vite fait
le choix du libéralisme et de la
démocratie de type occidental
donc le problème des deux états
allemands fondée en 1949 a été
d'accueillir peu à peu une autonomie
vis-à-vis des alliés et à l'intérieur du
camp auquel auxquels ils la partagent
appartenait le dialogue politique entre
les deux allemagnes a commencé
véritablement en 1969 avec le chancelier
willy brandt c'est ce qu'on appelait
lost politique merci beaucoup monsieur
ménudier nous allons poursuivre notre
analyse tout de suite mais nous vous
retrouvons à la fin de cette émission
pour plus de détails sur ce thème merci
encore pendant plus de quarante ans les
relations entre les deux allemagne ont
été marquée par la rivalité la
confrontation c'est la conséquence de la
défaite complète de l'allemagne nazie
dans la seconde guerre mondiale et sa
partition par les alliés de la coalition
anti hitler après la seconde guerre
mondiale les quatre états vainqueur
l'urss les etats-unis la grande-bretagne
et la france 10 vise l'ex reich allemand
en quatre zones soviétique à l'est
américaines britanniques et françaises à
l'ouest berlin enclavé dans la zone
soviétique est aussi divisée l'urss
contrôler la partie orientale les trois
autres la partie occidentale
l'allemagne est gouvernée par un conseil
de contrôle spécial réunissant les
représentants des quatre pays alliés
pourtant au fur et à mesure que la
tension monte entre l'urss et les états
unis les divisions deviennent de plus en
plus prononcé entre la zone d'occupation
soviétique et celle des pays occidentaux
en 1947 les etats-unis la
grande-bretagne et la france unissent
leurs zones d'occupation en un ensemble
économique la trisomie en plus tard il y
introduisent une nouvelle monnaie le
deutsche mark en réponse l'urss mène
aussi une réforme monétaire dans sa zone
d'occupation et décrète en 1947 un
blocus à berlin qui va durer jusqu'en
mai 1948 en mai 1949 la république
fédérale d'allemagne est proclamé cinq
mois plus tard le parlement provisoire
de l'allemagne de l'est le vol scammeurs
c'est à dire la chambre du peuple
annonce la création de la république
démocratique allemande avec le soutien
de moscou au fil du temps la possibilité
d'une réunification s'éloigne de plus en
plus les deux états développent de
modèle politique et économique
absolument différent état fédéral selon
sa loi fondamentale l'allemagne de
l'ouest avait un système politique basé
sur le multipartisme deux partis
principaux ils sont en concurrence le
parti social démocrate d'allemagne et
l'union chrétienne démocrate d'allemagne
au contraire l'allemagne de l'est est un
état unitaire et centralisée avec un
système politique proche de celui de
l'urss
le parti socialiste unifié d'allemagne
deux mines la scène politique dans le
domaine économique la différence est
encore plus prononcée la rfa adopte un
modèle économique de marché introduit sa
propre monnaie le deutsche mark et
bénéficier du soutien américain dans le
cadre du plan marshall tous ces facteurs
ont contribué à un redressement rapide
de l'allemagne de l'ouest le miracle sur
le rhin c'est ainsi que le quotidien
britannique times qualifié les succès
économiques de la rsr à l'allemagne de
l'est elle suit l'exemple soviétique
dans la construction de son système
économique économie planifiée
collectivisation dans le domaine
agricole et nationalisation des
industries contrairement à son voisin
occidental
r d à peine à retrouver l'équilibré
économique les pénuries devienne le
quotidien des habitants de l'est
certains blâment le système de gestion
soviétique alors que les autres pointent
du doigt les conditions économiques
inéquitable en 1953 la rda est secoué
par une contestation populaire qui
exigent la démission du gouvernement et
parfois le d par des troupes soviétiques
les autorités répondent par une
dispersion brutale des manifestations et
en font incomber la responsabilité à la
rfa et aux américains qui auraient
envoyé leur agent 1 er d'air ces
événements ne font qu'amplifier l'exode
des habitants de l'allemagne de l'est
vers l'ouest ce problème qui existe
depuis la fin de la seconde guerre
mondiale frappe la main d'oeuvre de la
rda selon les estimations les plus
modestes de l'allemagne de l'est plus de
deux millions de personnes ont préféré
l'ouest à l'est entre 49 et 1960 afin
d'empêcher les migrations des personnes
la rda déploie en 1952 des patrouilles
renforcées long de la frontière avec la
rfa et autorise à ouvrir le feu sur les
habitants qui veulent fuir c'est à ce
moment là que les flux migratoires se
déplace vers berlin où le passage entre
la partie orientale et occidentale reste
peu réglementé pourtant dès 1961 cette
voie n'est plus accessible dans la nuit
du 12 au 13 août le mur de berlin est
érigée devenant l'un des symboles les
plus forts de la guerre froide à part
les migrations de main d'oeuvre la mise
en place de ce mur permet de faire
baisser l'intensité des opérations
secrètes contre la rda
espionnage propagande incendie plusieurs
organisations ouest allemande opèrent
sur le territoire de la rda des sa
proclamation parmi les plus connus
citons le groupe de combat contre
l'inhumanité et le comité des juristes
libre la r d ares répond par des
opérations pointu de ses services de
renseignement renommée la stasi il
organise par exemple l'enlèvement de
l'un des leaders du comité des juristes
libre à berlin ouest en 1952 il sera
extradé en urss où il se verra condamné
à la peine de mort entre les deux
antagonistes la diplomatie et le 6
occupe une place importante en 1955 la
rfa adopte la doctrine einstein du nom
du secrétaire d'état ouest allemand aux
affaires étrangères
l'idée d'empêcher la reconnaissance
internationale de la rd11 promettant la
rupture avec tout état par l'urss qui
nouera des liens diplomatiques avec
berlin est la doctrine est appliquée
deux fois en 1957 avec la yougoslavie et
puis en 1963 à l'encontre de cuba alors
comment la détente internationale at
elle affecté les relations entre
l'allemagne de l'ouest et de l'est
pourquoi le mur de berlin est il tombé
comment la réunification des deux
allemagne at elle bouleverser
l'échiquier mondial la réponse après la
pause
[Musique]
la passion à ses les chiens nordiques je
dirais donc le chien de race husky de
sibérie qu'est ce qu'ils représentent
pour vous ces chiens armes et leur
présente plein de choses parce que c'est
de l'amour de l'amour au quotidien je
chassais pas une motoneige assez bonne
machine c'est pour nous faire plaisir
bien souvent qui courent chaque chien à
son caractère il ya certaines de mes
chiennes avec lequel ryan par le regard
on arrive à se comprendre cette année on
a fait un parcours à l'envers arrivé à
un moment depuis des années enfin à
gauche cette année elle nous a fait
prendre la piste par la droite au fait
comment alors la chienne de tête assez
retourner elle m'a dit tu es sur ton
coup parce que c'est pas par là qu'il
faut aller c'est d'autre côté
[Musique]
appartenant à des blocs opposés les deux
allemagnes diffèrent à plusieurs égards
superficie du territoire économie ar
mais quel est le rapport de force à
l'époque entre la rda est la rfa avant
d'aller plus loin faisons le récap avec
17 millions d'habitants fin 1970 la
population de la république démocratique
allemande constitue seulement le quart
de celle de la république fédérale
d'allemagne la superficie de la rfa
représente plus du double de celle de la
rda sur le plan économique la rda adopte
un système de planification économique
c'est l'état qui joue le rôle clé dans
la vie économique du pays
l'allemagne de l'ouest mènent une
politique basée sur la libre concurrence
et l'initiative privée des entrepreneurs
bien que la rda reste derrière la rfa en
termes de productivité l'allemagne de
l'est est à la sixième place en termes
de production industrielle en europe sur
le plan militaire la rfa créé en octobre
1955 ses propres forces armées appelé le
bundeswehr trois mois plus tard la rda
met en place sa propre armée l'armée
nationale populaire cependant son nombre
selon les données de 1981 n'est que 280
mille soldats contre 495 mille soldats
en rfa en revanche l'allemagne de l'est
un atout de taille son ministère de la
sécurité d'état ou la stasi autrefois
l'un des services de renseignements les
plus puissants du monde les années 60 se
traduisent par un certain dégel des
relations est ouest dans ce contexte à
rda et la rfa font aussi leur premier
pas timide vers la détente en 1963 en
allemagne de l'ouest le parti
social-démocrate énonce une nouvelle
conception de la politique étrangère le
changement par le rapprochement l'idée
de nouer le dialogue avec l'est en
laissant pour l'instant de côté la
question de la réunification
la coalition au pouvoir en adopte
quelques éléments toujours en 1963 le
protocole de berlin permet à des
centaines de milliers de berlinois de
l'ouest de visiter leurs proches à l'est
pour la première fois depuis la
construction du mur en 1967 pour la
toute première fois la rfa entre en
correspondance officielle avec la rda
ensuite bonne
va à l'encontre de la doctrine einstein
et établi des relations avec la roumanie
socialiste et renoue avec la yougoslavie
en 1968 les deux allemagnes s'accordent
pour libérer le commerce bilatéral ce
rapprochement s'accélère dès 1969 la
doctrine einstein commence à montrer ses
limites de plus en plus de pays
reconnaissent la rda et l'agent d'agglo
ballet dominé de plus en plus par la
détente américano soviétique à bonn ce
contexte propice au pouvoir les
partisans du dialogue le parti social
démocrate
dès son discours d'investiture le
nouveau chancelier willy brandt annonce
donc un tournant vers l'est une ligne
politique connue sous le nom dost
politique
vingt ans après la fondation de la rfa
et de la rda nous devons empêcher
l'évolution divergente de la nation
allemande
en d'autres mots nous devons tenter de
progresser d'abord via une coexistence
harmonieuse vers la cohésion ce n'est
pas un objectif purement allemand il est
aussi important pour la paix en europe
et pour la relation est ouest très vite
les paroles laisse la place aux actes en
novembre l'ouest renonce formellement
aux ambitions nucléaires
en rejoignant le traité de
non-prolifération
février 1970 la doctrine einstein est
officiellement abandonné cela suffit
pour briser la glace le tout premier
sommet est ouest a lieu en mars mais ne
donne pas de résultats concrets
la rda et surtout son chef walter
ulbricht reste méfiant envers
l'ostpolitik une brique tu démissionnes
en 1971 c'est à ce moment là que le
dialogue est ouest décolle vraiment
plusieurs traités ponctuelles sont
signés avant l'aboutissement du texte le
plus important celui qui en décembre
1972 posera les bases de leur relation
les deux allemagnes se proclame égales
en droit en terrine leurs frontières
nous la coopération et et procède à un
échange de représentants sur le plan
bilatéral la normalisation amène à un
nouveau niveau d'intégration des deux
états les relations commerciales
s'intensifier et le volume des échanges
ne cesse de croître vers 1985 et latin
15 bull 5 milliards de marks ouest
allemand conscient de sa supériorité
économique bonne subventionne plusieurs
projets d'infrastructure liant l'est et
l'ouest dans l'espoir d'accélérer la
voie vers l'intégration la rfa ne cesse
d'élargir la ligne de crédit accordée à
la rda ce soft power lui permet de
décrocher des concessions notamment dans
le domaine des visas et des échanges
humanitaires ce qui favorise le
développement des contacts au niveau
culturel et social l'établissement de
partenariats entre les universités ou
entre les villes des deux états si
berlin est accepte volontiers ses
aspects du rapprochement sur le plan
politique il continue de s'opposer à
l'ouest des contacts toujours plus
nombreux au niveau des populations et la
propagande active de l'unification
allemande par la rfa pousse la rda à
défendre davantage sa souveraineté ainsi
dans les années 70 la nation allemande
dans la constitution et est remplacé par
un état socialiste des ouvriers et
paysans dans les noms des institutions
publiques les mots allemands et
allemagne sont remplacés par rda le mur
est sans cesse perfectionnés et devient
de plus en plus infranchissable est la
pression sur les dissidents montrent les
années 80 seront le dernier chapitre du
duel entre les deux allemagnes en
transigeant tu dans son roger de
l'unification la rda traverse une
période difficile qui préfigure sa chute
depuis le début des années 80
l'allemagne de l'est s'enfonce dans une
crise économique l'écart technologique
s'accentue de plus en plus et pèse sur
la croissance le budget est en déficit
permanent à cause de larges dépenses
sociales la dette publique
s'accumulaient atteint 20,9 milliards de
dollars en 1989 le niveau de vie de
l'est contraste de plus en plus avec
l'ouest capitaliste à ses problèmes
internes s'ajoutent les bouleversements
qui se coule qu'on socialiste à la fin
des années 80 dès 1987 l'urss se réalise
un tournant idéologique qui entame la
pérestroïka le gouvernement de la rda
rejette
so lu ment cette politique cette
inflexibilité contraste avec la vive
réaction de la population et la hausse
de l'activisme politique en 1989
l'europe orientale traverse une série de
révolutions de velours sous les slogans
de liberté
d'autodétermination et d'économie de
marché ce qui mènera à la chute du
régime communiste en pologne en hongrie
et en tchécoslovaquie
ces pays ouvrent leurs frontières avec
l'occident du coup les allemands de
l'est se précipitent par milliers pour
quitter la rda via leur territoire
tout cela amène la population à se
mobiliser de plus en plus activement
pour réclamer des changements à
l'automne 89 les événements s'accélèrent
à la proche de la date symbolique des 40
ans de la fondation de la rda les
manifestations pour le changement inonde
plusieurs villes de l'est le 7 octobre
l'anniversaire de la fondation de la rda
mikhaïl gorbatchev effectué une visite à
berlin et entend la foule scandait
aide-nous gorby l'intensité de ce
mouvement populaire amène le
gouvernement est allemand à la démission
le nouveau chef de l'état egon krenz est
vite aux demandes de la population
il proclame la fin du monopole du parti
socialiste en rda ouvrant la voie aux
premières élections libres pourtant le
changement le plus important a mené par
le nouveau gouvernement et la chute du
mur de berlin le soir du 9 novembre le
porte parole du gouvernement annonce la
fin des restrictions de voyage depuis
l'est vers l'ouest pour les citoyens de
la rda il s'avère plus tard qu'il
s'agissait d'une erreur les nouvelles
règles ne devait pas être introduites
immédiatement cependant l'annoncé fait
l'effet d'une bombe des centaines de
milliers d'allemands des deux côtés font
sur la frontière sous la pression de la
foule les gardes sont forcés d'ouvrir le
passage le parti socialiste de la rda se
désintègre et en mars 1990 le parti
chrétien-démocrate gagne les élections
le même parti est déjà au pouvoir en rfa
de là il ne reste qu'un pas vers la
réunification de l'allemagne
en rfa le chancelier helmut kohl se
saisit du moment pour amorcer les
négociations sur la réunification avec
l'est en même temps débute les
pourparlers au format de +4 entre deux
allemagne et les quatre puissances
alliées de la seconde guerre mondiale
helmut khol parvient à convaincre l'urss
a accepté que la future allemagne unis
soient membres de l'otan en échange de
l'aide économique le 12 septembre le
format de +46 le traité portant
règlement définitif concernant
l'allemagne ou traité de moscou le rss
accepte de retirer ses troupes de la rda
le 3 octobre les territoires de la rda
sont joints à la rfa et la rda cesse
d'exister la réunification des deux
allemagnes marque aussi la fin de la
guerre froide quel impact cette page de
l'histoire allemande aura-t-elle sur la
construction européenne dans les années
90 pour y voir plus clair nous revenons
vers henry menuisier professeur
honoraire des universités à paris iii
sorbonne nouvelle germanistes monsieur
ménudier quel a été le moment qui après
déterminée et la réunification de
l'allemagne le régime politique
économique et sociale de la rda était à
bout de souffle au début des années 1980
de plus en plus allemands de l'ouest de
l'est partez sur réfugiés à l'ouest
l'économie se serait effondré sans les
prêts financiers de la république
fédérale la fragilité du régime a été
accentuée par les effets du contexte
international
à partir de 1980 1981 la révolution
solidarnosc en pologne avec les chevals
enza a ébranlé le monde soviétique mais
également la r&d à la pologne de la rda
ayant une frontière commune les réformes
ensuite économique et social de mikhaïl
gorbatchev
à partir de 1985 c'est à dire la
pérestroïka et de l'afnor la snsm ont eu
un très fort retentissement en rda
comme les dirigeants de berlin-est se
réfugier ce refus se refuser de faire
des réformes qu'il craignait de pouvoir
contrôler citoyens de rda quitter
massivement le pays en 1989 pour réduire
cette pression la rd a décidé d'ouvrir
le mur de berlin le 9 novembre 1989
c'était le premier pas vers la
réunification de l'allemagne qui a eu
lieu le 3 octobre 1990 certains ex
allemands de l'est estiment qu'un mur
invisible existe toujours entre l'est et
l'ouest
êtes vous d'accord avec ça à partir de
s'effectue
immédiatement par l'intégration de la
rda d'un système politique économique et
sociale de la manne fédérale sans
période de transition donc cette
réunification a eu lieu très vite et
elle a beaucoup bousculé les allemands
de l'est il en résulte un effondrement
économique et une forte poussée du
chômage à l'est malgré l'aide financière
importante l'allemagne de l'ouest les
cas politiques économiques sociales et
culturelles persistent entre les deux
allemagnes il s'agit non seulement du
chômage mais aussi du niveau de vie dix
salaires et de l'évolution démographique
les jeunes allemands de l'est par l
ouest pour y trouver des emplois
laissant à l'est une population
vieillissante et dans le nombre
d'habitants sur terre de se se réduit on
note aussi d'importantes différences
politiques entre les deux allemagne les
partis fondés à l'ouest comme la cd ou
le spt le fdp et les verts stores -
moins bien représentés en allemagne de
l'est qu'à l'ouest en revanche la gauche
août d-link aux racines communiste et
l'extrême droite la mt sont bien
implantés
allemagne de l'est donc effectivement il
ya bien une séparation un mur invisible
qui continue d'exister entre les deux
allemagnes merci beaucoup monsieur
ménudier je rappelle vous êtes
professeur honoraire des universités à
paris iii sorbonne nouvelle germanistes
merci pour cette analyse
cette partie là n'est pas encore
terminée la semaine prochaine une
nouvelle partie vous attend avec
d'autres pions sur l'échiquier mondial à
bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]
de tous les départements français aucun
n'est peut-être aussi intrigant et
méconnue que ce petit bout de france au
coeur de l'océan indien qu'on appelle
mayotte derrière la carte postale ce
101e département et le plus pauvre de
france foyer à la rivière là il ya tout
et c'est un peu dégueulasse
type ethnique à oisy l'onu kawachi trop
basse et une dictée il me dit il n'ya
même pas de pain donc là je lui donnais
une compote qui est bien ce qu'est ce
que vous avez une idée de qui sont ces
gens qui attaquent un lycée
bon ça va
danse
[Musique]
et après
[Applaudissements]
veut contenir tout le monde sur l'île
évidemment que l'on est assez sur une
poudrière enfin moi je leur jette même
pas la pierre c'est bien l'accueillir
mais je cassais un mot leur donne de
l'espoir et puis à la fin on leur dit
quoi non mais t'as pas de papiers des
écoutes accroche-toi mais j'ai pas de
conneries pour une fois qu'on a la
parole a aussi dit mais est-ce que ce
qu'on leur a apporté est ce que ce
système là ce qu'il est bon pour moi
notre gros point d'interrogation
exception française sentiment d'être
oubliés qui sont ses habitants qui
vivent à 8000 kilomètres de l'hexagone
est content il à nous dire entre
grandeur et misère nous sommes allés à
leur rencontre
[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire je reçois aujourd'hui judith
et non l'une des commissaires de
l'exposition quartiers et les arts de
l'islam qui se tient au musée des arts
décoratifs jusqu'au 20 février
fabrice gaignault pour son roman la
ville est plus douce et benoît doremus
qui sort son cinquième album désolé pour
les fantômes et l'on commence comme
toujours pas les images que vous avez
choisie pour illustrer notre époque la
vôtre benoît lavoie chi
je crois voir ce qu il s'agit mais
préciser quand même on voit beaucoup de
choses justement c'est pour ça que j'ai
choisi pour résumer notre époque gelé
quelque chose qui englobe un peu ce
qu'elle le diront qu'on voit un petit
bout les ss à gauche tant que c'est une
photo prise par thomas pesquet well as
alors il faut bien garder c'est tout en
bas à gauche si effectivement type à
normétal voilà cbs j'étais j'ai suivi de
près ce qu'il a fait je contiens il
écouter vos chansons dans un rossi m'a
fait ses petits cadeaux me fait un petit
clin d'oeil de la hook était incroyable
je le suivais avant ça et puis cette
photo pour moi résume beaucoup de choses
on y voit là la fragilité de la terre
évidemment que le climat qui nous affole
tous et puis à la fois je trouvais que
ça renvoie vers la maîtrise de
l'humanité avec la technologie
incroyable et le progrès avec une
majuscule et puis je trouvais j'ai
choisi aussi parce que ça m'évoque le
recul dont on manque souvent et je
l'envié un petit peu thomas pesquet
d'être là où est d'avoir cette vision
d'ensemble sur une petite bulle de savon
dans laquelle on vit et voilà moi c'est
un recul que j'ai pas du tout au
quotidien je l'envié pour ça fabrice
gaignault votre photo à vous alors moi
je
faisais des photos à moi je suis trompé
de l'époque
c'est pas trés passerait de 70
donc ça c'est laisser oui ces pompes lon
donc la grande plage de saint tropez
dans les années soixante dix apparemment
ce que je peux voir de près les bêtes
sait et c'est un des personnages si
j'ose dire face et un une situation
assez importante dans livres puisque
c'est un lieu où va se
où le personnage va va découvrir l'amour
dans les bras d'une jeune fille de son
âge et puis c'est l'époque aussi que je
dépeins sur les seins nus qui sont pas
très nul à nantes c'était l'époque des
seins nus sur la plage et de l'espèce
d'exubérance des années 70 avec les
avantages et les inconvénients des
foulées il faut on reviendra en effet
est sûre ça tropez et sur les années 60
70 tout à l'heure vous gênez que la
photo
alors je vois qu'il ya de l'art
islamique en bas c'est une vue de
d'une des expositions qui ont lieu en ce
moment dans 18 villes en france consacré
aux arts de l'islam qui s'appelle un
passé pour un présente une vue de
l'exposition figeac et pour moi ça
illustre vraiment l'envié j'irai le
besoin de culture qu'on a en ce moment
après ces longs mois sans musée
et le public est au rendez-vous en fait
c'est un vrai succès populaire et bien
commençons
[Musique]
judith et non vous êtes directrice
adjointe au département des arts de
l'islam au musée du louvre et vous êtes
l'une des commissaires de l'exposition
quartiers et les arts de l'islam qui se
tient jusqu'au 20 février au musée des
arts décoratifs à paris alors il faut
d'abord comprendre que paris au tout
début du 20e siècle c'est la plaque
tournante du commerce
des arts islamiques tout à fait pourquoi
pourquoi il ya plusieurs raisons
effectivement
la langue française l'implantation
[Musique]
des français dans des villes comme le
caire comme istanbul qui sont des lieux
importants pour le commerce de l'art
islamique et c'est surtout le lieu où
vont se tenir de grandes expositions
à paris parly pardon et donc
effectivement ce n'est pas la seule on à
londres aussi qui attire un certain
nombre d'oeuvres mais paris c'est
vraiment le lieu si on veut constituer à
cette époque une collection d'art
islamique ouais vous dites amendant le
dans le catalogue qu' il ya des types
qui viennent en iran chercher du 2e qui
y trouvent rien on leur dit mais c'est
déjà parti à paris
voyageurs qui reviennent bredouilles en
dix ans mais en fait les marchands et
notamment les marchands arménien puisque
ce sont eux qui s'empare notamment de ce
commerce de l'art islamique sur place en
iran les marchands arméniens ont envoyé
toutes les pièces de qualité déjà paris
donc en fait sur place on trouve plus
rien vivement et
c'est le moment où on reconnaît que ça
fait partie de l'histoire de l'art parce
que les occidentaux ont toujours été
assez jaloux dans ce domaine les
américains sont rentrés dans l'histoire
de l'art quasiment dans les années 60
avant fin non le depping apollo un peu
avant mais mais avant la seconde guerre
mondiale il n'y a que les français les
anglais les italiens les espagnols dans
l'histoire de l'art y a personne d'autre
en fait c'est vraiment au début de ce
xxème siècle qu'on a un petit courant de
d'amateurs qui vont essayer de faire
émerger les arts de l'islam comme une
discipline scientifique à travers des
expositions
et la plus marquante est certainement
celle qui est organisée à munich en 1910
et qui est la première à présenter des
oeuvres d'art islamique sans
accumulation sans décor où il ya une
vraie rupture avec l'orientalisme des
expositions précédentes et là on a des
oeuvres qui sont de très belles qualités
qui sont présentés sans décor pour leurs
qualités propres et c'est vraiment ce à
cette date qu'on peut dire qu'on a que
colis que les arts de l'islam rentrer
dans l'histoire de l'art véritablement
et ça va déclencher des passions et
notamment chez louis cartier le moment
là la tête de la maison cartier mais
reste haut sur les arts de l'islam dit
également que au fond ça amplifie l'idée
qu'on a à ce moment là de la décadence
de l'art occidental
oui tout à fait en est on a l'impression
qu'on est en décadence alors que pour
nous rétrospectivement on se dit que
cette époque extraordinaire artiste et
alors on est dans des époques
historiciste ont copié les périodes
précédentes les périodes antérieures et
on a l'impression qu'on est à bout de
souffle et con qu'on est à court
d'inspiration et en fait
ces amateurs justement qu'ils vont
utiliser la risque vont utiliser l'art
islamique pour essayer de donner un
nouveau souffle à la création et pour
fournir de nouveaux modèles aux artistes
et ça n'a marché oui ça va influencer
les artistes ça va influencer la
décoration ça va influencer la mode zoom
s'habille ça va influencer la joaillerie
notamment à travers quartier les objets
de luxe pas seulement les bijoux et un
quartier fait aussi des objets de luxe
ddd boîtes de cigarettes sert à tout ça
va être on va le voir en train daris
lamic mais est-ce que les gens qui les
achètent est-ce que les gens à ce moment
là qu'ils s'habillent de cette façon est
ce qu'ils sont confiants alors pas
toujours en tout cas pour les bijoux de
chez cartier je ne pense pas
alors il ya c'est la grande époque où on
fait des bals costumés on s'habille ont
fait le bal des milieux de la mi lé
deuxième nuit donc là oui bien
évidemment qu'on est conscient
dans les décors aussi c'est l'époque des
balais russe qui vont jouer à paris pour
la première fois donc et on joue
sherazade voilà donc là effectivement on
est conscient après je dois dire que
cela par exemple quand on voit ces
objets par exemple ce qui ressort de
cette de l'analyse en tout cas qu'on a
faim de de cette recherche dont
l'exposition et le résultat c'est que
très probablement
les formes utilisées notamment par la
maison cartier sont tellement intégrée
qui a pas forcément une conscience que
ces objets sont inspirés par les arts de
l'islam oui c'est ça
c'est il ya parfois même de pure copie
parfois on est très proche du modèle et
d'autres fois on est très éloigné dire
que eux
c'est notamment grâce au dessin vous
montrer les dessins ce sont les dessins
qui nous ont permis parfois de de
prouver notre hypothèse de départ parce
que initialement on disait voilà est-ce
que c est ce que ce sont les uns et cela
mais est-ce que c'est pas l'asie est ce
que est ce qu'on se trompe pas en
faisant le lien entre
une mosaïque et alors là là c'est plus
évident mais parfois ça l'était moins et
effectivement grâce au dessin on a pu
reconstituer tout processus créatif et
parfois apporter la preuve que la source
d'inspiration c'était bien une pièce
d'art islamique et est ce qu'on s'en
inspire par nostalgie un peu comme
fabrice gaignault s'inspire des années
60 et il n'est pas le seul on est en
visite grande époque de d'ostalgie
aujourd'hui en france est ce que c'est
de la nostalgie pas du tout parce qu'en
fait il faut avoir en tête qu'à l'époque
on ne voyage pas aussi facilement
qu'aujourd'hui on n'a pas accès à ces
oeuvres est que justement la découverte
de ses oeuvres à travers le marché de
l'art parisien constitue un vrai
véritable choc esthétique notamment pour
les artistes on découvre les arts de
l'islam pour la première fois mais ça
peut être pardon je voulais dire par par
nostalgie dans le sens où il ya une
préciosité il ya des matériaux qu'on est
peut-être et à ce moment là en train de
perdre déjà
non je dirais pas vraiment par nostalgie
je dirais qu'on est vraiment dans
quelque chose de complètement nouveau et
complètement innovant et vous dites
d'ailleurs c'est le sous titre de
l'exposition aux sources de la mort de
la modernité un tout à fait parce qu'en
fait on se rend compte en étudiant le
vocabulaire de la maison cartier que
cette inspiration qu'ils vont puiser
dans les arts de l'islam et notamment
dans les formes géométriques parce qu'à
l'époque on dans la bijouterie on ne
trouve pas beaucoup de formes
géométriques
on est plutôt en tout cas chez cartier
dans le style guirlandes c'est à dire on
s'inspire des enroulements végétaux des
ferronneries du xviiie des pompons des
noeuds ils vont trouver dans l'art
islamique des formes assez pur
assez éthérée qu'ils vont employer et on
peut on peut on peut dire que grâce aux
arts de l'islam ils vont amorcer les
prémices de l'art déco tout en sautant
la période de l'art nouveau ils ne font
pas du tout d'un nouveau et ils vont
passer de ce style guirlandes un petit
peu
conduire un petit peu chargé à ses
formes géométriques qui vont amorcer
l'art déco et donc ils vont rentrer dans
une certaine modernité à travers ses
inspirations islamique il ya l'inde
aussi qui va avoir beaucoup d' influence
sur la maison cartier mais à partir des
années 20 30 ans plus tôt
de manière antérieures parce qu'en fait
ce qu'on a ce qu'on a démontré dans
l'exposition c'est tout à fait très tôt
la maison va s'intéresser à l'inde
ils vont envoyer les frères quartier
vous renvoyer jacques le plus jeune
frère en 1 de faire un très grand voyage
pour nous est de
des liens étroits avec la clientèle des
maharadjahs mais pas uniquement
également pour trouver des sources
d'approvisionnement en pierres
précieuses et en perles parce qu'il sera
ensuite à bahreïn et il va rapporter
dans ses valises de nombreux bijoux
indiens que la maison va vendre parfois
tel quel donc ils vont faire plusieurs
expositions à londres à paris à boston à
new york où ils vont vendre des bijoux
indiens et ensuite on voit qu'ils vont
les modifier les transformer c'est le
cas voilà tout un pays où ces
magnifiques saône et oui c'est vraiment
magnifique là on est devant un le
collier d'un grand que le bracelet d'un
grand collectionneur d'art islamique qui
s'appelle search hester betty dont la
bibliothèque est aujourd'hui à dublin
avec le celui dont une collection tout à
fait alors certes chester betty amène
les pierres que vous voyez qui sont des
amulettes iranienne il amène les pierres
et quartier va réaliser ce bracelet qui
est inspirée d'un modèle qu'il trouve
dans un ouvrage qui est consacré aux
bijoux indiens qui est écrit par soir
thomas scène lait et on a le livre dans
la bibliothèque
de la maison qui était un livre qui
était accessible aux dessinateurs et on
fait le lien du point entre cette
inspiration de cet ouvrage le bracelet
qui elle réalise avec des pierres
iranienne
et à une drion oui fabrice gaignault
boucherie qui est un petit côté mondrian
oui mais ça c'est vraiment la modernité
géométriques les ailes et au sol et vous
montrait bien en fait dans cette
exposition tout le côté géométriques je
voulais qu'on trouve très moderne et
très occidentale en fait elle vient de
là
et d'ailleurs c'est une question que
j'avais envie de vous poser on parle
beaucoup d' islam en france depuis
quelques années je pense même qu'on en a
jamais autant parlé vous en tant que
spécialiste des arts islamiques est ce
que vous y reconnaissez est ce que les
discussions les débats qui peuvent y
avoir avoir lieu sur l'islam ont un
rapport avec l'islam que vous connaissez
vous non parce que nous vraiment on
traite de la civilisation islamique
c'est vrai qu'on fait parfois le mélange
quand on parle d'art de l'islam on parle
des arts qui se sont développées dans la
civilisation
islamique du du milieu du 7e siècle
jusqu'au 19ème siècle et qui sont
d'ailleurs
produite en fin de la civilisation
islamique
c'est une mosaïque de peuples c'est une
mosaïque de langues c'est une mosaïque
de religion mais ce n'est pas un art
uniquement religieux bien sûr qu'on a
des pièces qui sont réalisés à
destination de deux mosquées de
monuments religieux mais pas uniquement
on a beaucoup d'objets de luxe produits
pour des élites urbaines des objets du
quotidien aussi et quand on dit que il
n'y a pas de représentation du visage
dans les arts islamiques c'est vrai
regardez les photos qui défilent
derrière nous
quand elle servait aux tous premiers
tableaux de tabac attraper quand j'ai vu
les premiers tableaux figuration
effectivement il ya une interdiction et
une interdiction de la figuration dans
là on envoie comptant les lieux
religieux mais je dirais c'est une
civilisation du livre on est on connaît
énormément manuscrits énormément de
peinture ce sont ces peintures justement
là vous avez des peintures qui
proviennent de la collection louis
cartier sa collection personnelle qu'il
constitue justement après avoir
découvert l'exposition de munich et fait
notable c'est que cette collection il va
la mettre à disposition de ces
dessinateurs pour les inspirer par ton
jeu mais je m'éloigne un petit peu et
donc vous voyez que c'est bien sûr une
civilisation aussi de l'image on a
énormément d'image mais le contexte
voilà là on est dans un manuscrit dans
quelque chose qu'on regarde de manière
intime
quand on l'a dit l'affluence que ça va
avoir sur sur une certaine modernité est
évidente ça va avoir de l' influence
surtout les noailles à nous c'est à dire
sur le cinéma sur vous avez retrouvé des
traces à peu près dans tous alors en
tout cas ce qu'on a ce qu'on a pu
démontrer moi serait que j'ai été
surprise de voir l'ampleur que ça avait
à l'époque en dépouillant notamment des
magazines de mode des années 10 il y
avait un véritable une irano feeling
incroyable c'était la mode persane et sa
infuse toutes les couches de la société
sert que ce n'est pas réservé à une
élite là on est face à des costumes de
poire est effectivement là on est pour
de la très haute bourgeoisie mais même
madame tout le monde si je puis dire
pouvait avoir son son on son sweat
alamo de personnes et on le retrouve
très bien dans la presse de l'époque
c'est incroyable d'appeler sa suite l
époque un twitter twitter pour la maison
et suit déjà des rodéos commença
s'angliciser déjà tout début xxème
siècle en fait les premiers datent de la
ca c les décors aux filles ça aussi on
s'en aperçoit les décors soient
imprégnés de de taris l'avis conforme on
appelle ça l'art musulman à l'époque
l'art musulman à saleux le nom évolue
effectivement on parle d'art musulmans
ont pas aussi d'art mahométans
mais en tout cas oui on retrouve on
retrouve cette influence à la fois comme
vous l'avez dit dans le divertissement
dans le spectacle beaucoup dans la mode
dans la décoration d'intérieur parce
qu'on connaît des papiers peints
notamment qui sont inspirés de ces
miniatures persanes et donc ça c'est
vraiment liée à l'arrivée massive en
fait entre les années 1900 cissé 1911 de
peinture et de manuscrits du monde
indiens iraniens qui vont arriver sur le
marché de manière très importante
parce que l'iran à cette époque là est
confrontée à la révolution
constitutionnelle et que du coup de
nombreuses oeuvres sortent du territoire
à ce moment-là et des oeuvres de très
grande qualité oui donc son volet vous
voulez dire elles sont pas forcément il
y en a qui sont volés et aussi des
collections privées qui profitent de
cette période un petit peu mouvementée
pour en habiller la même chose on va
voir de l'invasion de l'irak par les
américains que énormément de pièces
avaient disparu en irak qu elle avait
été revendue est-ce qu'on commence à les
revoir
vous devez être attentive quand on voit
des nouvelles pièces arrivée est ce qu
est-ce qui en a qu'il pourrait provenir
des musées irakiens qui ont été payées à
l'époque on fait toujours extrêmement
attention surveille le marché il ya des
équipes qui sont dédiés à cette
recherche de manière enfin à plein temps
si je puis dire je dois dire que moi
c'est pas véritablement dans vous ses
plus anciens dans mes missions moi je
suis moi je suis plus sur le monde
iranien mais oui à cette époque pour
revenir à la question de la révolution
constitutionnelle où il ya des oeuvres
qui ont été volées elles sont
identifiées on sait qu'à cette époque
elle sorti illégalement du territoire
iranien et sont des pièces qui
proviennent des bibliothèques royal
est ce qu'il ya des pièces à ce moment
là que si on vit au début du 20e siècle
les français sont présents d'algérie
est ce qu'il ya des pièces qui viennent
du maghreb à ce moment là étonnamment il
y en a c'est peu et ça c'est
probablement lié dont je vous parlais de
cette collection louis cartier qui est
qui va influencer directement la
création de la maison louis en fait avec
ta ble ment a un goût très marqué pour
l'iran et l'inde et ça envoie très
clairement dans les objets qu'il va
collecter c'est un grand bibliophile
donc sa collection d'art islamique elle
révèle aussi cette passion qu'il a pour
les livres dont on trouve beaucoup de
manuscrits beaucoup de peinture est
également des objets incrustés très
précieux et là je dois dire si petite
déformation professionnelle probablement
voilà vous avez montré tout à l'heure
les très beaux puni en ivoire qui sont
aujourd'hui dans les collections du
musée du louvre c'est le public du chat
d'ailleurs il cherche les plumiers du
chat tout à fait mais ça par exemple le
pardon c'est fou ça se voit tout de
suite pour moi que ça bien on est sur
l'inde très clairement et dont je vous
parlais de cette pratique de la maison
de
de reconstruire des bijoux à partir de
bijoux plus anciens
là on est face à un collier hindous qui
très probablement a été constituée à
partir de d'un ou deux bijoux indiens
qui ont été modifiés et remonter tels
que vous pouvez le voir mais vous
trichez un peu si c'est un doux ça
dépanne brument tout à fait donc il est
alors la dénomination hindoue c'est
celle qu'on trouve la maison cartier l'a
enregistré comme ça dans les livres de
stocks
mais on a englobé en fait l'inde au sens
large en prenant le parti de se dire que
le lam au gol avait aussi influencer la
les bijoux traditionnels les moghols 1
mt musulmans tout à fait et les voilà
les fameux plumier dans des films alors
qu'ils sont des objets vraiment
exceptionnel et aujourd'hui ce sont les
deux seuls objets puisqu'ils on a aussi
une peinture de cette incroyable
collection de cartier qui sont conservés
sur le territoire national tout le reste
a été dispersée beaucoup aux états unis
et dont
benoît dorémus un commentaire c'est pas
facile parce que je te demande veut dire
pour moi des univers parallèles de gens
passionnés moi je découvre tout ou
quasiment donc non non c'est comme ça ça
me semble évident et aussi cimecom unis
j'ignorais pas totalement le lin
longtemps travaillé dans un magazine de
mode américain donc j'étais un peu au
courant de mes jeux je dois dire je suis
assez fasciné par le l'important je
l'ignoré un peu comme toi comme vous
l'importance de de l'art islamique dans
l'eure dans le
lard de quartier quoi dans le terreau
c'est cesser une recherche qui est
complètement nouvelle
l'exposition on a avec mes collègues
jouer tout seul notamment un cas bien
reposé mais on a travaillé pendant
quatre ans
les archives de l'année au départ
c'était une intuition vous aviez alors
je dois dire qu'elle ait pas de nous
l'idée de départ en fait c'est pierre et
nero qui est le directeur du style de la
maison cartier qui avait vu qu'ils
avaient vus et qui avait identifié un
lien avec les arts de l'islam est il
arrivé avec ce sujet disant voilà on
aimerait faire une exposition on vous
livre ça et on vous ouvre nos archives
et il faut dire qu'ils ont des archives
assez incroyable et donc on a plongé
pendant quatre ans dans les archives de
la maison et également dans le fond de
l'un des dessinateurs important de la
maison qui s'appelle charles jacquot qui
est conservée au musée des beaux-arts de
la ville de paris le petit palais et
grâce à ce fonds de dessins et grâce à
tout ce qu'on a découvert dans les
archives on a pu montrer prouver que
effectivement les arts de l'islam ont eu
un impact extrêmement important sur les
créations la maison cartier mais vous le
disiez sur d'autrui parce que regarder
comme ces petits flat qui sont
typiquement la syllabique quand on va
dans les palais de l ordre des loups en
allant des en andalousie dont les pales
et arabes on est frappé effectivement
par ses répétitions qui nous sommes de
tout à fait des années 20 on a
l'impression que c'est un alors voilà ça
aussi on se dit ça c'est le début du 20e
siècle en europe mais en fait non c'est
le quinzième les 14e dans le lampy rab
mai mais le c'est vrai qu'ils ont
tellement enfin ses formes ont été
intégrés à leur répertoire et je dois
dire qu'ils les utilisent encore
aujourd'hui mais il les utiliser sans
avoir la conscience de leur origine ll
était assimilé en quelque sorte au
répertoire des formes de la maison et du
coup cette exposition a permis de
d'apporter la preuve de leur origine et
aussi de de l'importance de l'impact de
cette découverte sur les artistes parce
qu'effectivement on a complètement
oublié
l'importance et l'impact de vos crédits
sur sur l'art sur la africains en
général sur l'art l'art du japon aussi
le chapeau sur van gogh et ça on a
oublié ça c'est encore un champ qui
reste à défricher effectivement et la
rupture est nette avec ce qu'on a appelé
l'orientalisme ou 19e siècle où les
peintres à les peindre des décès de
bordel
c'était souvent l'occasion de pommes des
femmes nues oui la rupture elle n'est
pas net parce que l'orientalisme perdure
au 20e siècle par contre ce qu'on a je
pense réussi à montrer dans l'exposition
c'est qu'il ya une émergence d'un autre
courant qui va puiser justement dans les
arts de l'islam pour pour réaliser des
créations imprégné de modernité qui vont
vraiment s'inscrire dans la modernité et
ça on le trouve dans les céramiques dans
l'illustration dans la mode et dans les
bijoux et ce courant la voilà les
graines elles sont semés au début du 20e
siècle je veux dire qu'en 1900 après à
partir de 1910 1912 avec cette mode
personne voilà c'est c'est le monde
iranien qui va fournir des modèles des
formes des couleurs dans lesquels les
artistes vont véritablement puiser
et c'est toute une recherche qui reste
encore à poursuivre il ya dansé
expositions environ 520 oeuvre c'est qui
le public est ce que est ce que est ce
que le public via justement des pays
islamiques
je pense qu'on a beaucoup de français
donc on a le public régulier des arts
déco mais je pense que ils ont ils sont
étonnés de voir qu'ils ont un autre
public il ya pas mal de jeunes qui
visitent l'exposition et les chiffres
augmente depuis l'ouverture et ça c'est
plutôt bon signe ça me fait dire que le
bouche à oreille fonctionne et que
l'éditeur sont contents et que du coup
ils parlent de l'exposition puis c'est
comme au cinéma voilà tient beaucoup de
communication au début ça commence très
fort et quand ça descend mais là celle
inverse justement les chiffres
augmentent les visages les visiteurs ont
l'air
assez satisfait c'est donc au musée des
arts décoratifs à paris jusqu'au 22
février elle va se promener ensuite
cette exposition staff et elle part aux
dallas museum of art puisque c'est une
coproduction avec deux commissaires
américaine eh bien on va faire une pause
et on se retrouve juste après
[Musique]
l'actualité économique de la semaine
décryptées par olivier delamarche le rsa
remplit-il ses objectifs non à en croire
un rapport de la cour des comptes
comment voulez-vous avec un peu plus de
500 euros vous en tirez et vous loger et
c'est donc évidemment que c'est pas un
tremplin pour quoi que ce soir je pense
que le dispositif aurait une efficacité
si on est dans une économie réellement
solidaire pour à l'édition 2022 choose
france 21 projets d'investissements ont
été annoncées en france il ya une
contrepartie qu'on va promettre à des
entreprises si elles viennent
s'implanter que d'abord on les embêtera
pas trop sur les licenciements qu'ils
annonceront après et vous aurez une
déduction fiscale ou des aides pour vous
installer pendant une période donnée
méfiez-vous qu'on l'appelle pas bientôt
loose france aussi
[Musique]
l'afrique la nouvelle crypte hollande on
a l'impression d'assister un phénomène
de mode qui est amenée à durer
véritablement sur le continent nous
sommes juste entré dans une nouvelle ère
du système financier et la population
africaine c'est un milliard d'habitants
c'est ça à la valeur de nos crypto mener
notre objectif c'est d'avoir de plus en
plus de partenaires qui acceptent notre
crypto comme moyen de paiement qu'en ce
cash si nous parce que l'argent liquide
perd de la valeur beaucoup de pays en
afrique ont interdit la crypto est ce
que vous répondez à cela d'une canette
on ne peut pas dire on va interdire la
crypto temps qu'il ya internet il y aura
des crypto points
et vous
[Musique]
fabrice gaignault vous êtes journaliste
et écrivain la ville est plus douce est
un véritable roman d'écrivains même si
c'est un roman sur le relâchement de la
bourgeoisie comment elle est passée du
fauteuil louis saez okada paix où l'on
s'enfonce puis au pouf sur lequel on se
vautre et enfin à la moquette toulon ça
soit en tailleur avant de s'allonger de
tout son long et ce grand relâchement
s'est opérée dans tous les domaines au
fond elle a tenu le langage les moeurs
la morale l'éducation
oui on peut dire qu'on peut dire ça je
suis je suis parti j'avais envie de
ça fait longtemps que j'avais en moi
j'écris dizaine de livres mais c'est
j'avais depuis longtemps envie d'écrire
un livre qu'il soit très personnel
il n'est pas entièrement
autobiographique mais quand même
beaucoup donc c'est un j'appelle ça un
roman parce que je pense que l'écriture
et puis certains récits ont été un peu
mêlé etc et c'est quelque chose qui m'a
qui m'a frappé en repensant à cette
époque tels que j'ai vécu dans ma
famille
de bourgeoise parisienne c'est cette
espèce de passage que vous décrivez bien
décrit au début du livre entre le entre
le siège le fauteuil et la moquette qui
a été assez précis
qui était assez prégnant chez moi dans
ma famille et quand on repense à cette
époque c'est vrai que c'était quelque
chose qui pouvait dans certains milieux
un bourgeois ou moins pour joie être une
façon de vivre très très adoptée à
l'époque fait la moquette le sol est un
spécialiste des années 60-70 votre
enfance et votre jeunesse au fond 1 vous
êtes né en 1956 et cd boboul à revisiter
vous l'avez revisité dans plusieurs de
vos livres
j'ai l'impression que c'est une
spécialisation récente de revenir en
arrière comme celle de revisiter une
époque si on prend bel zac quand on lit
les romans de balzac qui fait pas la
différence entre le règne de charles ix
10 de louis philippe et de napoléon iii
il a connu les deux ses romans
cent ans sont forcément inspiré mais il
n'a il ne s'arrête pas là dessus il
écrit pour l'éternité au fond j'ai
l'impression que les écrivains
aujourd'hui veulent absolument alors
est-ce que c'est l'influencé d'internet
on se documente plus facilement mais
vous vous les avez véritablement vécu
ces époques on est emmené en 1956 où les
ai vraiment vécu aussi bien des 60 que
les années 70 internet la moi c'est mal
c'est ma vie je peux y voilà exactement
mais je me dis pourquoi est-ce qu'on
assiste à ce besoin quand vous me parlez
du relâchement de la bourgeoisie je
pense qu'on le ressent encore
aujourd'hui mais voulant créer dans ce
moment qui a été à véritablement de
transition est oui alors j'ai écrit
quand même un premier roman qui était
très actuel mais beaucoup moins de
succès qui s'appelle l'eau noire et qui
était complètement qu'était contemporain
mais il est vrai que lorsqu'on parle de
moi je suis pas du tout connu c'est
parce que je veux dire mais on parle
toujours de moi comme l'auteur dé gérer
sixties par exemple c'est le livre qui
qui reste le plus de moi qu'on connaît
il ya des tentatives d'adaptation enfin
voila c'est un livre quelques cas pas
mal circulé et je l'avais déjà un
chapitre dans ce livre consacré à ma
mère et je me creuse oui je suis
absolument fasciné par cette époque qui
m'a vu grandir est ce qu'il y avait à la
fois chez moi une enfance heureuse mais
qui était un peu détruites par des
années de pensions qui ont été terribles
c'était une pension extrêmement sévère
tout en étant élevé par des parents très
très libéraux un scélérat qu'on puisse
dire donc il cette rupture un peu cette
schizophrénie dont je parle entre le la
pension catholique avec encore des
châtiments corporels ce qui a disparu
après 68 ou en soixante dix et le léthé
assez relâché à saint tropez puisque je
connais c'est à la fois c'est donc je
connaissais à la fois la communion la
confection toutes les semaines et à
saint tropez où je voyais ma mère les
amis de ma mère qui avait les seins nus
donc c'était un monde pour moi qui qui
ne cesse de me fasciner entre la entre
la la passion musicale dont on parlait
avec benoît et d'autres domaines qui est
victime qui m'intéresse beaucoup
et puis l'horreur d'une autre façon
quelque chose qui a disparu et
je voulais dire vous accueillant le
rouge tout à l'heure pour moi c'est un
peu le petit chose qui était déjà un
roman autobiographique d'alphonse allais
dans la fin du dix de halak d'alphonse
daudet pardon est la fin du 19e et mais
là ce serait le petit chose dans sa
version sixties est plutôt seventies
dont 6 626 oui mais cette petite chose
pour moi et le petit chose c'est pareil
ils faisaient pas attention à l'époque
le petit chose c'était censé pouvoir
être lus à n'importe quelle époque sans
jamais de référence à une époque précise
j'espère que ce seront peut-être aussi
lui comme quelque chose d'universel sur
l'art a toujours inscrit dans une épave
c'est ça qui m'intéresse c'est pourquoi
on se spécialise dans des époques
aujourd'hui pourquoi on ne veut plus
écrire le livre vous auriez pu raconter
la même histoire sans insister sur les
acteurs les
les tout ce qui date au fond on aime que
nos roms en date aujourd'hui c'est une
petite critique ou non votre excellent
jeu non pas parce qu'ils sont que c'est
très très bien fait là et chez vous
c'est justifié mais je me demande
toujours pourquoi on se crée cette
complication au fond oui oui c'est vrai
il reste que je ne sais pas je portais
ce livre en moi depuis très longtemps
des proches me poussait à l'écrire parce
qu'ils connaissaient aussi le l'envers
du décor c'est à dire derrière les
fastes d'une certaine bourgeoisie du 7e
arrondissement od et d une adolescence
une enfance et une adolescence qui avait
été assez compliqué quand même oui on
puisse voir malheureux réellement
malheureux on s'aperçoit qu'on peut être
on se dit oh là là quelle chance il est
dû à voir pas du tout non et jouer je
trouve ça toujours crétins les gens qui
pensent que le qui a une prime aux
malheurs spécialement dans un milieu
social etc c'est quelque chose lorsqu'on
est enfant un enfant peut se construire
adultes on est libre de ça mais
lorsqu'on est enfant je pense que c'est
quelque chose hélas la mieux partagée du
monde après il ya des mémés pour revenir
ça je trouvais en plus c'était une
époque romanesque que je trouve très
intéressante parce qu'il ya une
libération des moeurs exemple dont on
bénéficie toujours qui est par ailleurs
qui et qui par ailleurs très
bonne qui a été très bonne mais d'un
autre côté il y avait ce que j'analyse
est que temps quelque chose d'horrible
un peu dans le une politisation extrême
d'amis de gens que je connaissais qui
était maoïste outils tic qui qui
voulaient mme que j'adhère au parti de
paul potts et en même temps ils avaient
tous les gens qui prenaient beaucoup de
drogue il y avait un côté monstrueux en
même temps c'est ça que ça veut dire il
ya des médias le les spectres
biographique vous dit à la fois c'est un
roman autobiographique et c'est pas un
roman autobiographique j'imagine que
vous avez durement certaines choses
néanmoins on se dit quand on lit que
c'est forcément autobiographique donc
c'est particulièrement réussie dans ce
domaine
et ça doit pas être rien de tout
déballer
vous peut parler de l'auto destruction
de votre mère
vous parlez de votre père vous parlez de
vous deux vous vos frères et soeurs
c'est c'est pas rien qua non la partie
la plus difficile pour moi peut-être je
n'ai pas de si vous en êtes rendu compte
c'est de parler de moi aussi par
forcément bien c'est ça un livre
intéressant j'ai été longtemps critique
littéraire je le suis toujours
c'est quand même les listes qui met en
danger l'auteur quand c'est pas je me
contente pas de me plaindre et je me
plains pas d'ailleurs puisque j'ai un
côté un peu indifférent tout ce qui
m'arrive mais je je je voulais aussi
montrer que j'étais assez faible un
petit peu la chanteuse des militaires un
peu un peu mou cette époque-là hawaii et
ont joué face est partie du vrai roman
autobiographique voit le roman
d'apprentissage aussi parce que c'est un
roman d'apprentissage comme quelque
chose que je sais
c'est pas facile non c'est pas facile de
déballer de ses secrets aux fonds non et
d'ailleurs on m'a demandé on a demandé
une psychanalyse avant une journaliste
j'ai passé de psy calais je serai
d'ailleurs après l'avoir lu je me suis
dit mais pourquoi êtes-vous devenu
journaliste me si vous aviez tu es une
fille vous auriez sûrement fait psy
oui parce que quand on a vécu dans une
famille comme celle ci en général les
filles elles deviennent psy il ya la clé
à la fin du lit elles veulent réparer
les gars sont forts à réparer du tout
non non je jeu il ya une des clés à la
fin du livre fête un moment je voulais
devenir on m'a proposé je sais pas trop
quoi faire après la pension j'étais
tellement dégoûté par la pension que
lorsque j'ai atterri dans le monde à 17
ans j'ai je me suis dit j'aimais
beaucoup lire un jeu disait beaucoup
j'écrivais un peu je me suis dit je vais
peut-être essayer d'être journaliste
j'ai failli être le secrétaire
particulier de voiliers se passe
toujours
le guide et carquefou sous un autre nom
ils ont fils s'était assis à votre place
n'est pas là il avait des gens des
secrétaires particuliers c'était
l'époque où l'adhérent bentley qui
venait chez mes grands-parents ben clé
puis finalement ça mais attends tu
essaies c'est vraiment pour ne pas le
citer au dans une boîte qui s'appelait
le privilège ou
quelques journalistes beaucoup plus âgée
que moi m'a dit mais tu devrais
je t'aime bien viens viens de voir ça
s'est vraiment passé comme ça je pensais
que j'avais parfois on dit que il ya un
débouché on dit un artiste aussi parce
qu'on sait rien faire d'autre sam est
peut-être arrivé je n'ai jamais écrit
votre votre personnage vous
est constamment déprimé dans ce livre 11
il a vraiment eu une jeunesse
malheureusement
une enfance très heureuse mais peut-être
pas ce qu'il m'arrivait rien et j'ai dû
me venger par la suite vous arrive plein
de choses oui mais dès que je débarque
chez mes grands parents dès que adrien
débarque chez ses grands parents à saint
tropez tout ça c'est quand même l'été
c'est ça reste des moments
d'émerveillement pour moi et aussi les
périodes où
chez les grands parents que ce serait du
côté paternel ou maternel y avait quand
même des grands moments mais c'est vrai
qu'entre la tension qui était vraiment
lugubre et à l'époque c'était l'enfer à
aujourd'hui les enfants veulent se
débarrasser de leurs parents ils partent
en internat à l'époque ce n'était les
parents qui débarrassé des enfants dans
des endroits épouvantable
alors à décharge c'est vrai que nous
sommes enfin la famille rentré d'algérie
et qu'il a fallu s'était passé n'était
pas pratique et il y avait plusieurs
enfants donc voilà la pension
correspondait peut-être un canton avec
quelques moyens à assurer une éducation
peut-être une éducation une rigueur
lorsque tout commençait à le camp
c'est je soutiens dans un autre milieu
parce qu'il y avait aussi c'était un
milieu moi je parle la vidéo que je
connais d'adultes qui passait beaucoup
de temps chez castel quand même césaire
je veux dire je sais pas je voulais pas
citer les boîtes où c'était si vous me
citer dans les sujets à dire le
souterrain parler parce qu'il est
beaucoup dire sur le palace et sa
baignoire on peut vouloir été un peu et
c'est quelque chose que oui
effectivement où il y avait il y avait
ce côté où on peut ça partait pas d'un
mauvais principe on se disait qu'on
allait mettre les
les enfants en pension comme ça il
serait préservée de ce qui s'est passé
mais le problème c'est que les parents
ne mesurait pas parfois ce qu'à l'époque
on pouvait pas évidemment ont d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs le personnage fait une chute
à 12 ans ce qui est très beau mais très
tout cetera les parents le retrouver
mais menacé d'une pensée encore plus
sévère et à l'époque c'est vrai qu'on ne
manifestaient pas on ne disait pas je
vais me plaindre auprès du juge ou si on
croyait pas tellement les enfants
faisait que c'est comme ça et c est d
abord mais la pension c'est forcément
religieuse ne pense pas aux religieuses
pas ou pas du tout la plupart des
pensions et éolienne était très
religieuse mais
c'est là où je reviens au début oui ce
relâchement à la fois dans la tenue que
vous
décrivez en détail avec le passage du
fauteuil louis saez à la moquette mais
aussi dans tout le reste c'est c'est à
partir de ce moment là en face a dû
commencer chez certains moi j'ai en
avant mais mais on voit bien qu'il ya un
relâchement et si aujourd'hui les
enfants parlent si mal c'est parce que
leurs parents où on leur a mal parlé
mais les parents ont parlé bien encore
ils s'étaient les grands parents mais il
ya quelque chose qui m'avait frappé par
exemple étant entendu que c'est vrai que
la première fois que j'ai rencontré un
personnage que j'appelle une sorte
d'olibrius qui était un peintre raté
maoïstes et qui m'a parlé de foucauld
moi je pensais que c'était le père de
foucauld tous les week-ends toute la
semaine on parlait du père de foucauld
que pour lequel j'avais pas du tout de
d'antipathie que je trouvais un
personnage très intéressant c'est pour
vous dire à l'époque il y avait deux
coups en fait qui m'a lancé dans ma tête
qui pourquoi ce titre ces sorties de la
phrase d'un de mes grands pères qui
constat n'allait pas que j'allais enfin
je voyais il était toujours la vie la
plus douce c'est de ne penser à rien et
c'est une phrase qu'il avait trouvé dans
montaigne et après quand j'ai pensé à ce
titre donc je la cite j'ai vu que
c'était montaigne on le sait reprenait
beaucoup ça vient de sophocle ça vient
de sauver je trouvais que c'était une
phrase qui résume eh bien oui mais il ya
aussi le côté je pense que c'est vous
vraiment sur la photo et
c'est vrai aussi qu'il ya toute cette
idée de douceur qui est liée aux années
60 et depuis la douceur de vivre la
dolce vita de fellini est en fait à
chaque fois ça montre une ça montre une
décadence l'idée douceur des
années 60 est liée à la décadence chez
nous oui pour ça peut-être que j'ai
voulu rencontre aller le personnel fasse
voir mario adore ce qui est un acteur
très connu à l'époque des leaders
italiens tels biens allemands d'origine
de m'équiper dévoilé dans lequel le
héros va qui est un peu mon double va
habiter quelque temps à rome il est à la
recherche aussi inconsciemment de
cevital parce que mario adorf qu'il
présente des personnages déjà qu'ils
seront un peu moins oui qui sont
toujours célèbre mais qui ont connu la
les fastes des années 50 il est fasciné
par ça parce qu adrien ses parents sont
assez proches de son bien connu brigitte
bardot bardot et je trouve qu'il ya un
portrait de saint tropez qui est
vraiment réussi et je n'ai pas connu
cette opé cette époque là mais je trouve
le cresson la façon qu'on aura de
décrire saint tropez tellement faux ce
que je vais vous avez du smic et aucun
roman sur saint-tropez pratiquement mais
parce que tout est lé tout est
lamentable que des enfilades de clichés
et c'était un mélange en fait y avait
des artistes y avait des gens je parle
de ça me ferait tous ces gens là qui qui
était aussi là bas c'était une époque
aussi oui oui c'est pas que les bikini
sur la plage c'était j'aimais bien
décrire tout ces gens qui gravitaient
autour de mes parents tous les
journalistes de match qui ont disparu
tous ces gens qui étaient tous les
copains on appelait ça des copains
l'époque de baigts oui oui c'est le mot
bien ça vient de sortir de chez grasset
la ville est plus douce c'est signé
fabrice gaignault
[Musique]
benoît doremus vous pratiquez vous aussi
le taux biographie mais chanter dans
tous vos albums vous donner de vos
nouvelles et dans le cinquième qui vient
de sortir désolé pour les fantômes il ya
une chanson assez gonflé assez
courageuse aussi parce que vous y
regarder la vérité en face en effet
depuis quinze ans que vous chantez vous
n'avez toujours pas percé en dépit de
tous les encouragements reçus de renault
ou de francis cabrel en particulier mais
vous êtes toujours là et en fait c'est
ce que vous racontez dans une chanson
qui s'intitule on croit en moi je
propose de la regarder
[Musique]
ça fait 15 ans que je vis de mon sac ça
fait 15 ans que je vis de mon art quinze
ans que je tiens la north ça fait 15 ans
que je tiens là bas pour venir à vous je
navigue à vue je n'ai pas la nostalgie
de mes débuts je dis non non quand on me
demande si j'ai disparu je dis oui quand
on demande si juqu'au nuls dont les
photos j'ai l'air d'un gamin renault
benito copain copain j'ai le même amour
pour la chanson justin l'excès sur
l'inflation dictionnaire de rimes de
synonymes mon grand robert ma petite
routine je mets des synapses en
compétition à fond les yeux au plafond
si j'étais assis gens se tuent m'aurait
déjà fumé sziget si mauvais j'aurais pas
tenu ça fait si longtemps j'ai même plus
d'angoissé je les ai blasé tellement le
temps passe benito bientôt un nouvel
album benito continue il faut il faut lé
plus il est géré ma guitare en bois ça
fait 15 ans
en moi
[Musique]
pis
crois moi
tu crois
[Musique]
à force de tenir la pancarte j'ai une
petite hernie discale mon rêve de gosse
dans l'est par intermittence et
traitement local tout seul à l'hôtel
tout seul dans le train je commence à
râler tellement je me plains je
m'engueule avec ma chanson française
dans le soir
et même si y'a pas toujours foule il ya
toujours une rencontre un peu cool il ya
ceux que je suis content de revoir ya
toute une histoire y'a que j'ai pu
toucher des gens comme henri death mon
coeur d'enfant comme red y animer dix
sept ans et comme gainsbourg mes
sentiments 15 ans quand même bien et
comme soutien je suis déjà même revenu
de loin requinqué d'amour participative
et août une tournée avec france ihf je
suis allé chanter l'amoureux transi en
indépendant en tachycardie j'ai appris
et puis j'ai encore appris j'ai laissé
des plumes ou six
mais on croit
moi
je crois en moi
[Musique]
sapa
beaucoup d'appelés peu d'élus beaucoup
d'apple est trop peu lui même si le
passé paul eu des regrets aucun aucun
beaucoup d'ego d'où les dégâts beaucoup
rigolé en tout cas 15 ans de vannes à
réaction d'attenté d'allitérations et
jorane depuis si longtemps j'ai des
chansons en noir et blanc et maxime a
fait une musique et à l'art une petite
visite je repasse l'accent sur mon bep
et y aura jamais de plan b et je regarde
dans la glace mon rêve gore cenpac ça
fait 15 ans que je vis mon sac ça fait
15 ans que je vis de mon art alors alors
alors vacciner ou pas je repars
pour venir à vous je navigue à vue je
n'ai pas la nostalgie de mes débuts j'ai
dit non non quand on me demande si j'ai
disparu dit oui quand on me demande si
je suis au mieux
croire en moi
tu crois en moi
c'est formidable il fallait quand même
c'est assez unique d'être aussi sincère
dans une situation qui est pas forcément
à votre avantage
j'ai toujours fait ça donc depuis mes
débuts voilà une baisse de 15 ans de
raconter l'envers du décor ma petite vie
de chanteur à la première personne sur
une ou deux chansons dans un disque un
jeu pas que ça mais je vais toujours
faire est connecté quand ça m'a plutôt
souri quand renault a produit mon
premier album quand même arriver des
choix de choses et puis et puis voilà je
me bats c'était logique pour moi de
continuer en essayant d'être un peu un
peu transparent 1 on peut se dire que se
demander à qui vous adressez vous
pourriez vous adresser à votre femme
votre mère vous adresser aussi à tous
ceux qui ont financé l'album c'est un
peu ça parce que je suis dans un
entre-deux bizarre en fait effectivement
j'ai un superbe luc un public qui me
suit depuis mes débuts et qui en plus de
me suivre à financer cet album via un
financement participatif et le précédent
il ya cinq ans et à la foire
le grand public ne me connaît pas et à
la fois j'ai quand même des parrains
super prestigieux renault francis cabrel
parmi d'autres maxime le forestier qui
m'ont soutenue encouragée et aidée
donc je suis dans une situation un peu
bizarre moi vous me l'avez rappelé que
je vous invitais dans trois émissions
différents absolument donc je suis parti
six très concret cet échec
pas vraiment échelle c'est bizarre ce
que j'aime du super reconnaisant ont
tout le monde rêverait j'ai passé une
semaine à travailler mes chansons avec
francis cabrel c'est le rêve de tout aux
auteurs compositeurs comme l'écriture
comme les textes j'ai une relation
professionnelle et amicale avec renault
ford je peux absolument pas me plaindre
et à la fois je rame c'est très concret
je gagne à peine ma vie avec la musique
est à la fois des gens me suivent même
beaucoup bon voilà cette chanson résumé
un petit peu ce que vous avez à peu près
couvert tout le spectre oui puis c'est
une chanson pour dire que c'est un
métier impossible à arrêter en fait
parce que même des moments de
découragement qui sont qui sont
fréquents
je me suis demandée en plus avec ce qui
nous tombe depuis sur la tête depuis
deux ans est ce que ça a changé trouver
autre chose et je trouve pas c'est un
sénat c'est une drôle d'attirant je suis
comme aimantés par cette cette passion
de l'écriture de la chanson donc c'est
un métier qu impossible à arrêter donc
mais ça que j'ai des doutes quand vous
dites que c'est impossible à arrêter
vous n'avez jamais eu envie de
raccrocher si un moment mais l'envi sa
réserve d'agde hérault du rebond ils
veulent pas de moi ils veulent pas de
moi ont un niveau de mois et on veut pas
de moi j'ai eu deux albums en maisons de
disques en major encore une fois j'ai
des artistes très talentueux qui sinon
qu'ils signent pas en maison de disques
et malgré leurs efforts et malgré tout
leur temps moi j'ai eu quand même eu
cette chance je veux pas faire que comme
plein de mai
mais les radios qui diffusent pas dit
plus très très peu mes chansons appels
mails envie d'arrêter si si je l'eus un
serment et est très fort et puis et
surtout il ya eu un moment où j'arrivais
pu écrire où j'écris une dizaine de
chansons qui était qu'il n'est pas bien
quoi que et donc je me suis dit bon bah
si j'en ai un petit peu marre et si en
plus ces nouvelles chansons sont pas
bien ok bâchage alors c'est une période
qui dure quelques mois et puis et puis
tout on trouvera un jour un dossier dans
l'ordinateur on relit un brouillon mais
en fait c'était pas mal faut peut-être
que j'aille au bout de celle là puis on
y passe quelques heures et puis bon bah
ça fait deux chansons terminer puis on
les essais sur scène à puis on en parle
et puis on voit un petit message et puis
on me demande quand je sors un nouvel
album 20 c'est pour ça que j'ai que
c'est impossible à arrêter c'est qu'il
ya la passion de l'écriture y seul avec
soi être aussi parce qu'on est à une
époque où on est en lien avec fait avec
ses supporters
autrefois ça n'arrivait pas y avait pas
les réseaux sociaux il n'y avait pas une
communication directe s'empressait par
une maison de disques on écrivait au
chanteur mais j'ai un peu connu cette
transition moi j'ai mon premier album
c'est 2006-2007 et les réseaux sociaux
étaient naissance était myspace à
l'époque sa part est un dinosaure donc
j'ai pas connu vraiment l'avant j'ai
connu de cette période un peu
transitoire mais maintenant les réseaux
sociaux sont omniprésents et c'est ça
qui m'a poussé à me lancer dans
l'aventuré d'un nouvel album celui là
c'est que au lieu de me demander
quand est-ce que tu sors un album dans
les nouvelles que je recevais c'était
quand est-ce que tu refais un
financement participatif des j'en avais
un bon souvenir il était content d'avoir
aider concrètement un artiste et voilà
et un message de messagerie messages et
puis je me suis dit il ya des gens qui
attendaient les chansons sont prêtes
alors oui le chemin est un peu plus
content mais vous avez l'air de dire
dans cette chanson ça fait 15 ans que je
vis de mon art on peut vraiment vivre
sans vendre beaucoup de disques et alors
que les salles sont souvent pas pleines
comme vous le dis tout est alors oui on
en janvier jean vit chichement mais j'ai
envie tranquillement j'ai un je vis à
paris et je dois payer mon loyer donc
encore une fois ça va mais mais j'ai
envie pas comment on vivait quand
comment vivent certaines vedettes mais
oui c'est moi c'est les concerts me font
vivre oui ouais on est dans un beau pays
on à l'intermittence du spectacle laisse
moi je suis très reconnaissant de ça la
sacem nos soutiens on a un peu de droits
d'auteur enfin voilà qu quand on bosse
dur est contenu mais qu'on s'accroche on
a envie en france en tout cas je crois
qu'ils les pays où c'est plus compliqué
je crois que les en angleterre où il ya
passé statut là un peu un peu pro un peu
protecteur c'est plus difficile même
quand on a du succès de d'en vivre
convenablement et alors est ce que vous
vous interrogez en vous disant ou est-ce
que j'ai pas fait ce qu'il fallait faire
ou où j'ai pas eu de chance à un moment
c'était à deux doigts voilà on est
obligé de se poser la question comme
vous on peut refaire un petit peu le
film quelques fois mais à chaque fois
que je refaire le film jeu très vite ça
s'équilibre pas ce que je fais la liste
des choses géniales qui me sont arrivés
encore une fois renault à chanter une de
mes chansons enfin je peux raconter des
choses comme ça qui sont des cadeaux de
la vie renan luce vous prend premières
pages et
francis cabrel aussi c'est ça et puis
j'ai une chouette reconnaissance dans le
métier dans le métier dans ce petit
milieu qu'en fait que la chanson donc on
est mon nom puis on aime bien je pense
que tu laisses et des bons souvenirs à
droite à gauche et puis j'ai des bons
copains donc quand on fait un film si
c'est difficile et puis sans vouloir non
regretté non parce que quand j'écris
je bosse dur ça c'est la moindre des
choses mais j'y passe un temps fou et
c'est ça peut pas laisser de place aux
regrets de
bosser tout simplement et de ne rien
lâcher et puis des traîtres traverser la
france avec ma guitare c'est ça qui me
qui me pousse à continuer aussi c'est le
fait de ne pas avoir de regrets
justement bon et puis il ya tous les
exemples aussi de tous ceux qui alors
dans la chanson ou au cinéma ou d'un
coup dans les littératures ceux qui
étaient en nous disant pour la cdc le
dernier j'arrête après celui là si ça
marche ça et puis paf ça marche
il ya plage pourrait vous faire une
liste invraisemblable de gens plus âgés
en les flots à dieu je me méfie je me
méfie de moi même aussi parce qu'il ya
cinq ans je pensais justement que j'y
retournerai pas et la mort me revoici
donc là je me fais cette promesse à moi
ne faut pas croire que ça reviendra
jamais en fait ça revient les gens que
j'en parlais que justement des artistes
prestigieux maxime le forestier il ya
deux ou trois ans quand je disais que
j'arrivais pu écrire que ça sorte f1 que
c'était que c'était laborieux nous
racontait que nos bars numéro claude
nougaro appeler ça la torture sublime et
voulait dire que la h cup pour y
retourne quand même même si ça fait mal
et je me suis rendu compte que cette
douleur dans la création elle est
commune à tout le monde en fait je
pensais même plus au fait que le fait de
percer enfin percer m enfin regarder
pour ce que l'on est
et ça peut venir à n'importe quel moment
même tardivement par sané est souvent à
un moment où on croyait que c'était fini
quoi ça c'est possible peut-être c'est
comme l'amour c'est quand on s'y attend
le moins que ça me tombe dessus
franchement je ne sais pas je crois pas
non plus moi je fais un art justement
dont on parlera probablement pas dans
600 ans c'est un peu un art de
l'instantané la chanson c'est des
chansons
ce
qu'ils doivent écrire l'époque je suis
pas sûr que le succès arrive à 60 ans
non plus mais mais peut-être que ce sera
peut-être que ce sera la chanson écrite
pour quelqu'un d'autre qui me permettra
de continuer ce que j'aime aussi ça
écrire pour les autres alors c'est un
métier riche quand même c'est pas
qu'être auteur compositeur avec sa
guitare sur scène c'est un métier large
et est riche et donc voilà il ya
plusieurs choses à faire désolé pour les
fantômes c'est le titre du cinquième
album
merci encore merci tous les trois
d'avoir participé à cette émission merci
de nous avoir suivis et rendez vous au
prochain numéro
[Musique]
il verra t-on équipements
et le cas sera en morceaux
[Musique]
et hausse et il prendra ton âme
et puis le festival
qui est dit
[Musique]
avant il y avait trois chaman maintenant
ils sont beaucoup mais pèsera ceux qui
sont venus pour un service de prières
par là
oh
[Musique]
le volontarisme politique atteint ses
limites dans les français sont de plus
en plus sceptique
[Musique]
chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs se jouer mais les
règles ne sont pas toujours respectées
les couleurs changent de camp
les pions prennent la place des rois
deux films stratégies peuvent porter des
résultats inattendus
[Musique]
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire
[Musique]
sur les chômeurs et chaque semaine dans
l'échiquier mondial nous analyserons les
coups les plus complexes du jeu
politique internationale
à bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]
le travail de julian et de wikileaks
nous a montré toute une série de
meurtres la corruption la profonde
criminalité des états unis et de leurs
alliés de l'otan
ce sa page de réputation qui a commencé
quasiment immédiatement après la
publication des irakiens warlocks
l'isolent de la société
le new york times
le washington post
der spiegel
ils ont tous publié exactement la même
chose
mais la violence du royaume uni et de
ses agents
cela donne la nausée
aviez vous été surpris que ces organes
de presse qui ont publié ces
informations se soit ensuite retournés
contre julian
et bien non pas vraiment 1 je dirais
déçus
mais pas surpris
que veut-il dire en japonais et qui
comme on veut quand il veut dire qu'il
ne sort pas de chez soi tout simplement
le propre du phénomène hikikomori c'est
que on trouve des jeunes au japon qui
refuse de sortir de chez eux alors
qu'eux ils n'ont pas de pathologie
identifiée dans la nomenclature
psychiatriques aujourd'hui les quais
komori ne sont pas des fadas de jeux
vidéo c'est pas des gens qui passent
tout leur temps dans leur chambre
scotché à l'ordinateur à jouer aux jeux
vidéo et c'est un documentaire qui
permet de comprendre en quoi ce
phénomène est vraiment spécifique de la
culture japonaise au japon la pression
scolaire est extrêmement forte mais les
parents s'endettent souvent à vie pour
que leurs enfants fassent des études et
puis vous savez au moment de la crise
d'adolescence un bel quelque chose qui
est remis en question c'est une super
méga crise d'adolescence
considérablement majorait par la
situation économique culturel social
familial qu'il y aura pont
[Musique]
j'échappe et à riom j'ai mal à la tête
et vous aurez aussi
beaucoup sont morts
ils n'ont pas su s'en sortir
c'était notre maison
et qui peuvent à peine marcher après
avoir plongé pour chercher de l'or
j'ai du mal à marcher maintenant
il est interdit d extraire de l'or sans
autorisation
mais aucun d'entre nous n'a de licence
ou de permis
voilà la pépite qu'elle a trouvé ça n'a
pas rapporté gros mais c'est déjà ça
[Musique]
bienvenue dans un free connect l'afrique
la nouvelle crypte hollande les chiffres
sont dithyrambiques le continent a reçu
plus de sens 1 1 milliard de dollars de
crypto monnaies entre juillet 2020 et
juin 2021 il se hisse au troisième rang
des progressions les plus rapides du
secteur des devises virtuelles selon as
le cabinet américain d'analysé ce qui
relève une augmentation de 1200 % de ce
marché africain à l'heure où le bitcoin
traverse une zone de turbulences il est
passé sous la barre des quarante mille
dollars en septembre 2021 est une
première et bien cet engouement sur le
continent contraste avec l'inquiétude
des investisseurs ailleurs ils sont
nombreux à se lancer dans l'aventuré
comme l'ex footballeur international
togolais donaldson nos coûts nous sackey
président directeur général et fondateur
de timeless capital technologies une
société à de crypto il est notre invité
et on se connecte avec lui bonjour à
vous donald sunoco moussac et merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation dans
l'afrique connect bonus un bon jour
samantha est d'abord cette question je
les dis le bitcoin qui traverse une zone
de turbulences est ce que vous êtes
inquiet
non je ne suis pas inquiet parce que si
vous regardez en arrière en 2020 le prix
du bitcoin était compris entre 40 et 50
mille dollars aujourd'hui il est à 44
mille dollars donc
la plupart des grandes entreprises ont
investi dans le bitcoin les banques
commencent à accepter cette devise sur
le long terme il est certain que la
valeur du bitcoin va augmenter
est-ce que lalalalala blocs chaîne à la
technologie de la crypto s'est
résolument l'avenir de l'afrique ja
oui la belote chaîne ce n'est pas
seulement l'avenir de l'afrique c'est
l'avenir du monde entier exactement
comme les devenu internet sans de plans
la technologie de la blocs chain n'est
pas utilisée uniquement dans le domaine
des crypto monnaie elle peut aussi être
utile pour toute l'afrique et le monde
entier vous avez créé votre propre
crypto timeless capital kong combien ce
que je dois investir dans cette crypte
tôt et surtout est-ce que je suis
certaine aujourd'hui de pouvoir gagner
de l'argent voire même à long terme à
yes you can oui vous pouvez investir le
montant que vous voulez pour commencer
ce n'est pas seulement de faire de
l'argent le but c'est d'utiliser nos
devises à luz nous ne souhaitons pas
forcément que vous changez vos crypto en
monnaies fiduciaires mais bien sûr vos
crypto pourront prendre de la valeur au
fur et à mesure que nous développerons
sur le marché et que nous aurons de plus
en plus de partenaires qui accepteront
notre crypto comme moyen de paiement on
va parler des objectifs plus précisément
mais d'abord dites nous pourquoi il faut
investir dans les cryptes africaine elle
ne pèse pas lourd en face ou bitcoin par
exemple aux autres actifs numériques
déjà présents sur ce marché yes à fait
monsieur ceux ci depuis je pense qu'il
est important de comprendre la vision
sous jacentes
même si les crypto monnaies africaines
ne gagne pas autant de valeur que le
bitcoin on peut se concentrer sur le
nombre potentiel d'utilisateurs et la
population africaine c'est un milliard
d'habitants c'est ça à la valeur de nos
cryptome aux néo
kantiens il n'est pas seulement question
de prendre énormément de valeur comme le
bitcoin il s'agit plutôt de développer
une devise qui peut être considéré comme
l'égal du dollar est
fier parce qu'en termes d'échangés de
transfert d'argent les mener africaines
ne sont pas du tout au même niveau que
le dollar ou un groupe de danse mais si
l'on regarde les crypto même une petite
devise c'est avoir la même valeur que le
dollar c'est ça l'objectif
d'avoir une valeur aussi stable que le
dollar qui permettent à la mode et de ne
pas être dévalué en cas d'inflation mais
cholet alors justement vous quels
conseils vous donnez aux africains qui
veulent investir dans ces crypto qui
qui sont sur le marché actuellement
continental
-
il ya toujours un projet derrière les
crypto monnaie présentes sur le marché
en tout cas il devrait y en avoir un
quelqu'un qui souhaite investir
il est très important de lire toutes les
informations à propos de la devise
corinne ciwara de plomb du témoin dessus
tout comprendre aussi il s'agit d'un
projet de monnaies à long terme ou à
court terme
un flottement chamson costaros au club
encore parce que certaines crypte mené
disparaissent au bout de quelques mois
ou de quelques années human 1 si on veut
vraiment investir
la première étape c'est de s'intéresser
à cette crypte haut et se renseigner sur
le projet derrière
afin de vous poser la question est ce
que je peux investir sur le long terme
lenteur alors timeless capitale kuala à
qui s'adresse cette crypte aux actifs
la crypte totem laisse capitale est fait
pour l'écosystème africain spéciaux en
particulier pour les entrepreneurs en
afrique connu un tel
par exemple si je suis un entrepreneur
au mali et que j'ai un client au nigeria
les transferts d'argent sont très
compliquées
les jeunes entrepreneurs n'ont parfois
même pas dedans pour les soutenir donc
l'objectif c'est qu'ils puissent
utiliser notre crypto comme un moyen de
paiement transfrontalier
près précisé nous un peu comment votre
crypto elle peut aider justement les
jeunes entrepreneurs affrétant
notre crypto n'a pas une aussi grosse
valeur que bitcoin ou l'été rock
est à la portée de tout le monde tout le
monde peut s'investir et s'acheter une
crypto entière et pas d'une fraction de
celle ci est la première chose
la deuxième chose c'est que nous avons
un service de prêt pour les jeunes
entrepreneurs tu veux te dire un truc
enfin vous pouvez investir et gagnez de
l'argent avec notre crypto ou mais le
plus important pour nous c'est le
paiement transfrontalier et la
possibilité de s'épargner toutes les
taxes sur les transactions comme c'est
le cas chez western union par exemple
tout seul
si nous prenons l'exemple du salvador et
de son président bouquet les et a
autorisé le bitcoin comme monnaie
officielle
les banques et les entreprises de
transfert de fonds comme moneygram
perdent en moyenne 400 millions de
dollars par an à cause des taxes sur les
transactions qui ont disparu en iran
why not alors pourquoi ne pas faire la
même chose ici non même si ce n'est pas
à l'échelle de toute l'afrique mais pour
un groupement d'entrepreneurs qui
pourrait tout simplement utiliser la
crypto pour s'épargner ces taxes sur le
transfert d'argent mais
oui m'expliquer nous un peu plus parce
que c'est vrai qu'on imagine que les
entrepreneurs ont besoin de cash quand
même pourra développer leur initiative
leur entreprise en quoi les crypto
africaines peuvent justement les aider
dans ce sens précisément puisque vous
dites vous même que l'objectif n'est pas
forcément de gagner de l'argent mais de
gagner en valeur sauf
est notre objectif c'est d'avoir de plus
en plus de partenaires qui acceptent
notre crypto comme moyen de paiement des
saintes gorille - c'est d'ailleurs
l'objectif des crypto du monde entier
ce que l'argent liquide perd de la
valeur fils il y aura seulement en
afrique mais aussi en europe tu as many
winch et si vous prenez le taux
d'inflation de l'allemagne qui est
actuellement à 5 %
ou si nous celui des états unis qui a
atteint les 7 % il ya quelques mois
l'acteur us which
perd de la valeur
fille margot sens oui oui casting de fou
c'est pour cette raison que les gens
investissent dans les crypto ou dans les
métaux précieux investing et chloé mais
parce que l'argent liquide
ce n'est plus ce que c'était
les jeunes cherchent des alternatives et
les crypto en sont une autre
alors pour illustrer donald sanaa le
décollage de la monnaie virtuelle sur le
continent on vous bombarde encore de
chiffres comme celui ci selon le cabinet
américain analyse un bond de 55 % entre
juin 2019 et juin 2020 pour les
transferts de moins de 10000 dollars ce
qui représente 3 116 1 millions de
dollars et grâce d'aia nous explique ce
décollage des crypto sur le continent
le bitcoin le dhj kane de l'ip cogne la
liste est longue autant de crypto
monnaie en vogue sur le continent
d'ailleurs les crypto monnaye poussent
comme des champignons
l'afro com créé en 2014 et côté en
bourse l'école lancé par le rappeur
américano sénégalais akon lubutu qui se
veut éthique on peut aussi citer la
table s capital coyne de donaldson
sacquet dans laquelle le footballeur
anis ben hatira a investi une belle
marque de confiance en tête de peloton
des nations friande de monnaie numérique
le kenya le nigeria le togo l'afrique du
sud et le ghana
en 2021 42% des nigérians y ont eu
recours contre 8% aux états-unis 7% en
chine et seulement 5% en france un
marché en pleine expansion nous avons
une forte croissance plutôt de la part
des clients de détail donc des individus
qui veulent acheter et vendre des crypto
monnaie et cela pour différentes raisons
qu'il veuille investir à plus long terme
ou spéculer à plus court terme ou qu'il
veut utiliser le bitcoin pour les
paiements
investir spéculer mais pas seulement ce
qui séduit c'est aussi le côté
pragmatique de la crypto monnaie
pratique pour les achats en ligne le
paiement des factures ou les transferts
d'argent internationaux
la monnaie virtuelle évite l'utilisation
massive des devises classique souvent un
frein au développement des entreprises
locales
l'attrait de la crypto monnaie c'est
aussi incertaine affranchissement
vis-à-vis des systèmes monétaire
traditionnelle en place soumis aux
banques centrales c'est vrai la monnaie
virtuelle affiche son indépendance peut
être un peu trop pour les instances
financières africaines qui lui reproche
d'être ingérable et incontrôlable faute
de réglementation elle souligne le
risque d'attiser la cyber criminalité
financière pour d'autres il est clair
que la technologie block chaining
garantie et la sécurisation des
transactions et les états dans tout ça
certains jouent sur les deux tableaux à
l'instar du nigeria abuja a lancé sa
propre monnaie numérique le inara la
puissance économique africaine entend
ainsi se démarquer de ses voisins ouest
africains francophones focaliser sur la
réforme du français fin elle prend soin
par la même occasion de ne pas se
laisser dépasser par les réseaux en
vogue de la crypto monnaie et le ghana
pas très loin lui emboîte le pas accra
test depuis septembre le essaïdi
[Musique]
donaldson de cognac et on voit que les
pays leaders visiblement ce sont ceux où
la monnaie est volatile et soumise aux
dévaluations comme le kenya le nigeria
le ghana l'egypte donc on se dit quelque
part que la crypto finalement elle
profite sur le continent comme ailleurs
aussi des tendances inflationnistes et
d'un pouvoir d'achat a faibli hier en
course quand ce oui bien sûr plus votre
taux d'inflation est élevé plus vous
allez chercher des opportunités pour que
votre monnaie prennent de la valeur
le bitcoin est une de ces opportunités
d une part il y à l'inflation mais dans
la plupart des pays cités dans le
reportage la plupart des gens n'ont pas
de compte en banque
si vous comparez l'afrique à l'europe ou
aux états unis vous verrez que le nombre
de comptes en banque ne correspond pas à
la démographie
c'est la raison pour laquelle le marché
des crypto est en pleine expansion en
afrique
au collège d'autant plus que la
démographie africaine est très
importante et que tout le monde possède
un téléphone portable pour faire ces
transactions de transactions en france
le temps sont incertains
donaldson nous que nous ça qu'on va
marquer à une courte pause et se
retrouver dans un instant pour
poursuivre on se retrouve dans un
instant rester avec nous assure rt
france
[Musique]
il y a trente ans l'union soviétique
s'est effondré comment avez vous perçu
ces événements à l'époque j'étais parmi
les partisans de la démocratie la
rédaction du journal russia se trouvait
à la maison blanche nous avons passé
deux nuits inoubliables à la rédaction à
la maison blanche on était au centre de
presse du ministère des affaires
étrangères lors de la célèbre conférence
de presse du comité d'état pour l'état
d'urgence j'ai bien sûr changé plusieurs
fois d'opinion sur ces événements comme
tout le monde s'en doute mais à ce
moment là il y avait bien sûr une sorte
d'euphorie démocratique
s'enthousiasme n'est probablement si
seulement j'avais pu imaginer à l'époque
en août 91 à quoi aboutir et ces
évènements post a comment se terminerait
cet enthousiasme joyeux dans la lutte
contre le monopole du parti communiste
et la censure on apprenait qu'en
province mais personne ne pensait que
cela aboutirait à l'effondrement d'un
grand pays pour sa part je suis
responsable ellison
[Musique]
retour dans afrique connect on poursuit
avec notre invité donald ça ne colle aux
actes et président directeur général de
thales capital technologie fondateur de
la crypto tamniès capital contre le
nigeria donaldson a lancé sa monnaie
numérique le inera le nigeria qui est
très attaché à sa souveraineté monétaire
hostile même à la réforme du français à
faro c est ce que vous croyez que
l'objectif c'est finalement de contrer
véritablement la progression du
phénomène à des crypto monnaies et
d'autre part est-ce que c'est aussi un
moyen d'affirmer son indépendance
monétaire
le nigeria est un cas très intéressant
ils n'ont pas créé une crypto monnaies
si l'on crée une siby d'ici une monnaie
numérique de banques centrales de
défense vitrine de cryptographie la
différence entre une crypto devises et
une scie bbc c'est que cette dernière
est toujours contrôlé par la banque
centrale donc l'état et son gouvernement
d'étudier
cela dit c'est un pas de plus vers la
digitalisation de l'afrique depuis pour
un soir
c'est utile pour les africains dans le
sens où ça facilite nos transactions ou
par exemple si vous avez une certaine
somme d'argent vous n'êtes pas obligés
de transporter tout le cash sur vous
c'est donc une bonne chose mais je me
demande quelle va être la valeur de 7,6
bbc par rapport au nez ira one to one
oufti ou bidet il commet cette monnaie
va fluctuer avec l'inflation
c'est ça la différence entre le bitcoin
et les monnaies numérique de banques
centrales mais ça reste un énorme
progrès
quand saint-louis nos sens pipeau mais
nous savons que l'europe est en train de
préparer sa monnaie numérique c'est très
bien mais ne sont pas décrites aux
monnaies en
somalie et
en afrique de l'ouest
là où la crypto est moins accessible
parce que la stabilité monétaire du
franc cfa reste garanti quand même par
l'euro pour l'instant même si une
réforme qu'elle en sait quelles sont les
perspectives dans ces pays prades
particulièrement de la zone francophone
ce qui concerne les pays d'afrique
francophone et des états membres de la
bceao
ils vont sûrement suivre le nigeria et
le ghana qui est aussi en train de
lancer sa monnaie numérique du rich and
see
pourquoi les pays qui utilisent encore
le franc cfa ne devrait-il pas s'ouvrir
à la blocs chaîne
la plupart d'entre eux perdent le
contrôle de leur monnaie aucun à fond de
new land devrait accepter les transferts
de crypto et de siby d'ici parce que ça
rendrait vraiment service à leurs
populations
et huguette tôt claude karine scène
toulonnaise to get ce domaine des
civilistes ne presse sauf monde pipo et
vous n'avez pas répondu tout à l'heure à
ma question qui concerne l indépendance
monétaire
du nigeria et d'autres pays voisins
yeah yeah
oui oui le nigeria est moins dépendant
par rapport aux autres pays comme
séquences et vous est mort c'est pour
cette raison qu'ils ont pu aisément
lancer leurs devises numérique
mais avec la bceao c'est plus compliqué
silence une monnaie numérique
elle doit être adoptée par tous les
états membres
ce n'est pas simple mais je pense qu'il
devrait sérieusement se pencher dessus
son élocution alors les réseaux du
bitcoin un cercle ouvert ou fermé on a
posé la question là en expert at about
qui est le directeur de financial
afrique on écoute
mais robert parce que toute personne
pourra connaître
à travers des plateformes dédiées des
plateformes qui sont soumises bien s'il
apporte encore mais qui soit accessible
à n'importe quel agent économique que ce
soit aux institutions aux ménages c'est
un réseau fermé parce que si justement
vous ne vous ne vous ne vous souhaitez
passer pro forma c'est à dire que vous
n'avez pas voté en
hockey lui permet de transférer de
l'argent de faire des transactions vous
ne pouvez pas y accéder donc je dirais
que la ville compte un maintien il
s'agit et d'envoyer de faire des
transactions l'équipe obéit aux règles d
autres moyens les moyens classiques
stade que si vous aussi vous voulez
ferrer transactions à travers par
exemple une banque il faut disposer d'un
compte bancaire il faut obéir aux règles
fixées par chaque
plateforme rapport avec la ma passion
[Musique]
donald ça vous partagez la vida mawad
yes marcos ambrose a chez les opinions
cos oui oui tout à fait je suis tout à
fait d'accord un lancer et oui quand ni
chaque entreprise a ses propres règles
je devais avoir un compte en banque
la gloire oui c'est pour ça que nous
essayons de créer une sorte de crypto
banque où les gens pourraient échanger
leurs devises camani face nous pourrions
leur procurer un identifiant une clé de
sécurité à es10 à es16 et britney
donc oui je suis plutôt d'accord avec ce
qu'il a dit est ce lieu on observe aussi
une crypto magnin sur le continent est
ce que c'est un mirage ou pas écouter ce
qu'on pense à damas watts alors est ce
que c'est un féru l éphémère jeudi les
lots ce n'est pas un phénomène éphémère
c'est une activité économique nouvelle
c'est une nouvelle manière de faire de
l'argent de la part de cette personne et
en même temps la contourner en réalité
c'est à partir qui obéit aux lois de
l'apostolat psychologique de la pousse
d'avis l'effet moutonnier temps de
grandes stars comme ils ont masqué haute
appelle à aller à investir dans le big
boss il y a un effet d'entraînement il
ya un moment où vous tapez encore
l'effet questeur l'aube dans ça dans son
livre qui date de 1895 c'est la
psychologie des foules se sont lancés
aujourd'hui à travers ou un street ou
d'autres plateformes ou en voir les
investisseurs se détournant des actifs
classique donc c'est un élargissement de
l'assiette des possibles pour investir
dans l'or ou bien investir dans les
actifs classiques comme les actions et
autres ou bien est-il carrément enlever
du coin même si l'on va estime madame et
d'autres qui sont nées les gardiens du
temple de la finance classique qui
disent attention depuis quand ce n'est
pas une monnaie
[Musique]
donaldson vous l'ex footballeur vous
avez cédé donc à la tentation de la
crypto il ya aussi des artistes comme
akon on l'a vu qui a aussi fondé sa
crypto l'iphone finalement on a
l'impression d'assister à un phénomène
de mode qui est amenée à durer
véritablement sur le continent y est
parfait oui
je ne dirais pas qu'il s'agit d'une mode
je pense que nous sommes juste entré
dans une nouvelle ère du système
financier
si l'on regarde en arrière les gens avec
de l'or une des pierres et tout
fonctionne et autres os
need you
know who we plus tard on a commencé à
mettre en place les monnaies l'argent
liquide donc du papier
imaginez la première personne qui a
échangé son or contre du papier 100 au
premier abord ça n'a aucun sens
mais nous entrons simplement dans une
nouvelle phase de la technologie
financière aux technologies
avant la naissance d'internet dans les
années 80-90 qui pensaient que l'on
pourrait communiquer comme nous faisons
en ce moment même sans un sourire d
internet de la même manière qu internet
a vu le jour les blogs chain
apparaissent et elles vont perdurer de
soirée fut alors le problème c'est que
beaucoup de pays en afrique on
t'interdit
la crypto le bitcoin et les crypto qui
ne sont pas considérés d'ailleurs comme
des monnaies légal mais plutôt comme des
actifs en numérique écouter adamaoua des
propos
relativement le beach boys éthique et
culture bonnet son tour volatile rien
que la semaine dernière il
ne l'a pas
en termes de capitalisation de
l'ensemble des clips tournés
on peut dire que c'était très belle
alternative le big white sale et ça
permet de
de ce commentaire et de se dédouaner de
l'inflation mais aussi ça ne m'est pas
[Musique]
et puis on va préciser aussi que les
états se méfie des crypto parce que il
ça peut permettre aussi à certains de
d'échapper au fisc et puis pour les
instances financières africaines il
s'agit d'une monnaie ingérable
incontrôlable qu'est ce que vous
répondez à cela
c'est difficile mais d'abord j'aimerais
revenir sur le fait que les crypto
monnaies soient souvent qualifié de
volatil sans les citer
mais je vous rappelle que le premier
bitcoin est apparu qu'en 2008 en
comparaison depuis quand notre système
financier tel que nous le connaissons
existe pour le premier système monétaire
date de 1944
loto de pécan et la création du fmi ça
remonte à plusieurs décennies
de les crypto le bitcoin tout ça c'est
très récent au triple 5 les utilisateurs
de crypto ne représente que 2 ou 3 % de
la population
fut l'hôte des fruits
bien sûr que ce sont des devises
volatiles n harmony pipol usenet mais si
vous regardez le taux d'inflation des
pays africains s'il est encore trop tôt
pour décrédibiliser les crypto monnaie
fille et ce n'est que le début et plus
de personnes vont investir dedans qui
ont plus les crypto vont se stabiliser à
auby vériste est restée rousseau a
compté pour moi les crypto et le marché
boursier ne sont pas comparables
certains pays essaient d'interdire les
crypto comme le nid à vous la chine par
exemple
mais grâce à internet il est tout à fait
possible de contourner ces interdictions
d'entrée du canucks c'est du pota alors
pourquoi ne pas rejoindre les marchés
des crypto monnaie et tenter de le
réguler whissell a hand croque thomas
rousseau un destin aussi les états
pourraient bénéficier d'une taxe dans
l'impôt sur les crypto
en sauveur j'entends également beaucoup
dire que la crypto monnaies permettrait
d'échapper à la fiscalité match victoire
des nantais mais combien de personnes
échappent déjà aux taxes et aux impôts
grâce aux paradis fiscaux owen des soirs
sans un assainissement vient
d'entreprises ouvrent des comptes
offshore
ces problèmes existaient déjà bien avant
la naissance de crypto gay a
pour moi ce ne sont pas des menaces que
l'on peut incomber aux marchés des
crypto photo chef
de file car si
vous craignez la mise en place peut être
dans le futur d'une taxe comme c'est le
cas pour les gaffes à en réflexion norad
on a donc fait à l'envié de cause je ne
pense pas si les gouvernements estime
que les crypto doivent être taxés tout
va dépendre de ce haut taux d'imposition
bis sans annonce et je ne dis pas qu'il
ne doit pas y avoir de régulation mais
tout dépend de la forme de la régulation
on ne peut pas dire on va interdire la
crypto
ce serait comme dire on va interdire
internet
s'il ya une interdiction des crypto elle
ne sera pas efficace existeront toujours
tant qu'il ya internet non il y aura des
crypto
merci beaucoup à vous donner le nom
connu ça a été je rappelle que vous êtes
le fondateur de timeless capital games
est une crypto que vous avez lancé merci
à vous merci à vous merci de m'avoir
invité et merci à aux équipes du mag et
techniques pour la préparation de cette
émission merci à vous de nous avoir
suivis retrouver à free connecte sur nos
réseaux sociaux et notre site internet
arte france au point tva très bientôt
dans un pré connecte sur arte france
[Musique]
en 2010 il y avait environ 200
satellites en orbite en 2021 on en
compte quatre mille et en 2030 il y en
aura plus de 100 milles autour de la
terre le secteur spatial est un domaine
stratégique
où les plus grandes puissances se
livrent une guerre économique
territoriale et militaire essentiel de
laventure c'est pas tellement laventure
scientifique et c'est d'abord une
recherche de supériorité stratégique
rien n'est simple car les intérêts sont
divergents et la concurrence totale
[Musique]
je suis habitué à vivre dans la toundra
à la liberté et aux rênes
comment
quand j'étais à l'école primaire en ce1
deux amis et moi même nous sommes enfuis
du pensionnat on est allé dans la
toundra
[Musique]
dans la toundra il n'y a que des
moustiques je ne comprends pas comment
les gens peuvent-ils vivre
comment pourrais-je envoyé mon enfant à
l'internât je n'en dormirais plus la
nuit
donc quand ils font face à la vie réelle
ils n'ont aucune idée comment se
débrouiller il quitte l'école sans
expérience
[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans la
matinale des reflets france il est 7
heures à paris et à la une de
l'actualité ce matin
alors que les états unis font de la
surenchère sur l'imminence d'une
invasion russe en ukraine les européens
temporise l'allemagne freine les
exportations d'armement vers l'ukraine
le président français lui appelle à la
désescalade emmanuel macron a fait
savoir qu'il s'entretiendra avec
vladimir poutine après demain et en
réponse à la mise en alerte de soldats
américains la russie a procédé à des
manoeuvres militaires
on sera en direct de l'audience au matin
des manifestations en faveur de la
vaccination obligatoire à rire en
allemagne alors que les premiers débats
s'ouvrent aujourd'hui au bundestag
depuis plusieurs semaines les allemands
opposés à cette mesure eux manifestent
dans les grands
sous forme de promenade contestataires
et en espagne la catalogue elle a décidé
de lever toutes les restrictions on fera
le point à barcelone ce matin
[Musique]
un nouveau coup de pouce du gouvernement
pour faire face à la flambée des prix du
carburant le montant des indemnités
kilométriques revu à la hausse une
mesure
c'est par l'opposition car les plus bas
revenus entre ont exclu alors que le
variant au micro elle m'a tous les
records de contamination et que
l'inflation augmente
qu'en est il du moral des ménages
français on a posé la question à jean
marc sylvestre c'est l'élite aux échos
de la matinale
[Musique]
allez on ouvre cette matinale avec les
suites de la crise en ukraine hier le
président emmanuel macron a affiché un
front uni avec son homologue allemand à
berlin en conférence de presse unis dans
la riposte en cas d'agression russes a
déclaré le président français sauf qu'en
coulisses les européens et surtout
l'allemagne se montre beaucoup plus
prudent vis-à-vis des déclarations
bellicistes des états unis écoutez
emmanuel macron
en cas d'agression et comme cela a été
dit s'il devait y avoir une agression
la riposte sera là et le coût sera très
élevé
c'est dans ce contexte et avec la même
volonté exigeante mais lucide que
j'aurai un échange vendredi matin avec
le président poutine ce n'est pas un
déplacement c'est un échange
téléphonique
le président français qui a par ailleurs
indiqué on viens de l'entendre qu'ils
sont en train tu qu'il s'entretiendra
avec vladimir poutine par téléphone on
va retrouver justement tout de suite à
moscou notre correspondante verhaeghe
hoffman
[Musique]
bonjour vers à washington a annoncé on
l'a entendu hier jusqu'à 8500 militaires
placées en état d' alerte prêts à
renforcer les troupes de l'otan selon
cela aura-t-il une influence sur le
cours des négociations entre moscou et
washington les rats
bonjour ou a galéré pour par la voix de
son porte parole dmitri peskov le
kremlin a dénoncé la mise en a l'air de
milliers de soldats américains
pour lui il s'agit là d'une nouvelle
exacerbation des tensions par washington
ce qui suscite l'inquiétude de moscou je
vous propose d'écouter
cela n'affecte pas le cours des
négociations les négociations en fait
ont été achevés dans le cadre de leur
phase actuelle et avant qu'il y ait une
compréhension de comment et quand nous
allons les poursuivre il faut obtenir ce
fameux texte
nous espérons que nous l'aurons cette
semaine mais ce qui se passe au niveau
informationnelle et factuel c'est
l'escaladé des tensions entretenues par
les états unis en avons déjà beaucoup
parler rien n'a changé
nous suivons ses démarches avec beaucoup
d'inquiétude
plusieurs pays occidentaux dont les
états unis ont annoncé renforcer leur
aide militaire à l'ukraine infirmant en
plusieurs reprises que la russie aurait
pour projet d'un d'ailleurs son voisin
en dépit des démentis répétés de moscou
qui réclame de son côté 1 renforce un
renoncement de tout élargissement de
l'otan à l'est et un retour à
l'architecturé c'est que sécuritaire
construite en europe après la fin de la
guerre froide les etats-unis doivent
remettre cette semaine une réponse
écrite aux exigences de moscou pour
garantir sa sécurité en plus de
l'entretien prévu des dans les prochains
jours entre emmanuel macron y vladimir
poutine une réunion aura lieu également
aujourd'hui à paris entre conseiller
diplomatique français allemand russe et
ukrainien tout en plaidant la voie du
dialogue avec moscou à travers
différents canaux emmanuel macron
affirmé que les européens et leurs
alliés étaient unis en cas d'une
agression russe la riposte sera là et le
coût sera très élevé pourtant le ne
monteront pas le même niveau
d'inquiétude que les états unis par
exemple concernant la situation en
ukraine ainsi le 24 janvier le
département d'état américain a ordonné
l'évacuation des familles de ses
diplomates en poste à kiev qu'elle fait
un la situation en ukraine
d'imprévisible merci beaucoup verra pour
toutes ces précisions on verra goffman
en direct de moscou ce matin
on en vient à cette manifestation des
aborigènes en australie en ce jour de
fête nationale
une date qui marque le début de
l'oppression des peuples autochtones est
donc considéré par certains comme une
insulte aux aborigènes le gouvernement
australien vient aussi d'acheter les
droits d'auteur du drapeau aborigènes
pour mettre fin a dit il à une polémique
sur son utilisation par les entreprises
des particuliers un drapeau qui est
devenu un symbole important de
protestation et de célébration
ce peuple aborigène d'australie on va en
parler ce matin avec mélanie sabah
juriste franco-australienne spécialiste
du droit de la propriété intellectuelle
en direct de sydney
[Musique]
bonjour mélanie sabah
et merci à vous d'être là dans la
matinale de rtl france le 26 janvier
marquent donc cette date de la de
l'arrivée de la première flotte
européenne à sydney la proclamation de
la souveraineté britannique sur ce qui
était appelé alors la nouvelle hollande
c'est un triste jour pour les
autochtones en australie oui alors il
faut savoir que les populations
aborigènes vois vraiment comme le jour
d'une invasion donc pour pour c'est pour
ces communautés là si vous voulez le
fait d'appeler ça le
le jour national que ce soit une cause
de célébration c'est vraiment il le voit
comme
c'est quelque chose de très triste
puisque c'était eux ils ont connu des
massacres c'était vrai invasion tandis
que on a une technique ou le l'état par
nikki c'est la brosse là comme passer la
fête nationale avec des défunts parents
fiers d'eux
pardon je vous en prie
oui non donc il ya deux versions de
l'histoire une qui est celle d'une
colonisation et celle qui est bas d'une
colonisation reçu du coup c'est une fête
nationale qui intervient en pleine
pandémie qu en est il de la situation
sanitaire et les aborigènes qui sont
particulièrement touchée aussi par par
cette pandémie un
oui elle a fait savoir aussi que le la
fin les la situation sanitaire elles
varient selon les états l'australie est
un état fédéral c'est le gouvernement
fédéral locaux donc qui sont
responsables de l'organisation de et de
la mise en place des mesures sanitaires
donc selon les états et selon les
communautés ça peut varier quand même
pas mal alors il ya sept ce rachat du
drapeau aborigène par par l'état
australien dit tout pour pour quelles
raisons le premier ministre at-il
racheter ce drapeau aborigènes oui alors
en fait le très peu aborigènes c'est une
oeuvre à l'origine de les artistes
aborigènes aval thomas qui est qui a
créé ce drapeau de femmes coptes est à
terre en 1971 donc c'était à l'origine
un drapeau protestataires qui est devenu
peu à peu
le symbole assez de l'unité aborigènes
en australie donc c'est un drapeau qui
est utilisé partout dans le pays qui est
sur beaucoup de meubles mais c'est pas
un ça n'a jamais été un drapeau officiel
de l'état en tant que tel ce qui fait
que les droits de ce drapeau qui ont été
créés sur la tête de l'artiste harold
maquiller tout qui étaient toujours en
piètre
on a des problèmes de liaison avec
l'australie malheureusement mélanie
sabah que l'on retrouvera peut-être un
petit peu plus tard on va passer à au
reste de l'actualité à présent avec ses
manifestations en faveur de la
vaccination obligatoire à venir en
allemagne alors que les premiers débats
s'ouvrent aujourd'hui au bundestag
depuis plusieurs semaines maintenant les
allemands opposés à cette mesure
manifeste également dans les grandes
villes du pays sous la fin de promenade
silencieuse thibault jana
jusqu'à présent il s'était plutôt
discret mais les militants pro vaccins
ont décidé de passer à l'action lundi
soir ils se sont rassemblés dans les
rues de berlin au pied de l'église gates
émané symbole des événements de 1989 en
allemagne de l'est avec un objectif
montrer leur opposition aux
manifestations anti vaccination on va
dire si aujourd'hui alors que nous
sommes autorisés à nous exprimer
librement que tout le monde est autorisé
à s'exprimer librement sans avoir à
craindre quoi que ce soit ils se
tiennent ici et disent que nous vivons
dans une dictature alors je ne peux plus
tolérer ça les intrigues ne sont
qu'entre les sentiments anti
scientifique et pour une société ouverte
nous avons besoin de parler mais nous
sommes aussi contre les histoires de
conspiration une réponse aux
mobilisations anti vaccination qui
continue d'attirer les foules chaque
semaine ils sont plusieurs dizaines de
milliers à défiler à travers tout le
pays pour dire non aux restrictions
antico vide des pro et des anti vaccins
qui n'hésitent plus à se faire face au
moment où les discussions de la
vaccination obligatoire s'invite au
bundestag une proposition défendue par
le chancelier allemand je veux dire ici
que je suis favorable soutenue par
beaucoup d'autres comme je les ai vus
dans l'arène politique mais aussi
soutenu par les chefs de gouvernement
des états à ce que nous introduisions un
mandat des vaccinations en allemagne une
obligation qui s'appliquera dès le 15
mars pour les personnels soignants les
employés des hôpitaux et des maisons de
retraite ce n'est pas avant la fin du
mois de mars que cette obligation
vaccinale pourrait être élargie au reste
de la population
en allemagne +2 73% des habitants ont un
schéma vaccinal complet seulement 50 %
ont reçu une injection de rappel
et al'inverse l'espagne desserrent
l'étau le gouvernement de catalogne a
décidé de lever la quasi-totalité des
restrictions sanitaires les autorités
avancent qu'il y a moins de
contamination alors que la situation
reste tout de même assez tendue dans les
hôpitaux regarde
en seulement deux semaines la catalogne
est passé d'un couvre-feu a quasiment
aucune restriction le gouvernement
régional a annoncé la levée de la
quasi-totalité des mesures sanitaires
qui était en vigueur depuis la
mi-décembre
ainsi à partir de ce vendredi il n'y
aura plus de limitations pour les
rassemblements sociaux qui était avant
fixé à 10 personnes et puis les jo jeu
d'occupation dans les commerces pour les
salles de spectacle le monde de la
culture la restauration ou encore les
salles de sport élevé et puis le couvre
feu lui avait pris fin la semaine
dernière en bref les seules mesures qui
vont rester en catalogne seront tout
d'abord l'obligation du port du masque à
l'extérieur le pas salutaire dans les
restaurants les maisons de retraite et
les salles de sport et puis la fermeture
des discothèques alors ici en catalogne
c'est une décision qui peut surprendre
notamment parce que la tension dans les
hôpitaux est encore élevé le nombre
d'hospitalisations pour coville a
d'ailleurs battu son record de la
sixième vague en début de semaine en
atteignant 2 me 816 patients et puis le
taux d'incidence a aussi grimpé ces
derniers jours dans la région avec plus
de 5400 cas de kobe de 19 pour cent
mille habitants en seulement deux
semaines mais le gouvernement catalan
justifie cette levée des restrictions
par un ralentissement de la sixième
vague il mise tout sur le fait que
presque 8 catalan sur dix ont reçu deux
doses de vaccin alors le prochain
dossier sur la table des autorités
catalanes ses petons rouvrir les
discothèques elles sont enfermés depuis
le 23 décembre dernier mais le secteur
demandent une réouverture au 15 février
c'est juste avant la tenue du salon
mondial du mobile à barcelone qui attire
des milliers de professionnels venus du
monde entier
et au royaume uni le sort de boris
johnson suspendus aux conclusions d'un
rapport de scotland yard aujourd'hui le
rapport doit paraître aujourd'hui c'est
une enquête qui a été menée sur ces
fêtes organisée à downing street dans la
résidence du premier ministre
britannique pendant les confinements et
les dernières révélations à londres
boris johnson aurait célébré son
anniversaire en compagnie de proches le
19 juin 2020 au moment où les
britanniques étaient donc soumis à de
fortes restrictions
le premier ministre qui risquent son
poste il a promis néanmoins de coopérer
sébastien à bas
la fête pourrait être bientôt fini pour
boris johnson la metropolitan police la
police britannique a ouvert une enquête
sur les festivités du 10 downing street
un parti gates qui a ulcéré les
britanniques à cancun femme va je peux
confirmer que la police métropolitaine
est désormais en train d'enquêter sur un
certain nombre d'événements qui ont eu
lieu 10 downing street et à watteau ces
deux dernières années en relation avec
de potentiels violation des restrictions
anticopie de 10,9 je dois souligner que
le fait que nous enquêtions ne signifie
pas que des allemandes seront
nécessairement prononcé dans chaque
instance et pour chaque personne
impliquée
une annonce attendue par l'opposition et
la population qui critiquaient le
silence de scotland yard sur ces
révélations pour rappel ces
rassemblements avaient lieu alors que
les britanniques étaient contraints par
la loi à restreindre contactez le
locataire du 10 downing street interrogé
au parlement a réagi à l'ouverture de
l'enquète sorecop peut mettre ce que je
salue donc la décision du maître de
mener sa propre enquête car je pense que
cela contribuera à apporter au public la
clarté dont il a besoin et à mettre un
terme à cette affaire mais je tiens à
rassurer la chambre monsieur le
président et le pays que moi même et
l'ensemble du gouvernement nous
concentrons à 100% sur les priorités des
citoyens y compris le rôle de premier
plan du royaume uni dans la protection
de la liberté dans le monde freedom
mais le chef du gouvernement comme s'il
était coincé dans une boucle sans fin
doit à présent faire face à un nouveau
scandale dévoilé ce lundi soir par la
presse britannique le 19 juin 2020 une
fête aurait été organisée pour
l'anniversaire du leader du parti
conservateur jusqu à 30 personnes y
auraient participé dont l'architecte
d'intérieur chargé de rénover
l'appartement du premier ministre et
dont le financement est controversée
dans la sphère politique les soutiens de
boris johnson se démène pour sauver leur
chef de file alors que ses opposants
font tout pour l'amener à la démission
le premier ministre qui vous le savez
était à l'article de la mort quelques
mois plus tôt à cause du cobp u19
travail est incroyablement dur s'était
absenté s'était vu offrir un gâteau un
peu plus tôt dans la journée avant de
revenir à son bureau où il travaille
avec les mêmes personnes avec qui il
collabore au quotidien et qui avait
décidé de lui offrir un gâteau pour son
anniversaire toronto claires les règles
sont claires vous ne pouvez pas
participer à une fête avec plus de deux
personnes en intérieur ce que l'on sait
c'est que 30 personnes étaient
rassemblées que sa femme était présente
et que l'architecte d'intérieur était là
aussi
s'il s'agissait de mon anniversaire et
que ma femme est une architecte
d'intérieur voulait relâcher la pression
au travail avec un gâteau d'anniversaire
et une fête se serait brisé les règles
il n'est pas question d'avoir dans notre
pays la moindre personne moi y compris
qu'ils s'imaginent au dessus des lois
dans ces circonstances le premier
ministre devrait simplement démissionner
laisser la place et partie starpass a
ride and co les conclusions de l enquête
sont particulièrement attendus par
l'opposition il faut 54 députés
conservateurs pour déclencher un vote de
défiance qui pourrait amener le chef de
l'état à démissionner
allez au plan social à la une de
l'actualité en france cette grève à edf
les salariés de l'électricien français
font une grève nationale aujourd'hui un
mouvement pour défendre les salaires et
l'emploi mais aussi pour protester
contre les mesures du gouvernement qui
vise à à destiner qui vise à maintenir
pardon la hausse du prix de
l'électricité à 4% pour edf
cette décision signifie une perte de 8
milliards d'euros et ce alors que le
groupe est déjà très endetté la faute
entre autres à l'organisateur européen
du marché de l'énergie les explications
de ghislain rosier regarder pour limiter
la hausse à 4 % le gouvernement a
actionné deux leviers le premier c'est
une baisse de la fiscalité 8 milliards
d'euros de taxe sur l'électricité en
moins et le second levier c'est la reine
l'accès régulé à l'électricité nucléaire
historique
il s'agit d'un dispositif qui comptera
edf à vendre à prix cassé son
électricité à des concurrents pour que
ceux ci puissent rester compétitif eh
oui si vous êtes un client d'un
fournisseur d'électricité autres que des
f sachez que si votre facture est ce
qu'elle est c'est grâce à la reine et
surtout à l'europe mais on y reviendra
habituellement l'entreprise leur cèdent
environ un quart de sa production les
concurrents comme total direct energie
ce we ou angie revendre cette énergie à
leurs clients en se fournissant
également sur le marché européen de
l'électricité
sauf que voilà fin d'année dernière
patatras crise russo ukrainienne est
tension sur le gaz font bondir les prix
de l'électro et forcément les
fournisseurs alternatifs n'ont pas pu
suivre et certains ont même dû congédier
leurs clients pour éviter l'hémorragie
et contenir la hausse des prix
l'exécutif a donc demandé à edf
d'augmenter les volumes céder à ce
concurrent 20 % de plus résultat edf qui
a déjà vendu sa production va devoir
acheter une partie de ces térawattheures
sur les marchés de gros prix exorbitants
pour le revendre deux trois quatre voire
cinq fois moins cher une bouchée de pain
tout ça pour sauver la concurrence
montant de la facture pour edf 8
milliards d'euros quelle est cette
concurrence où on demande à un
producteur de subventionner ses rivaux
des niveaux qui ne produisent rien l'acr
eux ne contrôle pas l'utilisation qu'ils
font de cette production nucléaire ils
peuvent aller la vendre au prix fort sur
le marché et ramasser les profits sans
que personne ne leur disent rien pendant
ce temps là edf pei s'endette et
s'appauvrit tout ceci pour faire plaisir
à bruxelles car oui si on en est là
aujourd'hui c'est parce que la
commission européenne trouvait que le
monopole d'état sur l'électricité que
représentait edf était insupportable et
contrevenait au principe de la
concurrence libre et non faussée
concurrence qui doit en théorie servir
l'intérêt du consommateur alors voici lé
indices de prix de l'électricité depuis
1990 jusqu en 2010 ça monte un peu mais
ça reste tolérable et depuis la création
de la reine up +50 4% en une décennie on
ne peut pas vraiment dire que le
consommateur s'y retrouve alors soyons
précis cette augmentation n'est pas dû
qu'à la reine mais ce dernier il ya bien
sa part quant à la concurrence non
faussée subventionné par edf à coups de
mégawattheures garantie prix bas par la
loi on a fait mieux edf quand elle se
retrouve donc encore un peu plus
endettée la chute du titre va aggraver
la situation autant d'argent qui ne
servira pas au développement du
renouvelable ni à l'entretien des
centrales ou des barrages d'ailleurs
l'europe aimerait bien aussi les mettre
en concurrence ces barrages enfin si
c'est dans l'intérêt du consommateur
européen
et alors que les français se préoccupent
de leur pouvoir d'achat cette initiative
à présent pour lutter contre le
gaspillage alimentaire les initiatives
dans ce sens se multiplient avec la
hausse des prix dans le finistère vous
allez le voir des paniers de légumes à
prix cassés sont proposés aux
consommateurs reportage jordi de maury
et grégoire doucet
transformer un problème récurrent en une
opportunité collective voilà l'idée de
karim directeur général de finis tes
reste 29 une entreprise fondée il y a
deux mois le constat un gâchis
alimentaire difficile à supporter la
promesse un panier garni de plus de 5 kg
contenant au moins cinq légumes
différents le tout pour 5 euros ici tu à
l'atelier de conditionnement donc comme
tu vas pouvoir le voir
malone avait au new récupère bassel vous
n'avez qui n'est pas commercialisé parce
qu'il est trop gros la carotte c'est
parce qu'elle est tordu ou parce qu'elle
est trop grosse le chou-fleur c'est
parce qu'il est trop petit trop petit
trop gros biscornu ces légumes sont
rejetés des étalages de nos supermarchés
et lorsqu'ils ne sont pas récupérés par
fini terrestre il termine soit dans des
plats industriels soit dans la gamelle
des animaux le concept se veut utile et
solidaire
c'est pourquoi karim embauchent des
personnes dans le besoin étudiants
retraités par exemple et s'attache à
créer du lien social
hier j'ai une dame qui m'a écrit un mail
à la soixante dix ans à la un garage et
elle voudrait accueillir nos paniers
pour les distribuer dans son village
pour faire une bonne heure et puis
surtout pour rencontrer des gens en
discuter échanger et demain pourquoi pas
faire de ces lieux un lieu de bourse aux
livres a lieu de bourses aux fringues
pour se développer karim a décidé
d'inclure des commerces en difficulté en
tant que point de retrait lorsque l'idée
est venue aux oreilles de thierry il a
immédiatement contacté l'entreprise
l'occasion s'est présentée donc voilà je
le sors meubles j'ai envoyé un message à
karim m'a répondu et c'est parti trois
jours après on annoncé va faire trois
jours après voilà et c'est une super
idée quoi je trouve ça super génial il y
en a plus de personnes qui arrivent
enfin ça m'apporte énormément de
personnes ray thierry diversifie son
activité récupère une commission et voit
sa clientèle croître d'après karim les
commerçants participants ont vu leur
chiffre d'affaires augmenter de 20 à 50
% grâce à ce partenariat
chaque année c'est un total de 18 % de
la production alimentaire mondiale qui
ne terminerait pas dans les assiettes
des consommateurs
et hier le premier ministre français a
annoncé des mesures d'urgence contre la
flambée des prix de l'essence dans ce
contexte de pandémie et d'inflation les
ménages français garde-t-il le moral le
baromètre de l'insee doit paraître
aujourd'hui c'est l'édito échos de la
matinale de jean marc sylvestre tout de
suite
[Musique]
bonjour jean marc
ayrault stage et magali heureuse de vous
retrouver dans cette matinale verte et
france les français dans leur grande
majorité assume la situation sanitaire
il supporte les mesures et les
restrictions et finalement garde-t-il de
morales qu'ils ont raison
bah écoutez on se sent très précisément
sur le mois de 2 2 janvier mais mais ce
que l'on seul sur la première partie de
décembre c'est qu'effectivement le moral
des français a
progressé d un vieux dicton qu'on
attribue à talairan vous savez télé rend
disait quand les françaises se regarde
il se désole mais quand il se compare il
se console je trouve ça un peu vrai on
est souvent en colère on est souvent
pessimiste mais finalement on supporte
la situation sanitaire et la situation
économique alors vous allez me dire on
n'a pas le choix c'est vrai mais on
aurait pu plus un
et on a un petit point de connexion
par certains
médias alors je vous disais on n'a pas
forcément le choix de refuser la
situation on aurait pu craindre donc des
résistances des refus d'obéir notamment
autour de la question du vaccin du
passeport on a eu chaud à un moment mais
globalement la majorité des français a
été très disciplinés très résiliente
alors les dernières enquêtes sur le
moral des ménages réalisée par l'insee
porte sur décembre et montrent que la
confiance des ménages français s'est
accru en décembre par rapport à novembre
on devrait avoir une actualisation vous
avez raison dans la journée mais la
quatrième vague pouvait nous faire
croire des difficultés nouvelles en fait
les frontières ont semble-t-il compris
depuis le mois de décembre que la
situation sanitaire pouvait s'améliorer
et ils ont compris aussi que le
gouvernement avait la possibilité de
prendre des mesures d'allègement sur
notre vie quotidienne alors le taux de
vaccination est très fort en france les
a rassurés sur le sur l'avenir et puis
le testing massif c'est paradoxal qui a
révélé un taux de contamination record
encore hier 1 et bien c'est avec mais
avec assez peu d'entrer à l'hôpital eh
bien ça aussi rassurer les français puis
du côté de l'activité économique mais on
a compris que l'économie était reparti
très vite très fort avec députation
digital notamment y sont accélérées avec
une prise de conscience accrue des
problèmes climatiques on n'était pas là
quand même il ya un an ou 2 1 alors sur
l'économie vous avez des chiffres qui
attestent l'amélioration puisque la
plupart des indicateurs sont au vert la
croissance la consommation
l'investissement progresse très vite le
seul moteur qui marche mal c'est le
moteur de l'exportation parce que le
commerce mondial est encore très
paralysée par par la pandémie alors là
on a un risque de déficit sur la balance
commerciale mais la plupart des secteurs
français marchent bien le bâtiment les
commerces la banque l'assurance les
industries mécaniques et même le
tourisme intérieur ça travaille et ça
télétravail beaucoup ce qui s'ouvre
c'est l'événementiel encore les
industries de la culture du spectacle le
tourisme d'affaires les voyages
d'affaires mais tout ça devrait pouvoir
s'arranger puisque on va lever un
certain manque de
résistance dans l'industrie vous avez
l'automobile qui l'autorisent saint pois
noirs ça a passé une très mauvaise année
la mutation électrique a beaucoup moins
de succès qu'on pouvait l'imaginer et
surtout surtout et bien vous avez des
usines qui sont bloqués en france faute
de composants qui eux sont coincés hip
hop et de la corée du sud et de china et
vous dites que les ménages ont
globalement le moral mais beaucoup
continuent à se plaindre quand même oui
alors c'est ce que je vous disais bon
bah c'est quand même ça c'est dans l'adn
française ça met beaucoup en raison
aussi se plaindre pourquoi parce que les
chiffres sont des moyennes et ses moyens
lui cache des disparités le ressenti est
très différent de la réalité ça c'est
important en politique trône et le
pouvoir d'achat le pouvoir d'achat
actuellement est devenu un des débats
les plus importants de la campagne
présidentielle la grande majorité des
français considèrent que le pouvoir
d'achat a baissé globalement je peux
vous dire c'est pas vrai c'est pas vrai
le pouvoir d'achat a même beaucoup
augmenté depuis dix ans mais dans la vie
quotidienne ben vous avez des prix
courants qui ont beaucoup augmenté
l'énergie a beaucoup augmenté le
logement il ya un vrai problème sur le
logement qui a terriblement augmenté et
pour beaucoup et bien ses factures sont
devenus très lourde à supporter vous
avez une enquête récente d'opinionway
sur 2000 21
57 57 % des français pensent que leur
pouvoir d'achat a baissé vous avez
d'autres enquête qui porte sur des
périodes beaucoup plus longues qui
disent la même chose sur les dix
dernières années ord balmont c'est pas
vrai ce qui est vrai c'est que le
logement je le répète à augmenter
l'écart du grand jeu devant le but j
explications en fait
j'ai internet dans une famille téléphone
plateforme streaming tout ça a augmenté
apparu il a hypothéqué une partie du
budget mensuel de la famille vous avez
une part des dépenses contraintes sont
des dépenses d'abonnements auquel on ne
peut pas échapper à partir du moment où
on s'est engagés eh bien ça mange et sa
amputent le pouvoir de dépenser on n'est
pas dans le pouvoir d'achat le pouvoir
d'achat par le pouvoir de dépenser lui a
abaissé donc vous avez un ressenti qui
alimente le débat sur ce pouvoir d'achat
l'emploi est il une source d'inquiétude
on devrait avoir les chiffres dans la
matinée alors oui alors le seul emploi
source d'inquiétude beaucoup moins
qu'avant d'abord parce que globalement
la situation et s'est beaucoup améliorée
2021 a été une très bonne année en
termes dont
nous sommes globalement au taquet dans
le commerce le bâtiment là
on cherche à nous et on ne trouve pas
donc normalement on devrait être au
plein emploi avec des salaires qui
devrait monter d'ailleurs le président
du medef qu'il faisait sa rentrée dans
le cadre de cette campagne un peu
présidentiel auquel il veut apporter des
propositions a dit qu' il était
vraisemblable qu'on pouvait augmenter
les salaires dans beaucoup d'entreprises
compte tenu de la situation de marché
alors on cherche près d'un million
d'embauchés en france actuellement on a
près de 4 millions de chômeurs c'est
quand même paradoxal les chômeurs de
longue durée ils auront du mal à trouver
un job pourquoi parce que ils n'ont
aucune des caractéristiques de ce job
donc problème de formation graves
problèmes d'éducation problème aussi
d'habitude il faut que ces gens là sont
un peu de courage est ce qu'il ya des
solutions jean-marc ya sûrement des
solutions il faut aider les chômeurs de
longue durée revoir la politique de
formation et sans doute relocaliser des
industries qui sont partis dans les pays
émergents même si pour des questions de
prix ça va quand même être compliqué on
est là sur le structurel on est là sur
la décision police alors justement deux
points politiques pour terminer
peut-être à qui va profiter cette
situation meilleure en tout cas pour le
moral des français et surtout est-ce
qu'il est durable que ce bon moral alors
écoulé théoriquement le moral ce moral
des français c'est un marqueur il peut
profiter à l'équipe sortante c'est ce
que disent les sondages la vraie
question c'est de savoir si le modèle va
durer alors c'est très fragile c'est
très vulnérable ça dépend de l'évolution
de la pandémie ça dépend aussi de la
perception qu'ont les français des
difficultés qu'on pourrait avoir après
pau vide parce que après kobe ne faire
payer les factures et là les français
s'inquiètent un peu des explications
qu'on leur donne c'est encore un peu
flou déjà payé la dette il va rétablir
l'équilibré budgétaire
ça dépend tout ça de la campagne
présidentielle on a compris que
la gauche n'existait plus la droite et
rai facturé l'explication à d'immenses
problèmes qui pour la pétro rageux et
pourrait ménager des surprises enfin
merci beaucoup c'est l édito échos de
jean marc sylvestre de la matinale
d'ayrté france et justement dans ce
contexte le patron du medef on l'a dit
elle a assuré les salaires devraient
être augmentés qu'en pensez vous faut-il
une augmentation maintenant et pour qui
on vous a posé la question regarder
ces longs mois dans le secteur
plutôt accessible donc qui demande très
peu d'études deux ans cinq ans parce que
c'est là où on est le moins bien payé
selon moi il y en a beaucoup les
retraites centre au monde comme un veau
né montinari
bon quand je pense aux copains aux
retraites des ministres et tout ça bon
bah je sais pas combien touche mais
toute façon ne seront pas à plaindre eux
mêmes j'avais
pour les hôpitaux oui et puis bon bah
les petits commerçants les bons les la
force de fruits de légumes ce qu'ils
produisent ah bon parce que toutes les
denrées augmente
bon faudrait d'abord faire un sondage
savoir qui vraiment qu'il ya besoin
d'être augmentée qui n'a pas besoin
parce que y'en a ils se plaignent
toujours en réalité bon ils sont forts
appelable sur les métiers qui qui
concerne pas mal d'énergie du style le
métier comme caissier déjà des métiers
comme cela ça mériterait d'être plus
valorisées en termes financiers qu'ils
ne les a pas au désavantage par rapport
à cela après ceux des métiers à libre
accès donc c'est comme des métiers qui
doivent pas toucher beaucoup d'argent
moi pour ma part je suis éducatrice
spécialisée dont je travaille dans le
social donc
non on a un salaire qui n'est pas à la
hauteur du travail qu'on fait
l'investissement surtout depuis trois
ans maintenant
voilà donc même s'il ya eu alors moi
j'ai le droit à la revalorisation ségur
donc c'est déjà ça mais pour moi ce
n'est pas suffisant le médical aussi
également
les infirmières même si
c'est un peu mieux
je trouve que c'est c'est pas suffisant
quand qui fait augmenter les salaires ce
serait bien mais la hausse des prix je
pense qu'elle est plutôt faite par
rapport aux grandes industrielles donc
ce serait peut-être à eux de voir
d'arrêté de s'empiffrer sur le dos des
petites gens
secteurs de services à la personne parce
que c'est eux qui prennent de plein
fouet la pandémie avec la réception de
la restriction de lits de personnel
soignant et toutes ces choses là qui a
été mise en place par le gouvernement
depuis déjà des décennies c'est eux qui
méritent eux les professeurs les filles
ne se sert du pur culture en crèche
parce qu'elles supportent beaucoup un
petit peu le smig oui vous montez un peu
le smic je pense peut-être la santé un
peu oui
les bâtiments les choses comme ça les
restaurations
elle est tout de suite le débat
politique ce matin avec anne-laure blain
député l'est républicain du maine et
loire elle est réputée pierre cabaret il
est député la république en marche de
haute garonne
[Musique]
bonjour à tous les deux merci beaucoup
d'être en direct avec nous sur rt france
pour ce débat de la matinale alors on va
commencer par le pouvoir d'achat des
français hier jean castex a donc annoncé
un coup de pouce supplémentaire pour
faire face à la hausse des prix des
carburants et donc après le chèque
carburant il a eu ce relèvement de 10 %
du barème de l'indemnité kilométrique
regardez
j'ai donc demandé au ministre de
l'économie et des finances de modifier
dès cette semaine l'arrêté définissant
le barème kilométrique il sera réhaussé
de 10% afin de mieux tenir compte de la
hausse réelle des prix supportés par ces
ménages l'effet sera rapide et directe
effet rapide et directe mais qui va pas
concerner tout le monde votre réaction
pierre cabaret sur cette mesure
bien les faits ne va pas concerner tout
le monde effectivement puisque 10% des
personnes sont son tarot réel
pour l'instant c'est ainsi chaque mesure
peut s'améliorer ou peut éventuellement
évoluer vers un système
plus
qui concernera plus un plus grand nombre
de français un peu plus près
d'avoir pris des mesures à la va-vite et
un manque d'anticipation s'affaisser pas
c'est pas d'hier que les prix augmentent
c'est pas dire que les prix augmentent
mais augmenté dans ces proportions là
c'est vrai que c'est important et c'est
important de pouvoir avoir une réponse
pérenne donc c'est aussi important de se
laisser quelques quelques jours pour
améliorer cette situation alors blanc
quelle est votre réaction à cette mesure
décidé hier en urgence par jean castex
effectivement moi j'ai été un peu
surprise de cette décision du
gouvernement parce que c'est une
proposition que pour le valérie pécresse
depuis plusieurs mois cette augmentation
du barème kilométrique
donc c'est vrai que c'est une
proposition que la candidate valérie
pécresse a fait donc les fortes heureux
qu'il ait reprise simplement on voit
bien qu encore les mesures sont
parcellaires et quand même le
gouvernement aujourd'hui dénoncent
l'augmentation du prix de l'essence mais
c'est quand même le gouvernement qui
augmente lui aussi les taxes sur
l'essence et on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui
elles sont très importantes
le gouvernement ne semble pas absolument
pas prendre en compte cette augmentation
est encore la semaine dernière j'ai
discuté avec une collègue de mes shows
cabaret enfin qui est elle si mon
collègue à l'assemblée nationale qu'il
visait que pour endiguer cette
augmentation du prix de l'essence
notamment en zone rurale n'y avait pas
de problème et toute manière on avait
des transports en commun ils avaient des
véhicules électriques donc ça c'était
l'avenir sous peu la réalité du terrain
elle est toute autre c'est ce qu'elle
accepte on a besoin d'un véhicule pour
aller travailler se déplacer pour
pouvoir livre tout simplement c'est bien
sûr c'est une revendication qui datent
de longueur des français et notamment le
monde et chez les jaunes donc bien sûr
qu'il faut prendre à bras le corps cette
question alors ça effectivement ce
qu'avait aussi emmanuel macron hier
qu'ils étaient en haute-vienne qu' il
fallait aller vers des idées des
véhicules moins polluants qui
consommerait moins d'énergie donc ça
résoudrait la situation mais papa sur le
court terme pierre cabaret est-ce que le
gouvernement va annoncer d'autres
mesures
alors bien sûr d'abord je laisse les
paroles de mes collègues députés et il
leur appartient il est évident que les
transports en commun en plus depuis
depuis des décennies ali n'ont pas été
ils n'ont pas évolué en tout cas de la
façon dont on aurait pu les voir évoluer
et surtout aujourd'hui on a une
difficulté et une grande difficulté avec
ses transports en commun donc le temps
qu'ils évoluent effectivement l'essence
sera entièrement à 2 euros
mais
cette cet état de fait n'est pas de
notre ressort aujourd'hui c'est à dire
que les taxes n'ont pas été baptisé
aujourd'hui n'ont pas été rehaussé
aujourd'hui entendre madame ben là on a
l'impression que les taxes c'est nous
qui l'avons inventé n'ont donc cet axe
là m6 le ressort est important est-ce
qu'on peut les baisser ses taxes mais
hadash à la
à la marge s'affronteraient toute chose
il faut absolument
initiés autre chose et quand on voit les
sens augmenter cette façon là
et j'entends bien que les personnes et
moi on a tous besoin de notre voiture
donc et surtout en milieu rural ailleurs
donc il est évident qu'il faut trouver
il faut améliorer et c'est cet aspect là
que monsieur castex envisage de faire
c'est un début ce n'est pas une fin
voilà et je suis ravi que finalement
nous fassions une chose que madame
preuve pécresse a proposé puisque
et bien là on est à la manoeuvre et on
fait donc c'est aussi pour dire que
finalement il ya des choses
intéressantes
il ya des choses intéressantes à leur
moulin c'est votre sentiment ou est ce
que c'est on va piquer les idées des
candidats
il ya vraiment pas de mots moi je pense
qu'il vaut mieux préférer l'original à
la copie et l'original c'est valérie
pécresse la copie c'est le gouvernement
voilà ça vient d'être audi ils ont
attendu ils ont attendu en étant fin de
quinquennat ils ont besoin de donner des
gages à la population mais on voit bien
que ce n'est pas un mouvement de fond un
mouvement de réformes telles que le
demande valérie pécresse donc ça à
comprendre les simples idées bah ça n'a
pas d'intérêt en revanche à accompagner
les idées du de la candidate pécresse de
réforme parce qu'elles sont
indispensables parce que là on parle des
frais kilométriques de l'augmentation
des prix d'essence mais faut pas oublier
que les particuliers sont affectés mais
les entreprises aussi et lorsque
j'entends évoqué la question des
transports en commun il ya énormément de
fioul et de l'archi porte valérie
pécresse sur la bureaucratisation
impressionnant aujourd'hui que vit nos
pays et nos entreprises notamment en
matière de transports en commun le
ministère de l'intérieur par exemple
interdit aux chauffeurs d'autocars donc
qui permettrait le chip de ma vie est
territorialement notre territoire deux
campagnes de pouvoir rpt côté des
chauffeurs autocaristes pour accompagner
justement ces moyens de communication
dans les campagnes on voit bien que
cette réforme enfin en flic à cette
proposition des frais kilométriques est
reprise totalement d'une candidat mais
n'est pas accompagnée d'un mouvement de
fond tel qu'il est nécessaire de le
mettre en place et encore nous faire je
crois qu'il vaut mieux préférer
l'original valérie pécresse est une pâle
copie quel gouvernement jour à la une de
l'actualité également il ya cette
enquête choc sur la maltraitance en
ehpad un problème qui revient
régulièrement dans l'actualité c'est le
groupe hors pair qui est qui est mise en
cause le ministre de la santé a été
interpellé hier à l'assemblée à ce sujet
regardez
le ferez preuve et avec de gilles
bourguignon dudit veilleront croyez moi
à la plus grande sévérité ci ne serait
ce qu'un pourcentage des faits qui sont
alléguées dans le livre devait s'avérer
vrai et nous donnerons tous les moyens
pour vérifier la réalité de ces faits
alors au delà d'ouvrir une enquête que
doit faire le gouvernement pour faire
cesser cette logique de rentabilité au
mépris de toute humanité envers nos
aînés le patron d'ailleurs du groupe
orpea et est convoqué par par l'exécutif
car cabaret que doit faire le
gouvernement
personnes âgées c'est un sujet qui n'a
absolument pas été traité par le
gouvernement depuis le début ils auront
tous sur cette question et aujourd'hui
et vous à venir qu'il ya des buts il est
le plan jamais eu et donc il n'y a
tellement eu aucun débat aucun sujet
aucune compassion de cette thématique
très important pour l'accompagnement de
nos aînés à titre personnel je suis élu
depuis 2000 20 mg à la première
proposition doit à aider des compagnies
nous n' y est mieux dans leurs fringues
j on doit leur permettre notamment le
maintien à domicile ou à leur permettre
d'avoir les personnes à leur coûter
d'avoir les accompagnants qui puisse
être valorisés et qui puisse leur permet
d'avoir une fin de 10e rennes et
l'aurait fait souvent la complication ce
livre a le mérite de remettre le sujet
sur la table et c'est un vrai sujet de
préoccupation dans les territoires dont
on nous parle tous les jours donc
découvrir aujourd'hui et maintenant le
ministre de la santé nous expliquer que
six avéré vrai il faudrait faire des
choses mais n'a rien n'était fait
pendant cinq ans et dramatiquement mam
sous nicolas sarkozy la loi grand âge
n'a jamais été débattue c'est pourtant
c'est pourtant un sujet qui avait été
évoqué par par nicolas sarkozy a
également par parra par emmanuel macron
mais c'est trois grands âges pour
l'instant n'est toujours pas là la loi
grand âge évoquée par nicolas sarkozy ça
fait dix ans qu'on est plus au pouvoir
je tiens simplement à préciser il ya
quand même eu un mandat de cinq ans de
françois hollande avec emmanuel macron
au sein du gouvernement emmanuel macron
à la présidence de la république je suis
donc durant ces dix ans il ne s'est
absolument rien passé sur la question du
grand âge donc renvoyé sa à l'opposition
alors que nous ne sommes plus au pouvoir
depuis un petit moment c'est un petit
peu facile en revanche la ce que je vous
dis c'est que sur cette question pendant
cinq ans nous ne nous sommes jamais
préoccupé de l'avenir de nos personnes
âgées et des conditions de vie de nos
personnes âgées alors il est évoqué en
revanche des questions telles que
l'euthanasie par exemple eh bien moi je
trouve ça particulièrement choquant
parce que quand on préfère se préoccuper
d'euthanasie et non d'accompagnement
dans des conditions de vie décentes de
nos aînés sa pelouse de vrais sujets de
société alors on a perdu pierre cabaret
malheureusement n l'arôme là donc on va
on va continuer avec vous sur sur ces
questions d'actualité vous parliez
d'améliorer le
travail d'aidé soignant dans les ehpad
notamment or on le voit c'est bien une
logique une logique d'argent qui prévaut
et qui fait qu'il ya des maltraitances
ce sont des groupes privés quels moyens
d'action concrètement les le
gouvernement pourrait-il avoir
tout simplement il faut que le
gouvernement que l'état que la force
publique la puissance publique met
sévèrement suffisamment d'argent pour
qu'on accompagne nos aînés on voit que
nos aînés lille ni heures s'ils sont
accompagnés si le personnel qui est à
leurs côtés étant suffisamment grand
nombre aujourd'hui n'a clairement pas
assez de personnel il viendrait pas à
l'idée de poser public contre privé là
n'est pas l'enjeu de la question mais
c'est simplement de donner des moyens
que l'on puisse avoir du personnel
autour de nos personnes âgées et le
ségur comme des souvent évoquée à un si
bon nombre de personnes sur le côté il
ne traite absolument pas tout les sujets
toutes les préoccupations
des personnels de santé des personnels
dans les établissements qui s'occupe des
personnes âgées on voit bien qu'il ya eu
sur le côté encore une fois des gens qui
ont été exclus et qui n'ont pas eu de
revalorisation salariale or c'est aussi
important de valoriser les personnes qui
se donnent pour nos personnes âgées
parce que de cet accompagnement nous
verrons que les personnes âgées se sont
beaucoup mieux beaucoup plus entourées
et beaucoup moins isolés hausse demain
s'ouvre la course aux parrainages pour
les candidats à la présidentielle pas
question de modifier la pratique de ces
parrainages public des maires avant le
vote cette année c'est ce qu'a déclaré
hier le président du conseil
constitutionnel regarder
il serait sans doute de bonnes
pratiques démocratiques que cette
question qui revient comme un peu à
chaque fois
ci elle doit être examinée et tranché le
soir
plutôt début de mandat au milieu mandat
que à la fin lorsqu'on on bute sur les
délais alors faut-il le faire à dès le
début du prochain mandat présidentiel ou
aurait-il fallu modifier cette règle
maintenant un angle un les questions des
personnages et les simples elle est de
savoir aujourd'hui par rapport aux élus
par rapport aux gens qui sont impliqués
dans les territoires quel candidat à la
présidentielle il souhaite porter pour
qu'il y ait véritablement un débat sur
les sujets de société donc je crois que
la règle des parrainages elle est
effectivement aujourd'hui importante
parce que ça évite un certain nombre de
candidatures qui pourrait venir
s'imposer dans le débat sans même
véritablement de légitimité ou
d'imprégnation sur les territoires après
il ya effectivement au delà de la
question du nombre de parrainages la
question des publications des noms qui
peut poser problème pour un certains
d'entre eux mais je crois que les maires
aujourd'hui et d'ailleurs dans une
grande majorité ont
leur lors la vie sur la question et
parraineront sans aucune difficulté des
candidats passionnés habilité et est
parrainée en tout cas les choix qui sont
plutôt bien placés dans les sondages a
priori
par une roue à mon âge y est c'est en
tout cas le ressenti que nous avons à
l'égard de valérie pécresse une
candidate qui sera la plus à même de
créer de susciter l'alternance et de de
faire battre emmanuel macron parce
qu'aujourd'hui des mais combien ça sur
les territoires et ça c'est très
important qu'on n'a pas d'autre sur les
parrainages pour valérie pécresse ma
question c'est est évidemment plus tôt
pour pour eric zemmour dont là pour qui
la question se pose
mais eric zemmour marine le pen jean-luc
mélenchon ils auront leur signature
parce qu'effectivement ils vont au
contact du territoire et donc ils ont
très probablement leur signature je
pense qu'il aura pas de grande surprise
mais effectivement on voit qu à chaque
veille des présidentielles on essaie de
faire monter la pression pour faire
croire qu'on ne les aura pas mais très
sincèrement je pense que tous ces euros
c'est faire durer le suspense car
cabaret sur cette question des
parrainages on a entendu laurent fabius
hier le débat sur une modification des
règles pourraient se tenir après
l'élection mais pas avant ce débat est
nécessaire selon vous
d'après moi ce débat est nécessaire mais
il faut en informer les français
il faut informer les français sur les
conditions de financement de ces choses
là parce que 500 signatures ça donne
droit à un financement public or on ne
peut pas avoir n'importe quel contact
qui se présente à une élection
présidentielle est touché de l'argent
public ça c'est une première chose
ensuite il faut arrêter de prendre les
français un peu pour des ânes je crois
que ce sont eux qui font les d'action ce
sont eux qui votent et ce sont eux qui
doivent être concernées et ce sont eux
qui donnent l'argent pour c'est pour ces
candidats là ensuite je excusez moi il
ya eu une coupure et ses deux manches et
je voulais juste te revenir à une chose
la grande différence entre valérie
pécresse et notre président de la
république emmanuel macron c'est que il
y en a une qui est candidat et qui peut
raser gratis et on le voit très souvent
dans les campagnes et l'autre qui est à
la manoeuvre et pour cette manoeuvre là
effectivement il ay langage et langages
le gouvernement il engage des français
j'engage les financements et ça c'est
important c'est de le dire et c'est pour
ça qu'il est moins candide en ce moment
et c'est pour ça qu'il se portera et je
le souhaite candidats un jour pour
pouvoir contre qui vivait cet engagement
vis-à-vis des français cet engagement
financier cet engagement qui nous
apporte porter qui nous a fait traverser
cette crise et qui nous a portés vers le
meilleur voilà je crois qu'il faut
donner à la foi de l'espérance mais moi
je ne suis pas en campagne aujourd'hui
je suis pour continuer à gérer cette
france donc si valérie pécresse a décidé
de faire campagne ça la regarde mais
madame plein de grâce ne nous dit pas
que demain on va raser gratis parce que
ça les français mais en ont mais
ras-le-bol et ça ça ne sera jamais de
mon fait jamais jamais jamais et jamais
du fait du président de la république
jamais jamais jamais voilà donc vous
pouvez continuer emmanuelle b 13 m
certains la meilleure des candidates
pour vous et je le conçois aisément
parce que vous la supporter mais le
président et mad mike rome à emmanuel
macron et la personne qui gère
aujourd'hui la france qui la gère bien
et le gouvernement avec jean castex je
le soutiens et très largement c'est
normal c'est de bonne guerre une réponse
courte alors blanc
écoutez je suis atterré de ce genre de
réponse parce que eh bien sûr que la
majorité parlementaire va soutenir et
président de la république ils ont tout
fait pendant cinq ans les yeux fermés à
suivre aveuglément les propositions du
gouvernement et du président de la
république simplement quand on évoque le
raser gratis ça fait quand même plus de
six mois que le président de la
république distribuer des chèques à tous
bras pour acheter des français le
dernier en date étant le l'odieux chèque
de 100 euros qui ne ferment ne répond
absolument pas aux problématiques du
terrain donc voilà je pense que au moins
l'honnêteté elle est du côté de valérie
pécresse oui elle est candidate oui elle
veut être présidente de la république et
elle le sera parce qu'encore une fois on
voit bien que le gouvernement navigue à
vue et puisqu'il ne sait pas quoi faire
reprend les les programmes et les
propositions de la candidate pécresse
donc encore une fois les exercice
d'autosatisfaction alors qu'on voit bien
la situation dans laquelle se trouve le
pays sont clairement inutile un
botté pour l'original alors il reste peu
de temps jour est votre réaction sur sur
ce sondage qui est quand même assez
surprenant les français se positionne de
plus en plus à droite selon un sondage
que vous voyez apparaître à l'écran
sondage réalisé par le cevipof 63% des
sondés pensent qu'il ya trop d'immigrés
en france est très surprenant 39 %
seraient favorables à une dictature
pierre cabaret qu'est ce que vous pensez
de ce sondage
je pense que les sondages les français
répondent à des sondages avec une
conception de la dictature est
certainement à la française
autorités en tout cas
je crois que le modding le mot dictature
il faut le sortir son vocabulaire
c'était épouvantable une dictature était
rentable donc les français n'en voudrait
pas et ne voudrais surtout pas cette
dictature l'a ensuite moi j'étais
sérieux c'est bien le mot
bien sûr mais à utoya d'état
d'organismes sérieux donc le cevipof ont
fait partie y a pas de doute mais moi je
vais vous dire je fais une consultation
citoyenne sur vingt-quatre mille
habitants il ya quelques temps et
justement sur la sécurité est bien la
sécurité les gens parlent de la
tranquillité est plutôt que de la
sécurité et ça c'est vrai il faut
vraiment faire un effort là-dessus
emmanuel macron la pole a le le fais et
je suis un de ceux qui veulent vraiment
vraiment vraiment elle être être celui
qui va aider à cette sécurité à cette
tranquillité mais les résultats c'est
3000 personnes qui m'ont répondu 3000
personnes qui m'ont répondu et qui ne
mange jamais parlé
parlons trois personnes me parle de
l'immigration
elle associe l'immigration
pour 3 personnes sur 3000 à la hauteur à
la à l'insécurité
donc il faut revenir dans des fait
normaux il faut demander aux citoyens
absolument leur avis et le rôle des
députés le rôle de l'élu local c'est pas
faire une pseudo consultation mais ce
faire une consultation sur des grands
thèmes comme cela et ainsi on peut
amener les personnes à pouvoir discuter
avec la politique avoir un politique
proche du terrain et à bord une
meilleure réaction et surtout une
meilleure anticipation des choses voilà
la sécurité elle est demandée mais dans
le mot sécurité c'est la tranquillité
parce que ce n'est pas normal que les
mamies qui habite au dernier étage d'un
immeuble quand elles des stands se passe
à insulter par des petits voyous ça
c'est pas normal et ça il faut le faire
alors une réaction rapide s'il vous
plaît à leur place à ce sondage
moi je prends beaucoup avec beaucoup
moins de désinvolture les résultats de
ce sondage
bien sûr je sais pas ce qui est entendu
dans l'étude du cevipof derrière le mot
dictature mais je crois qu'aujourd'hui
les français ressemble bien cette
semaine nous expriment leur manque de
confiance à l'égard de leurs
représentants donc il faut que nous leur
donnions confiance il faut qu'il croit
en l'action politique il faut qu'ils
croient leurs représentants politiques
et cette confiance elle vient aussi de
l'autorité de la force du politique et
on voit bien quel point les autorités du
politique aujourd'hui se délient dans le
pays le politique n'assume plus ses
responsabilités n'assume plus ses choix
et donc il faut redonner des
perspectives aux français pour leur dire
que oui on peut avoir confiance encore
les français les élections sont là pour
désigner leur représentant notamment les
aider les élections légistatives aussi
pour désigner les députés et les députés
sont à leurs côtés et ils peuvent encore
faire confiance
à leurs représentants encore une fois
sur la question de l'immigration il faut
pas se voiler la face bien sûr
qu'aujourd'hui on a une très mauvaise
politique d'immigration tout simplement
parce qu'on n'a pas eu de politique
d'intégration
on continue à accueillir chez nous des
gens biens ne sommes pas capables de
nous occuper nous leur donnons ni les
moyens et nous donnons nous mêmes amis
pas les moyens de les intégrer
convenablement faut que nous assumions
dealer français de nous assurer que les
villes sont des valeurs de la nation
française et ça c'est fondamental aussi
pour les arcades à l'intégration c'est
réciproque
voilà merci beaucoup merci passion
nature temps de relancer le débat à
l'intégration c'est réciproque ce sera
le mot de la fin de ce débat de la
matinale merci à tous les deux en tout
cas d'avoir participé à ce débat c'est
la fin de cette première partie de
matinale on se retrouve dans quelques
petites minutes très sérieux
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi qui dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du pays il
est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez déçu l'univers
l'uniforme c'est quand même des hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inouï et gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite c'était
des gens qui travaillent c'est les gens
qui avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose à leurs enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas la double hic
parlementaire ça se passe en direct
puisque on est en direct il y a quand
même la liberté merci de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
de tous les départements français aucun
n'est peut-être aussi intrigant et
méconnue que ce petit bout de france au
coeur de l'océan indien qu'on appelle
mayotte derrière la carte postale ce
101e département et le plus pauvre de
france fois et à la rivière là il ya
tout et c'est un peu dégueulasse
type unique avoisine l'onu kawachi taux
passé indique t il me dit elle vient
même pas de pain donc la jolie de mai
une compote qui est bien sûr fait c est
ce que vous avez une idée de qui sont
ces gens qui attaquent un lycée
sapa
ça risque ans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
veut contenir tout le monde sur l'île
évidemment que j'en ai assez sur une
poudrière moi je leur jette même pas la
pierre c'est bien d'accueillir mais je
cassais un mot leur donne de l'espoir et
puis à la fin on leur dit quoi non mais
t'as pas de papiers bah écoute
accroche-toi mais j'ai pas de conneries
pour une fois qu'on a la parole a aussi
dit mais est-ce que ce qu'on leur a
apporté est ce que ce système là ce
qu'il est bon pour moi le gros point
d'interrogation
exception française sentiment d'être
oubliés qui sont ces habitants qui
vivaient 8000 kilomètres de l'hexagone
est content il à nous dire entre
grandeur et misère nous sommes allés à
leur rencontre
[Musique]
le quotidien de ces éleveurs de rennes
ces nomades de la toundra est une
réalité parallèle qui n'a rien à voir
avec celle des mégapoles
vas-y avec la corde
les hommes s'occupent des troupeaux les
femmes s'occupent des travaux ménagers
une femme doit être agile robuste et
forte celle là le confort et la chaleur
ces maux qui les crée une menace
cependant dans les vastes étendues de la
russie il existe un endroit où les
femmes au foyer ont un statut officiel
il s'agit du grand nord sinon j'ai
commencé à m'occuper du tchoum à l'âge
de 17 ans il n'y même 31 ans plus tard
je ne regrette rien
[Musique]
un certain nombre de journalistes que
semble s'être octroyé un pourboire de
juger à pouvoir même de condamner c'est
extrêmement dangereux parce que moi
j'aime savoir d'où parle les gens
cherchent et j'essaie de trouver des
réponses mais les travaux ne suis jamais
à oger une qualité ou une compétence ou
une expertise sans que je n'avais pas je
pense que notre métier devrait un peu
douté de ses bases et les revoir et les
remettre en question a toujours eu un
rôle historique pour le meilleur et pour
le pire d'ailleurs parce que si on était
un petit allemands dans les années 30 on
l'a beaucoup entendu hitler et ses potes
à la radio puis toutes les choses graves
j'ai l'impression qu'on les apprend par
la radio quand on écoute la radio on
sait si c'est grave ou si c'est pas
grave plus qu'à la télé
[Musique]
qui est 8 heures à paris bienvenue dans
cette deuxième partie de la matinale
berthet france est à la une de
l'actualité ce matin
le respect des droits humains en échange
de la reprise de l'aide humanitaire en
afghanistan les occidentaux expose la
liste de leurs exigences aux talibans à
l'issue de trois jours de pourparlers en
norvège une visite dont se félicitent
les nouveaux maîtres de kaboul il la
considère comme un premier pas vers une
reconnaissance internationales depuis
leur arrivée au pouvoir aucun état au
monde n'a reconnu officiellement le
gouvernement de ces islamistes afghans
[Musique]
le portugal se prépare à élire ses
députés ce week-end un scrutin convoqué
après le rejet du budget de l'exécutif
minoritaires par ses anciens alliés de
la gauche radicale c'est la troisième
élection organisée par lisbonne en
pleine pandémie
du premier ministre socialiste sortant
part favori mais l'ultra droite
pourraient faire une percée et devenir
la troisième force du pays
[Musique]
c'est donc le dernier jour de cette
visite des talibans en norvège la
délégation afghane est arrivé samedi à
oslo pour discuter notamment de
l'urgence humanitaire avec les
représentants occidentaux après avoir
rencontré des membres de la société
civile afghane et des diplomates elle
ils se sont entretenus avec le
gouvernement norvégien des représentants
des ong leur objectif parvenir à
débloquer l'aide humanitaire et l'aide
masquelier
dernier tour de table avant de quitter
le sol européen les talibans désormais à
leur aise dans cet hôtel de la capitale
norvégienne finissaient leur ultime
entretien au programme mardi une
rencontre avec les représentants des ong
qui ont appelé à la levée des sanctions
contre le gouvernement taliban
est le problème numéro un actuellement
et que les sanctions occidentales et
créer une crise de liquidités ce qui
signifie que nous ne pouvons même pas
faire entrer les fonds des dons le pays
qu et nous ne pouvons pas sauver des
vies comme nous le devrions l'occident
et des talibans doivent donc discuté et
nous devons mettre un terme aux
sanctions qui frappent les 6500
une issue favorable pour le gouvernement
afghan qui était venu réclamer le retour
des aides internationales
une invitation pourtant largement
controversé des manifestations se sont
tenues pendant trois jours dans la
capitale norvégienne pour dénoncer leur
venue mais oslo le maintien ces
discussions sont un dialogue nécessaire
devant l'urgence humanitaire
cette visite est la première étape pour
commencer à traiter avec ceux qui
détiennent de facto le pouvoir en
afghanistan
l'alternative de laisser l'aghanistan un
million d'enfants face au danger de
mourir de faim ce n'est pas une option
nous devons faire face au monde tel
qu'il est nous avons clairement indiqué
que nous voulions que les filles
retournent à l'école en mars y compris
celles de plus de 12 ans et nous voulons
un accès humanitaire
retour des aides financières mais non
sans compromis oslo demande la garantie
du respect des droits humains par les
talibans notamment celui des femmes et
des minorités l'accès à l'éducation et
aux services de santé ainsi que le droit
de travailler une entente qui ne
constitue pas une légitimation du
gouvernement taliban affirme oslo mais
ses représentants eux se félicite du
résultat de cette visite
de telles réunions auront un impact sur
la situation de l'afghanistan c'était un
très bon voyage ce sont ces voyages qui
nous rapprocherons du monde
ça nous voulons que l'afghanistan ne
soit pas un centre de conflits mais
plutôt un centre de connectivité
d'économie et de communication salons
nous ferons de notre mieux pour protéger
l'afghanistan de tout type de problème
avant que l'afghanistan ne puisse être
considéré comme un partenaire par les
puissances occidentales
le chemin est encore long
la norvège affirme qu'un suivi sera mis
en place au terme de cette visite pour
voir si leurs exigences sont respectées
dans les prochaines semaines et les
prochains mois le gouvernement taliban
sera scruté de très près par les
occidentaux
en syrie le siège des forces kurdes
devant une prison qui avait été rice
d'assaut la semaine dernière par des
djihadistes du groupe etat islamique
le problème c'est qu'à l'intérieur de ce
centre pénitentiaire il y a des enfants
parmi les détenus voyez les précisions
de grégoire doucet
quand le temps devient un facteur clé
assiégée depuis plusieurs jours les
djihadistes retranchés dans la prison
syrienne de guayara voit l'étau se
resserrer le 20 janvier dernier un
assaut été lancée par l'organisation
extrémiste pour libérer 3500 de leurs
anciens combattants les affrontements
ont semé la confusion certains se sont
évadés beaucoup se sont rendus plusieurs
centaines selon les forces kurdes
les négociations sont des plus délicates
parmi les personnes retenues à
l'intérieur se trouvent des personnels
pénitentiaires mais aussi des enfants
enfermés ici en raison de leurs liens
avec le groupe etat islamique
nous occupons également des petits du
califat requis sont les enfants que le
groupe prend comme boucliers humains et
nous essayons de les faire sortir les
appels à la reddition dédié à dist sont
donc lancés périodiquement et
continuellement dans la prison
les combats moins intense que les
premiers jours se poursuivre tout de
même par intermittence des soldats
américains et paul les forces kurdes
dans le cadre de la coalition
internationale anti djihadistes au cours
de ces derniers jours
ces événements ont poussé 45 mille
civils à la fuite selon les nations
unies il était 5 heures du matin quand
les combattants du groupe etat islamique
ont fait irruption dans nos maisons ils
nous ont mis dehors ils ont dit qu'ils
ne voulaient rien juste la sécurité est
maintenant on est là on a soif ils ne
nous ont même pas donné d'eau pas de
nourriture n'ont plus d'autres personnes
arrivent et on dirait qu'ils nous ont
oubliés
j'ai ouvert la porte ils sont venus à la
porte et nous ont demandé d'ouvrir pour
parler ils ont dit nous sommes vos
frères de l'état islamique qui nous
aucun mal laissez-nous juste entré les
femmes sont allées dans l'autre pièce
ils ont pris nos téléphones
le mien et celui de mon père ils sont
restés jusqu'à quatre rangs environ
il s'agit de l'attaqué la plus
importante de l'état islamique depuis sa
défaite en 2010 9 face aux forces kurdes
celle ci appelle désormais la communauté
internationale à l'aide
nous demandons à la communauté
internationale de s'impliquer davantage
dans cette question car il ne s'agit pas
seulement d'un problème local qui
concerne le nord-est de la syrie est
plutôt d'un problème international les
terroristes internationaux les plus
dangereux se trouve dans cette prison et
l'état islamique ont continuellement sur
eux pour raviver son autorité et son
prétendu état elles
ce sont des milliers de djihadistes
d'une cinquantaine de nationalités
différentes que les kurdes aimerait voir
rapatriés dans leur pays d'origine un
appel qui ne trouve qu'un écho limité
parmi les pays concernés
alors on en vient à la crise ukrainienne
à présent alors que les états unis font
de la surenchère sur l'imminence d'une
invasion russe en ukraine une invasion
qui a été démenti maintes fois par par
la russie les européens eux se montre
plutôt sceptique sur les proposent les
propos belliciste de washington
l'allemagne a même freiné récemment des
exportations d'armement vers l'ukraine
le président français a appelé hier à la
désescalade tout en affichant un front
uni sur une éventuelle riposte avec
berlin mehdi eskers fils
à l'est de l'ukraine la frontière avec
la russie prend de plus en plus l'alluré
d'une scène de guerre depuis ce mardi si
la crise est tendue à cause des renforts
militaires de l'otan accordé à kiev de
quoi inquiéter un peu plus les pays
européens le couple franco-allemand
était réuni hier à berlin principalement
autour de cette question
et nous appelons l'un et l'autre avec
beaucoup de force à une désescalade
détention et je veux ici dire combien
l'allemagne et la france sont unis sur
ce sujet qu'il s'agisse des discussions
que nous avons dans le cadre de l'otan
de l'union européenne au sein de la bce
mais aussi comme étant les deux
partenaires européens due forme a dit de
normandie
le chancelier olaf scholz appelle lui à
la sagesse notamment concernant
d'éventuelles sanctions supplémentaires
contre moscou
l'allemagne craignant des répercussions
dans ses relations commerciales et
diplomatiques avec la russie kiev qui
reprochaient la semaine dernière sa
position pacifiste à berlin appelé ce
lundi à l'apaisement c'est de contrôler
pression de la panique j'aimerais avant
tout est sous contrôle il n'y a aucune
raison de paniquer au cours de la
session du conseil de sécurité nous
avons discuté de la situation à la
frontière de notre pays travaillons à la
désescalade complète de la situation et
à l'évolution vers un règlement
pacifique
nous savons tous nous sommes prêts à
tout nous espérons le meilleur et nous
faisons absolument tout tout ce qui est
nécessaire et urgent marcelo demain
c'est c'est chaud porte terrible l'union
européenne quant à elle estime être face
à une situation extrêmement dangereuse
décor match wan jifei et shenzhen le
message essentiel est le suivant
l'europe est en danger j'aimerais qu'il
en soit autrement mais les deux
dernières années ont vu une grave
détérioration de notre environnement
stratégique
à tel point que je suis convaincu que
nous vivons aujourd'hui le moment le
plus dangereux de l'après guerre froide
le moment le plus dangereux depuis la
fin de la guerre froide a ajouté deux
semaines c'est écolo en tête alors que
la pression américaine qui s'amplifie et
que l'europe semble encore hésitante sur
ce dossier les manoeuvres pourraient
s'accélérer ces prochaines heures en cas
d'offensive russe projet démenti à
maintes reprise par moscou emmanuel
macron avertit tout de même d'une
riposte au coût très élevé un rendez
vous téléphonique est prévue entre
vladimir poutine et son homologue
français ce vendredi
le portugal se prépare à élire ses
députés et un nouveau premier ministre
ce week end un scrutin convoqué après le
rejet du budget de l'exécutif
minoritaires par ses anciens alliés de
la gauche radicale c'est la troisième
élection organisée par lisbonne en
pleine pandémie le camp du premier
ministre socialiste sortant part favori
mais l'ultra droite pourraient faire une
percée et devenir la troisième force du
pays explications avec nicolas fontaine
une opération sans précédent a été mise
en place au portugal en pleine pandémie
de kobe 19 des milliers d'électeurs sont
placés en quarantaine ou confinés et
pour leur permettre de voter ce dimanche
des volontaires viennent directement
recueillir les bulletins de vote au
domicile des malades qui se sont
inscrits pour disposer de ce service
nous allons commencer à recueillir les
votes c'est des personnes qui se sont
inscrites ce seront 30 personnes à
domicile et 621 en maison de retraite
nous avons préparé 15 équipes de 2
personnes
au total près de 13000 portugais vont
bénéficier de cette aide malgré un taux
de vaccination important près de 89% des
portiques et sont totalement vacciner
le pays connaît actuellement une
recrudescence du nombre de cas avec près
de 58 contamination de moyenne sur les
sept derniers jours allez un mot sur sur
la pandémie avec le variant omicron qui
progresse toujours plus de 21 millions
de nouveaux cas détectés à travers le
monde sur ces sept derniers jours un
record depuis le début de la pandémie et
c'est dans ce contexte que tedros
adhanom
gebre et sus le directeur général de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé a
reçu les soutiens nécessaires pour
briguer un nouveau mandat ce docteur
éthiopien qui a dû faire face à la crise
du coc vide 19 a souvent dénoncé les
trop faibles moyens financiers dont
dispose l'organisation mondiale de la
santé les etats-unis demandent davantage
de transparence sur l'utilisation de ces
fonds quant à mme auclair
une confiance unanime pour un nouveau
mandat de cinq ans tedros adhanom
gebreyesus seul candidat à sa succession
devrait rester le directeur général de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
jusqu'en 2027 et sasha grey tournage
c'est un grand honneur et je voudrais
vous faire part de mon engagement à
construire et l'om est ce encore plus
efficace et plus efficiente plus
responsable et plus transparente
plus efficiente grâce à un meilleur
financement devant le conseil exécutif
de l'om est ce ce mardi le docteur
éthiopien a de nouveau appelé à un
renforcement du budget et à plus de
souplesse dans la gestion de ces fonds
et le même jour les états unis plus
grand contributeur financier de l'om s
ont appelé à plus de transparence dans
l'utilisation des fonds de
l'organisation
les etats unis cherchent à mieux
comprendre les mécanismes de financement
actuel les gains d'efficacité et la
façon dont les décisions sont prises
avant d'envisager une augmentation des
contributions obligatoires
une déclaration qui n'est pas du goût du
directeur général de l' oms pour qui les
questions de transparence ne doivent pas
devenir une condition préalable au
risque d'être pris dans un cercle
vicieux tedros adhanom gebreyesus qui
demande une réforme du financement de
l'organisation souhaite que les
cotisations obligatoires des états
membres représentent 50% du budget
général d'ici à 2028 2029 pour le moment
elles ne représentent que 16% des fonds
bi annuel les 84 % restants sont issus
de dons extérieurs privés et publics
pour le moment aucun consensus n'a été
trouvé pour les années 2020 2021 le
budget de l'eau à metz s'élever à 5,84
milliards de dollars et un mot sur les
chiffres en france avec ce nouveau
record plus de 500 mille nouvelles
contaminations ces dernières 24 heures
c'est du jamais vu depuis le début de la
pandémie 500 à 1635 cas détectés ces
dernières 24 heures un taux d'incidence
de plus de trois mille sept cent pour
cent mille habitants
3842 nouvelles hospitalisations ces
dernières 24 heures trois mille sept
cent quarante et une personnes en
réanimation et 3
164 morts
bien mais peut mieux faire c'est la
conclusion du rapport transparency
international sur la lutte contre la
corruption des responsables publics la
france est 22e sur 180 elle ne progresse
pas vraiment malgré l'adoption de la loi
sur la moralisation de la vie publique
sous le mandat des manuels macron
regarder ces avancées sont atténués par
les signaux inquiétants qui ont émaillé
le mandat du candidat de la république
exemplaire emmanuel macron comme les
attaques portées contre le parquet
national financiers le nombre de membres
du gouvernement mise en cause dans des
affaires d'atteinte à la probité
les conclusions de ce rapport on va en
parler justement avec notre reporter
estelle farges
[Musique]
bonjour estelle alors on l'a vu le lg
note des progrès de la france mais aussi
de nombreux reculs et signaux
inquiétants quels sont ils eh bien on va
commencer par les progrès magali
notamment ceux accomplis pendant le
mandat de françois hollande à commencer
par la création de la haute autorité
pour la transparence de la vie publique
elle a été créé en 2013 tout comme le
parquet national financier noter aussi
l'arrivée du statut protecteur des
lanceurs d'alerté c'était avec la loi
sapin 2 en 2016 une bonne dynamique donc
mais qui ne s'est pas poursuivi selon
les ong parmi les signaux inquiétants
elle note notamment les déclarations
elle est incomplète ou mensongère deux
ministres à qui on est dégradé l'image
d'exemplarité voulue par l'exécutif et
quels sont selon les ong les causes de
cette stagnation
estelle et bien c'est le nerf de la
guerre les mains le manque de moyens
alloués à la justice et à la police
économique et financière un manque de
moyens qui traduit le fait tout
simplement pour les ong que la lutte
contre la corruption n'est pas une
priorité résultat est la france se place
à la 22e place sur 180 pas si mal mais
peut mieux faire merci beaucoup estelle
pour toutes ces précisions
[Musique]
et après les révélations sur le scandale
de maltraitance dans les ehpad le
directeur général du groupe orpea est
convoqué par le gouvernement
hier à l'assemblée nationale ministre de
la santé olivier ferrand a évoqué des
allégations graves il a promis de tout
mettre en oeuvre pour vérifier la
réalité des faits mais également ouvert
la possibilité
de lancement d'une enquête écouter le
de frais preuves et avec de gilles
bourguignon nous y veillerons croyez moi
à la plus grande sévérité si le serait
ce qu'un pourcentage des faits qui sont
alléguées dans le livre devait s'avérer
vrai et nous donnerons tous les moyens
pour vérifier la réalité de ces faits et
justement on va en parler de ce scandale
dans les ehpad avec elia qui riait fait
les aides soignantes ans en clinique
privée lanceur d' alerte et auteur du
livre les scandales des ehpad
[Musique]
bonjour et laqué rieff merci beaucoup
d'être en direct avec nous ce matin sur
la france on voit derrière vous il ya
une mobilisation parce que il y a
quelqu'un de de l'ehpad de l'ehpad qui
est situé à marseille qui vient d'être
remercié par la direction c'est bien
cela alors c'est pas tout à fait ça j'ai
déménagé dans le gard parce que suite à
man lancement d' alerte sur le scandale
des ehpad j'ai été blacklisté comme vous
avez pu le comprendre et suivre sur
plusieurs chaînes de télévision
aujourd'hui j'ai atterri dans le gard et
je travaille pour un grand groupe privé
le groupe health and ben ali la clinique
bonnefon mois à l'essai est
effectivement en grève aujourd'hui
l'ensemble des salariés en a ras le bol
parce qu'aujourd'hui on dénonce une
pression économique une pression sur le
salarié on
muselle ans les bayonne exemple eu droit
à la parole sous prétexte qu'il est
sous la menace et même qu'on leur enlève
leur emploi en les glissant si on les
sanctionne des mises à pied ont été
reçus par certains salariés des
avertissements etc deviennent
catastrophiques le climat au pré
enseignes les établissements privés
lucratifs
c'est juste inadmissible et la santé ne
doit pas faire partie du privé et du
coude j'imagine que les révélations
faites hier par ce journaliste notamment
dans un grand et pas de parisiens vous
conforte en tout cas dans votre combat
est belle ça me donne encore plus de
l'histoire et je me dis que le combat
continue on va finir par ces charente
indre ont fini par se faire entendre par
tous de notre gouvernement qui jusqu'à
présent n'a jamais rien fait pour
soutenir nos aînés dans ses structures
pour se tenir tous les français qui sont
dans l'obligation de mettre leurs
parents dans une structure qu'ils aient
pour qui l'heure l'objectif et le
rendement et je me dis que vers on y
arrive on y arrive à cet objectif et
grâce à lui grâce à toutes celles qui
donnent la parole tous les soignants
toutes les familles tous les résidents
sont maltraités aujourd'hui en france on
va finir par faire quelque chose et
j'espère vraiment que monsieur macro
maintenant qu'il est encore au
gouvernement va agir eva m une pression
forte et une sanction disciplinaire à
exemplaire pour tu peux à france et tous
les français alors sais pas si vous avez
entendu justement le patron d'orpea il a
dit hier qu'il n'y avait pas de
maltraitance généralisée dans ces
époques que c'était le fait d'individus
parfois et que c'était finalement humain
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
alors oui c'est monsieur le directeur de
hrw et à ses messages vous est adressée
directement un individu je veux bien
mais quand vous avez des millions de
familles des millions de résidents des
millions de soignants qui répète la même
chose dans toutes les ehpad privée en
france à but lucratif je pense que c'est
pas juste une voix ils ont laissé une
polaire est une réalité c'est ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui dans les ehpad privé
lucratif la maltraitance et est ce que
tu es tu sûr l'alizé pardon et il faut
que ça cesse parce qu'il faut être
honnête parce que la maltraitance passe
par les les réductions drastiques de
budget on l'a vu et l'aide apportée à
ces personnes exactement quand vous
devez
rationner un plat pour un résident qui a
travaillé toute sa vie et qui paye 8000
euros une chambre par mois je trouve ça
scandaleux
quand on ne peut pas lui changer sa
couche est plus de trois fois par jour
c'est de l'aberration on ne peut pas
continuer comme ça ça suffit c'est de la
maltraitance c'est des humains et des
humains qui veulent finir leur vie
tranquillement et sereinement que quel
est l'état d'esprit du personnel
soignant dans les ehpad lorsque il ya
cessé rationnement
et b on est méprisée dans les ehpad les
soignants mais ils n'ont pas le choix
que pour continuer de faire d'exercer et
de gagner
de l'argent pour pouvoir nourrir leurs
familles mais ils continuent à
travailler mais c'est pour ça
aujourd'hui qui a énormément de burn out
énormément de gens et de soignants qui
quittent leur
métier qu'ils ont choisi par vocation
parce qu'ils n'en peuvent plus et parce
que leur petite voix à travers leur est
injustement belle et pas porter au delà
de delà du combat et de moi vous
expliquer ça
et de la force de ce combat l'importance
de ce combat les personnels soignants
devraient être mieux considérer mieux
rémunérés également
les personnels soignants dont fo mieux
considérer effectivement est beaucoup
mieux rémunérés quand aujourd'hui vous
avez un salaire net qui a pau qui
approvisionne ce qui est à peu près à
1200 1300 euros pour douze heures de
travail tous les jours
avec une charge de travail aux
énormes on constate même et on a pu le
constater par le passé et on le constate
toujours que les accidents de travail
pour s'avancer sanaa le milieu du swing
et que pensez vous alors il ya de
l'argent puisque les les sociétés
privées en tout cas font des bénéfices
on l'avait vu alors dû lors du premier
confinement des bénéfices redistribués
aux actionnaires ce qu'est ce que ça
vous inspire
mais on commercialise notre santé madame
voilà ce que ça m'inspire c'est comme
pour mieux commercialiser notre santé et
notre avenir notre retraite et que ses
actionnaires berry devrait tous les
matins l'argent on regarde et
l'argentine sur leur compte c'est la
sueur et la maltraitance et déjà le
connecteur pour qui le gagne et se fixe
et ça c'est inadmissible
qu'est ce qu'il faudrait faire qu'est ce
que vous demandez au gouvernement at il
les moyens d'agir au niveau des groupes
privés
bien sûr qu'il a le moyen âge y va parce
que le gouvernement distribue des
dividendes c'est à ces entreprises il
est il leur donne des de l'argent pour
qu'ils puissent exercer alors on va leur
demander izard est de donner de l'argent
aux établissements privés mais qu'ils
amènent plus au public et pour que le
public et s'agrandissent et qu'on arrête
de bannir la santé mary sont bannis
c'est plutôt la charité privée pardon
davantage d'établissements publics c'est
ce que vous réclamez donc c'est ce qu'on
réclame et de contrôle merci beaucoup et
merci et la carrière d'avoir répondu ce
matin prix en direct à nos questions sur
rt france
et c'est la fin de cette matinale merci
à vous pour votre fidélité la matinale
revient lundi pas demain
exceptionnellement lundi même heure même
place je vous souhaite un très très bon
week-end sur notre antenne bonne femme
semaine
[Musique]
le résultat d'un dieu peut réserver bien
des surprises pour mieux comprendre où
vous aideront à y voir clair
[Musique]
le travail de julian et de wikileaks
nous a montré toute une série de
meurtres la corruption la profonde
criminalité des états unis et de leurs
alliés de l'otan
ce sa page de réputation qui a commencé
quasiment immédiatement après la
publication des irakiens warlogs
l'isolent de la société
le new york times
le washington post
der spiegel
ils ont tous publié exactement la même
chose
mais la violence du royaume uni et de
ses agents
cela donne la nausée
aviez vous été surpris que ces organes
de presse qui ont publié ces
informations se soit ensuite retournés
contre julian
et bien non pas vraiment 1 je dirais
déçu oui mais pas surpris
la partie pacifique de l'expédition
autour du monde
[Musique]
5 milliers de miles nautiques
24 heures sur 24
et des requins et un calme de mort dans
ce cas la chine ne s'est pas passé comme
nous l'avions prévu tous les pays sont
fermées
la peur du coc vide est encore plus
forte ici
l'équipage en recherche de nourriture et
d'eau potable
nous n'avons pas eu l'opportunité de
récupérer de l'eau douce nous avons
attendu la pluie elle est arrivée mais
nous n'avons récupéré que deux litres et
demi
a fait peur à tout le monde tout le
monde est confiné il ne nous reste
presque rien ni eau ni nourriture
maintenant les marins de santa isabel
ont déchiré les revêtements des
structures pour rire du pain à partir de
restes de mouches
en pleine période de coronavirus vivre
comme les marins d'antan mais au 21ème
siècle
[Musique]
c'était un grand chercheur un grand
homme
[Musique]
un homme au destin tragique sous
je lui dit qu'est ce que c'est voit deux
coups de pied et les côte se ressoude
comme ça
plusieurs prix nobel ont été attribués à
partir des théories viraux génétique de
zilber
est de mon point de vue elle avait 20 25
en avance sur les capacités d'alors de
la science expérimentale
en travaillant dans la taïga il a
découvert l'étiologie de l'encéphalite à
tiques et tout ce qui est lié à cette
maladie et après ça la prison c'était
horrible mais il était
exceptionnellement résistants on l'a
toujours admiré
qu'est ce qui pousse tout simplement un
apnéiste à vouloir touchées les abymes
le but ultime c'est pas forcément de
gagner des médailles web podium m6
d'arriver à gérer ses émotions dans un
certain vendre et c'est un univers qui
me permet justement d'aller encore plus
loin dans cet état d'introspection et de
travail sur le corps et aussi sur
l'esprit plus on va être dans l'instant
présent plus on va être capable de gérer
ce qu'on en a à faire est concentré sur
ce que l'on fait et a confiance et la
capacité à vivre l'instant présent à
être connectés que sur ce qui se passe
sur les sons sur le toucher sur le
ressenti et ça nous pousse dans les
retranchements à changer des choses dans
notre propre vie en dehors de la cne
[Musique]
je suis habitué à vivre dans la toundra
à la liberté et aux rênes
oh
[Musique]
quand j'étais à l'école primaire en ce1
deux amis et moi même nous sommes enfuis
du pensionnat on est allé dans la
toundra
[Musique]
dans la toundra il n'y a que des
moustiques je ne comprends pas comment
les gens peuvent-ils vivre
comment pourrais-je envoyé mon enfant à
l'internât je n'en dormirais plus la
nuit
donc quand ils font face à l irréel ils
n'ont aucune idée comment se débrouiller
il quitte l'école sans expérience
[Musique]
et
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire je reçois aujourd'hui
maurizio serra de l'académie française
pour son livre le mystère mussolini qui
a reçu le grand prix de la biographie
politique
on va passer toute cette émission sur
celui que vous présentez comme le plus
6001 de tous les dictateurs du 20e
siècle le moins facile à cerner mais
commençons par une image et plutôt trois
images celles que vous avez choisi pour
symboliser notre époque voici la
première
qui existe en plusieurs langues qu'est
ce qu'elle vous évoque ses 10 et bien
évidemment il ya une différence
considérable entre les deux sujets
pourtant populisme peuple peuple c'est
la base de la démocratie et donc il
pourrait y avoir quelque chose qui les
rassemble plutôt collet que les diviser
mais il faudrait passer par la raison la
responsabilité et le réalisme les 3r qui
manque souvent populiste la deuxième
image
s'est elle est bien l'opportunité
immense que les nouvelles technologies
l'audiovisuel donne à l'enseignement des
enfants mais connaîtront-ils la réalité
resteront ils dans le virtuel et surtout
lire ont-ils des livres oui c'est une
question qu'on posait déjà mais
génération qui aiment regarder la
télévision et c'est vrai que d'ailleurs
moins regarder mais de gens lisaient que
ne qu'il n'y en avait qui regardaient la
télévision troisième image plus
énigmatique et bien c'est l'image qui
était prise je crois sur une
représentation d'un opéra de luigi nono
et finalement c'est la beauté qui est
prisonnière qui a engagé et c'est un peu
le signe de notre temps je crois que
nous avons besoin de plus de beauté et
d'au moins deux cages
et bien commençons
[Musique]
non ici au cera vous êtes le premier
italien à avoir été élu à l'académie
française c'était en 2020 vous êtes
diplomate historien écrivain vaudois des
biographies de marinetti de mal à partes
d'italo svevo de d'annunzio est
maintenant de mussolini aux éditions
perrin vous l'avez intitulé le mystère
mussolini pourquoi il y aurait un
mystère mussolini alors qu'il n'y aurait
pas de mystère hitler ou une mystère
staline pour trois raisons
essentiellement la première c'est que
l'homme étant finalement comedia
comédiens nietzsche et a donc un
comédien tragique a tellement de
retomber dans sa vie qu'il aurait pu
avoir prendre des chemins très
différents
alors que si vous prenez un hitler
staline et à cap
particulier vous voyez que du début à la
fin c'est un jusqu'au boutiste dans une
seule direction l'idéologie même chez
muslim y est extrêmement mouvante
première raison
deuxième raison du mystère et du côté
sibyllin du dictateur c'est que
contrairement à l'image et aux poncifs
qu'on en a d'un personnage très évident
évident entre m ubuesque parfois un peu
grotesque c'est un homme extrêmement
rentrée c'est un homme qui n'a jamais
d'interlocuteurs il n'est jamais même
entourée d'une petite monde comme hitler
ou staline le sort dans le caddie clair
c'était d'ailleurs dangereux docteur
dans ce petit monde parce que on risque
de ne pas survivre
donc tout est replié en lui mais n'a pas
d'amis dites vous des regrets c'est lui
qui l'a dit dit locale oui le dis parce
qu'évidemment disons lui à côté même
romantique de la solitude du pouvoir
mais c'est une réalité est évidemment
c'est un cas
houde dans lequel il fini et c'est le
troisième fois par oublier le réalisme
qui a été sa grande ressource de
politiciens au début et au fur et à
mesure il s'enlise dans une sorte de
château des mystères dans un dans un
village potemkine il ne voit plus la
réalité ni de son pays ni de l'europe
réalisme dit vous-même pourtant
vous dites qu'ils mentaient tout le
temps et notamment pour conquérir le
pouvoir de mensonges qu'il va utiliser à
l'époque l'idée d'une d'une italie trahi
par ses alliés après la première guerre
mondiale qui on aurait volé son son
butin de guerre donc sa victoire et puis
sur le risque d'une révolution
bolchévique en italie qui d'après ce que
vous dites n'est jamais existé non d'un
les deux sont certainement des mensonges
ou en tout cas des dissimulations parce
qu'en lot par lot de mensonge nous
parlons toujours d'une dimension
politique sur laquelle les prépare une
plateforme
d'ascencio pouvoir
la première c'est un fait les
nationalistes hélas même dan woods
exploite l'idée de la victoire mutilé
par la mauvaise volonté des alliés ce
n'est pas vraiment le cas disons que
grosso modo 80% des buts de guerre
débute pour lesquels l'italie était
entré en guerre du côté des alliés sont
obtenus à l'afad là à l'afad du conflit
d'autre part l'autre la fragilisation
par des remous ball chez visant c'est
quelque chose qui a lieu au bon moment
surtout de l'occupation des usines in du
nord en 1919 20 mai largement résolue
avant l'ascension de mussolini et avant
la marche se robe donc il n'y avait pas
de risque
pour nous et rangez vous l'avez rappelé
il ya un côté très théâtral bouffon chez
miche et mussolini que chaplin
d'ailleurs a magnifié dans le dictateur
on se souvient de la prestation de dzeko
qui on va retrouver son visage et
missoni c'est quelqu'un qu'on voit le
torse bombé
le menton relevé
à la fois martial il se voulant un
vulnérables on se dit que c'est une
espèce de césar de carnaval et on trouve
demande comment ça a pu marcher auprès
des italiens oui justement c'est une
question que je me pose souvent je pense
qu'elle parle quand même d'un certain
même si vous voulez d'un certain poncifs
parce que au fond nous avons un homme
qui reste pouvoir pendant 20 ans toutes
les images comme eux pas ce sont des
images des années 30 et surtout de la
deuxième moitié des années 30 ou même le
port constant de l'uniforme uniforme
sans grade d'ailleurs est la conséquence
de la militarisation du pays qui doit se
préparer à la guerre mais à les voir
toutes les photos de mousseline y des
années 20 jusqu'à la boîte et des années
30 et vous voyez un homme d'état qui est
certainement non démocrates cela va sans
dire mais qui est quand même
l'interlocuteur des personnages de son
temps et de son époque
donc il faut quand même remettre ça dans
la perspective de la longue durée du
régime ce qui évidemment est
particulièrement difficile en france
j'aime bien je bois de problèmes quand
j'en parle avec des amis espagnols vu la
longue durée du fascisme du franquisme
ou des eaux des amis même russe vu la
longue durée du bolchevisme mais le
fascisme français n'est de deux facteurs
la défaite et l'occupation qui n'ont
rien à voir et en plus se concentre une
période heureusement très rigoureux ce
qui n'a rien à voir avec loewen tenir du
bushisme italien et c'est vrai que là on
le voit il est en 1926 il
c'est le même
il est irritant civile voilà il est en
civil
mais vous n'avez pas entendu caisse
comme moi est ce que les italiens
qu'être subjugué par mussolini écoutez
je crois qu'il y à trois facteurs qui
jouent évidemment c'est une question qui
n'a pas encore de réponse et vous
trouverez
les
réactions les plus variés chez les
chercheurs
et chez les auteurs en italie peu
partout par celle qui est hélas
pourrait-on dire la moins importante des
trois c'est la répression parce qu'il ya
certainement une répression forte le
contrôle de la police le contrôle
d'un même de l'emploi qui est également
quelque chose de très important la
corruption qui joue
tout cela mais finalement il y a
surtout au début une conviction assez
large je ne dirais pas majoritaire parce
que nous n'avons pas mes instruments qui
puisse nous le dire nous ne faut pas la
possibilité de sondages ou autre que
quand même l'homme fait n'oubliez pas
l'union des trois forces essentielles de
la société italienne de son époque la
monarchie l'église et l'état oui
effectivement
il conduit lui-même son alfa romeo et
autres bolides il pilote son avion
il se donne
en tout cas au début mais même même à
cette époque là l'image de l'homme
nouveau l'homme futuriste d'ailleurs on
a souvent lié le fascisme des premiers
temps avec le futurisme italien il se
met vous dit qu'il n'est pas si moderne
que cela au fond là parce qu'il ya une
contradiction l'homme est pétri de
contradictions
le mais pétrie d'ailleurs même sur
l'image son image d' esbroufe d'image de
deux grandes de comment dirais-je
d'assurance physique et est l expression
de quelqu'un qui est intimement fissures
et lacérés de doute et de contradictions
et alors dans le cas spécifique où il
est moderne c qui comprend qu'il faut
bien qu'il faut qu'il y ait une autre
image une image mise en interne jeunes
de la politique et donc qu'ils soient
sportives qu'ils soient linverse de ce
que les croulants hommes politiques de
la vieille europe ont produit lors de la
pré peuple de la veille et pendant la
grande guerre ça doit être le premier
qui s'exhibe torse nu déjà vote sans
doute à côté de cela il y a le côté nos
modernes parce que il y a des limites
culturel pourtant c'est un intellectuel
quoi qu'on puisse dire il a des limites
forte il ne comprend pas par exemple la
force puis sorte qu ont les moyens de
communication oui